[Music]
thank you
thank you hey everyone just wanted to
say a big congrats to the Lords on 300th
episode that is amazing it takes a lot
of work and dedication to put the show
together every week
and to do 300 of them is really
outstanding
I feel incredibly lucky and fortunate to
have played a small role in a few of
those episodes
I I wanted to make a special thank you
to Lord Cognito for reaching out to me
initially a vote under the end
and asked me to join uh up uh on the
Lord's podcast I think was 2019. it was
a very cool moment
I I think my favorite moment ever uh uh
with the Lords it's got to be talking
about old Sega games games like zillion
games that uh as uh we all get older uh
less and less of us know about and have
played
uh to to talk about
those experiences with with people like
me folks that have played those games
and and that's really where they fell in
love with games uh that's a really
special moment and uh yeah it was just
great to talk about you know things like
zillion and and Shinobi and and punch
out and and all the memories uh that you
go through as a kid getting introduced
to uh to gaming and that's really where
I fell in love with games and and
started you know in some small way
thinking about making games
so uh that yeah that meant a lot
um
big congrats on 300th episode
I'm sure there'll be 300 more if not
thousands more you guys do amazing work
essential work covering games from Indie
titles to to AAA titles and everything
in between uh That's essential to gaming
I appreciate it as a Creator Sarah
appreciates it as a Creator I know many
other creators appreciate it as well uh
podcasts like
the Lord's really are essential for
gaming and uh so so big thank you and
thanks for asking me to to come on and
just say a little quick hello uh sorry I
can't be there in person
Sarah and I are away traveling but uh
yeah big congrats again 300 episodes
absolutely amazing all the best
[Music]
go out there boys and just get your
breath
300 yeah well done boys and this is just
the beginning no matter how great
David's beard gets go out there and keep
killing it now just got a very Colin in
the yard
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you
hey everybody uh this is Ivan AKA
Anchorman V2
I want to say thank you for giving me
the opportunity to speak for you guys on
episode 300 of iron Lords podcast
I will say it's been a rare privilege to
having been able to see these guys
before they were iron Lords podcast uh I
got to see the clay be molded and the
raw Parts come together uh look I knew
Cog before he thought he was somebody I
remember addict and I sitting in parties
talking about YouTube drama every day
um I remember listening to King David's
absolute slanderous heresy about Hulk vs
Superman just look so these are the
funnest funniest conversations I still
remember to this day
um I'm definitely not gonna make the
claim that uh it was my idea for them to
do a podcast that's just not true in the
first place
um I will say though I did see potential
I will say that much um whenever Cognito
invited me to the channel 5 group I saw
how these guys interacted with each
other and I watched them grow and get
better
as not only you know podcasters but as
people
um I remember the video as I actually
remember the night specifically whenever
they kind of made the decision or at
least got the wheels turning to start a
podcast I had just gotten off of a shift
working at the grocery store
um I used to close there and I got off
work picked up some food and then went
back to my apartment and would eat
dinner and play Minecraft and talk when
parties with these guys and just laugh
my ass off for a couple hours and just
was absolutely a blast loved all of it
um and I remember somebody I don't
remember who exactly but somebody said
wow this would be a great podcast and I
do remember
specifically saying yes that would be a
great idea definitely do this let's make
this happen
I remember supporting and I do remember
that much at least
um
I don't think I had any swear of their
decision but I like to think that it
helped
um oh my gosh I remember so many other
times specifically I remember having
discussions about branding
um Lord zero having to push these guys
to stick with it when the numbers
weren't good initially which that part
wasn't really that hard because these
guys are very driven from the get-go so
um I remember implementing the hard no
cursing or the the language policy so I
remember that
um I remember coming up with a four
horsemen stick for the Lord's day
um I was just such a funny one-off thing
I'm so glad they kept it around
um
I remember I was doing that when I was
promoting tick Network at the time
um I remember the destiny Intervention
episodes I remember going to E3 with
these guys and partying at the Bethesda
party for E3 2016. I remember filling
out like filling in the pinch like
I watched the refiner of these guys over
the years
um I know I only I can only really speak
for myself but I'm pretty confident that
our late brother uh Lenwood who passed
away last year
um if or AKA kalal for those who don't
know from tick podcast I'm pretty
confident that a year around he would
say uh he'd be very proud of you
um for not like
I mean mainly for the the Foster
community that you guys have had over
the years that you've built up here but
as well as like you know picking up the
torch of the Common Man you know
sticking to the media Giants of this
industry showing that you guys can you
know get interviews and that not like
they're doing the whole Spirit of any
man can do this but not just any man can
you look at the end of the day it just
boils down to Brotherhood I mean you
guys guys have been friends for a long
ass time uh you guys can feel it on the
show and that that's really the main
selling point of iron Lord's podcast I
mean that's it's always come down to
Brotherhood that no matter how how
annoying your brother can be that no
matter how much they uh get on your
nerves or how much success they have
that at the end of the day these are
people that you can trust they have your
back
and
they're always going to support you
so uh congratulations on 300 episodes
for iron Lords podcast
I'm proud of you guys uh here's to many
more episodes
have a good day
[Music]
thank you
what's up guys welcome this is 300
episodes of arguably the best gaming
podcast in our community the iron Lords
podcast what is going on man hope you
guys doing well big cloud here
um let me just go ahead and get right
into this man shout out to of course
these crew you know Lord David Cognito
Sovereign and of course addict shout out
to you guys and of course everybody at
logging it
um you know there's so much I can say
about this show there's a lot of stuff I
can literally just put out here but this
is going to turn into something very
very you know like a long video and I
don't want to do that I'm just going to
celebrate this awesome moment with my
family right here first of all I got a
shot of you the person who's watching
this do me who's your favorite man give
yourself a round of applause we made the
300 episodes and we wouldn't have made
it here without your support I
appreciate y'all I love seeing the chat
love seeing our everybody's engaged make
sure you guys hit that like button make
sure you guys hit that subscribe button
if you are new to this platform why do I
love IOP it's very very simple I've been
on a a ton of podcasts throughout my
YouTube Journey a lot of them some have
been chaotic some have been controlled
and some have just been a flat out mixed
bag and some have just been one of those
random situations where you don't even
know where it's going to go I Ops Vibe
is something that just can't be matched
it really really is it's that special
when you come on IOP you don't feel
pressured you don't have no weird vibe
no if you love gaming it doesn't matter
what your preference is you're always
welcome here and you feel welcome and
that's one thing I love about this show
you always have you have fun you might
go in here with like second guessing
yourself especially if you're a first
timer but then you'll leave one to come
back on instantly it is that type of
vibe at this particular show it's
literally run by some of the coolest
people coolest most down-to-earth people
that you can find on this planet and
literally it has won the most humble guy
on the planet with uh Laura Cognito as
your host this show is going to continue
to go uh you know it's going to continue
to go places it's going to continue to
prosper and I'm very proud of these guys
man I've been watching you know uh God
now I really think about it but watching
the show stay real at like 12 Subs it's
amazing to see them go from 12 Subs to
where they are now the community that
they that they have built and the
overall love they have for this industry
and where they continue to go words
can't describe how you know proud I am
of my brothers I can't wait to see them
in the real we're going to make that
moment happen very very soon but I just
want to say thank you guys again for
this awesome awesome like milestone
we couldn't be here without y'all and of
course much love to lure Cognito you
already know what's going on with big
cloud so I you're enough Yuri knows
what's up but I appreciate y'all thank
you guys so much I hope you guys enjoy
this awesome episode the next stop of
course is Episode 600 and onwards y'all
be good I'm out
[Music]
thank you
yo what up this is BG I just want to
give a quick shout out to everybody in
the iron Lords podcast and congratulate
y'all on making it to 300 episodes which
is not an easy feat so congratulations
to solve addict David Incognito y'all
get up there every Sunday which takes
dedication you know energy
um to just you know deliver on the
entertainment every Sunday and y'all got
the chemistry y'all got the Synergy and
y'all do it every Sunday and y'all do it
really well especially when y'all be
going like six seven hours it seems
sometimes and you know the stress and
the weight of making it to 300 episodes
seems to really be getting to David with
all the Grays this thing is really like
aging him faster than Obama in the Oval
Office so salute to y'all man I know
y'all gonna keep going Y'all Gonna Make
it to like 400 500 all that good stuff
so keep doing what y'all doing proud of
y'all boys man peace
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
oh hey what's up hey Lord sorry I
couldn't make it to the show but I just
wanted to say happy 300 episodes that is
in insane Milestone you guys should be
really proud I love the podcast I love
what you guys do I just think it's
important to have Independent Media
completely what you guys are doing it's
your own brand it's your own thing it's
getting bigger and everybody there is
genuine I've been lucky to meet most of
you and you're all fantastic so keep
killing it that's it I'm gonna try and
be on the show soon addict I also owe
you a DM I'm sorry but I love you guys
I'll see you soon be well
[Music]
please
foreign
mixer podcast and I would like to say a
huge congratulations to the iron Lords
for 300 episodes
uh the iron Lords to me aren't just an
awesome podcast
but they are friends they helped Inspire
and create the midweek mix-up and what
we are today
um again I fully appreciate everything
that both lordcognito
uh King David
addict Sovereign and all of the iron
Lords team do and from behind the scenes
all the way through to the live shows
you see every Sunday
um and throughout the week
like I say the the more than just
podcasters the the very close friends
and appreciate everything that they've
done for us over the three years that
I've been around here and over the many
years and that they've been there but
for the iron Lords this is uh is just
the beginning
we've got an awesome bunch of shows uh
spanning from a whole host of awesome
creators again
Lord Cognito King David Sovereign addict
and all of the lognet team as well
um shout out to all of you guys huge
congratulations again this is just the
start of still bigger and better things
to come from you guys
so congrats and uh have a great show
see you later
[Music]
thank you
first of all I'd like to say
congratulations to the iron Lord podcast
salute to you guys this is going to be
your 300th episode salute to you been a
big fan been watching you guys for
probably four or five years now been
fellowshipping with you guys salute the
king Cognito solve and of course my
brother like no other Lord addict
um been watching the podcast been
actually on the podcast ton of fun I
love you guys chemistry
um I love the camaraderie I love the
personalities that you guys have each of
your own melded together it's a podcast
like no other salute to you guys stay
Kings
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
what's going on everybody it's Lord
Chris your boy scene at one two three
one two three Michael Jordan a log net I
wanted to stop by iops 300th episode and
leave you with this message there's not
a better group of friends than King
coxav and attic King Cog sov u3
Implement what it means to be lifelong
friends joined together by something as
amazing as your love for video games and
just your love for being together I
posted a picture on Twitter of you three
together at the arcade at the versus
arcade and it reminded me of how close
me and my friends are
join together by something that we love
to do as well so you three are
Inspirations to everybody out there
lifelong friends joined together by
something that we love an addict
you are an amazing individual that does
not get the credit you deserve people
don't realize how much work you put into
ILP
and the whole brand in general so for me
to you addict I appreciate you I'm glad
to have met all four of you at PAX East
you made me comfortable you welcomed me
in
I can't wait to see you guys all again
do it all over and obviously have some
young talk with the attic because you
know me and Adam are kind of the younger
people of the group but I appreciate all
four of you pillars of positivity in The
Gaming Community
and uh you guys brought me in you
treated me like family and for
everything you've done for me I'm
forever grateful and I'll never be
forgotten
salute
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you I was asked to say a couple
words about the iron Lord's hidden
podcast number 300 I didn't have any
video equipment up so here's a quick
video that didn't take me very long
first up thank you to Lord Sovereign one
of the nicest dudes you're ever going to
talk to about games he loves old school
titles and he'll listen almost any
opinion and give it a stew he's also one
of the nicest guys I think I've ever
talked to he would have to be to take
the back and forth ribbing he and King
give each other I'm pretty sure one time
it took me two hours after a podcast to
realize we disagreed on something then
there's Lord addict now addict is the
first of the iron Lords I got to talk to
that's like the first exhibit at the zoo
being the ape that they don't let out
when the kids are around the dude is as
nuts as I am loves his games and is one
of the funniest guys I've ever got a
chance to talk to a genuine amazing dude
and his excitement for gaming is
legendary to me then there's King what
can I say the dude eats Breeze and
probably goes to the bathroom and leaves
little bits of games in there true story
when King was born a umbilical cord was
a Sega Genesis controller and he can do
the Konami Code with an Atari 2600 one
button controller few people are as over
the top and as energetic as king is and
that's a sad thing for gaming but a
great thing for anyone who wants to make
sense of the world and I'm pretty sure
God made sure that east and west coast
existed purely to make sure King and I
aren't in the same room at the same time
because that's just too much extra for
everybody amazing guy to talk to
hilarious and his energy is infectious
he also has an awesome toy collection
though he calls them stats choose last
but not least of course Lord Cog you
could call him the leader but that would
indicate that these guys are able to
follow anybody anywhere that's the thing
though cogs got the skills as far as
anyone does in the industry listen to
his intro for guests if Cog was a WWE
wrestler his name would be mic drop and
McMahon would just make every wrestler
walk out to him talking if he isn't
talking about games he's posting
pictures of late night workouts on
social media like The Rock's little
brother Boulder all kidding aside though
he has an amazing dude a guy who knows
his games knows how to lead this rabble
and always wants everybody on the
podcast to get their say no matter how
batshit insane they are in every way the
iron Lords are like the world's scariest
Pokemon each one awesome with their own
traits but as the saying goes you really
do need to catch them all peace out guys
and I hope to see you at 600.
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
welcome to the iron Lords podcast I got
my fellow Lords here we're gonna go
ahead and start this number 10 number
20. number 30 number 40. so 50 but 60 70
but 80 but 90 episode 100
110. number one twenty one Thirty One
forty
[Music]
welcome to the iron Lords podcast
my check my check
hello Realm hello panel Lord's Brethren
everyone the leader mike check welcome
Kyle p300 hello hello I'm still watching
thank you so much I do appreciate it I
was up to date until Sovereign jumped in
and then he had to push me back I'm
listening to a wonderful ACG speaks so
eloquently about us I'm going back to
what I'm listening so you just not gonna
be a part of it
shall we wait for you to catch up
to the realm
oh man oh I don't even know what to say
um 300 episodes y'all 300 300 of these
things man um you know I hope you guys
like the little thing we put together
just to kind of give perspective I want
to do a little different you know um
attic man I love you bro like last night
we was talking about how did this thing
might go and and just um you know what
we wanted to kind of represent with the
journey and um I want to give you your
flowers man that was that was really fun
it was really fun going through the
archives and seeing our journey and
where we begin the co-host with the
co-host how you feeling man 300 episode
before before I even give it to you
we got to raise the toast right now we
gotta raise it we got to do a little
Royal talks right now io3 300 episodes
y'all we've been doing this a long time
man we do a lot and we are still here we
still love to do it that's the most
beefy yeah thing I've ever seen in my
life I had to get a really long yeah you
got to say pause
this so he could oh he could pause it
I'm not gonna jump I'm not gonna be
listening to you talk about that
you're not feeling the most beefiest
I vote to misappropriate podcast fun to
get chalices for everyone
I'm telling my wife to bring down my
challenge I'm breaking protocol there
may or may not be Advanced
there may or may not be Advanced but hey
let's go honey bring me my challenge
bring forth the challenge
look man 300 episode I am so proud
addict talk about it man 300 what does
it mean to you man like where you at
with this
man 300 so I'm still doing this like
what's going on what's wrong with us
it's like you know we have been ups and
downs clearly you know when it comes to
call to create people don't see they
just see the finished product they don't
see us being like yo there's only 15
people in it there's been only 15 people
in it for six months actual uh you know
I think I think we need to wrap this up
wasting too much time you know we push
through that then we had the
low-key replacing previous lures with
the new Lords and you know we felt like
that might start stuff let's say they
name Lord Sleek Lord SWAT the original
original iron Lord sleeves
save me another
more Mead
what made but it was only a fledgling
Destiny podcast that's what this was and
at that time we had to figure out our
way
we had to bench that garbage
so I remember from there you know one
thing I do want to like point out uh
probably my most misguided thing that's
ever been on the show is is that I got a
I got to tilt my head off the king
because I didn't think the merchandise
would blow the way it did and when when
King was fighting over the merchandise
and the shirts and stuff I was on the
other end I was like dude we don't need
none of that not just you
remember about the country at it we saw
he's like bro this budget that can't do
it we don't know
these shirts he going we just getting
out the gate with a little so we we
gonna be out of here before it started
he was like this shit's gonna run 1200
hours
cost us two grand yeah those shirts
close to us two thousand four hundred
and some changes because they cost 770
each yeah
we send it then I had to ship it to Cali
yes remember when so I shipped it to
Cali and I had to drive to the hood the
hood shout out shout out to the hood
hood shout out to the whole Cali family
yes I went out there
and then drove deeper into Compton
Crenshaw Dave uh uh slasher swap meet
facts handing them out handed out all
the shirts to everybody over there so if
you saw me at the convention center
after that that was after I went to
every gang set
every uh person on the street every
common person yeah I gave out shirts did
and then I went to give out shirts to
people online you know what the wildest
the people online
was the most stuck up people
[Music]
um
I was looking through the member only
content which we might go ahead and make
some of that public and it was literally
you going through strong arm of these
people yeah
and then there's this one chick that was
like he said oh thank you and then she
didn't grab but he's like you're gonna
take it though right
the wildest thing is see the attic
remembers that part so I'm in the hood
I'm in my hood by myself uh like
probably where we're at that time that I
can't believe it something in the
Corvette and I'm popping the trunk on
people
they taking the shirts oh what's up big
bro that's what's up you're giving that
out big bro big bro so I'm handing out
the shirt yeah cuz give me a shirt coz
yeah
shirts right see so but when I get to
the convention center for people that's
on the line looking for free stuff yeah
oh
yeah the biggest thing that is so weird
that ended up like obviously like Domino
effecting into like the merchandise the
uh the Teespring doing the pack shirts
doing the E3 shirts but I I would ever
forget watching one of those Arena
things at E3 a couple years ago and
seeing a chick asking I think it was
Kojima a question or something like that
about a game and she had our shirt on
yes yes remember sorry it's like little
things like that man you know uh what
they are I gotta hand off to to solve is
like just just keeping me realistic
oh so Thomas I I most of the time
approach solve with ideas first because
I kind of get a general sense of
direction if I should go to the other
two so I was like yeah it's a video
I don't think that's gonna work yeah
it's a yeah I have the grounded
mentality which isn't always the best
like I it keeps me safe and happy but I
don't know that everybody likes thinking
that way yeah it's a nice French yeah
that's right and yeah I need to Reign
King in sometimes I'm off the farm
quick question for you because I was
very very curious you know you you came
in mid-atic look it was like probably
like episode 10 or something like that
right that was the guest appearance that
was a guest appearance right because you
would have guessed first and then yeah
so like when you got a part of this
you know saying like what was your
thought process as far as what oh boy
the Super Chat for you but we're gonna
talk about that later
um but like what was your thought
process joining the podcast and then
like just in general like what was your
favorite moments of our journey either
in personal on show it was just for me
like first of all like you said shout
out to sleet and SWAT um just in that
whole vibe by the time I came on you
guys had already transitioned to just be
a general games podcast you started that
already right so what it was is you was
doing the general gaming the iron Lords
gaming and we were still doing iron
Lords podcast too but then we got I
don't even remember we were doing the
book because I know we looked at them
all y'all okay okay SoundCloud snitched
us all up after after a certain amount
of time we just ditched the game and
went straight out and went straight to
iron Lords okay because I remember being
on it I remember the first thing I
talked about the first show that I was
on was Resident Evil 7. okay and and
back then it's like you know you don't
know how to talk on a mic or whatever
and I'm talking and I'm like I'm trying
to be really analytical and stuff and
that's just me generally but I was like
I listen to it again I'm like this is so
cringy because
right you need to be able to analyze
yeah you need to analyze and be
entertaining at the same time and I'm
like okay I'm trying to be somebody I'm
not I have to remember that I'm with my
friends I need to find myself again in
that space and it just I think it
happened one day without just me and
King going back and forth the way we
always did
there was a moment when IOP changed and
it was the rise of solve and I was just
like yo he's outside for me personally
if you take it by these every game award
show is getting on my nerves yeah every
prediction the first big like argument
me and soft had back to back uh back and
forth was that gears
he started saying oh I want this I was
like that's not here
it was that and it was the Red Dead
thing because red that he was like oh
the shooting sucks they messed it up I
was like they didn't mess it up
I remember going back and forth with
that yeah but I gotta say man I think
300 episodes
there are moments like when life really
tries to get in the way and and not make
this a thing faction they were they were
playing moments I don't even know that I
really shared them with you guys but you
guys have seen the stuff that I've gone
through behind the scenes like just you
know whatever is that there were moments
that I'd miss some kind of weeks on end
sometimes and I'm like oh man I don't
know if this can continue to happen it
just for me
what I really stepped back from it and
looked at it and really love about it is
that I get a chance to see my friends I
get a chance to see my friends in a way
that before we started doing the podcast
I literally hadn't seen King in years
no reason just life and him doing his
thing me doing my thing same with Cog
very rarely that I see [__]
and it was just like I get a chance to
see my friends and capture that again in
a way that I never knew could be
possible anymore right and then just to
open me up I tend to be a person that
I'm very I'm reserved when it comes to
friendships I have my friends and you
know I don't think even today I don't
friends friends I probably could count
them all on less than two hands you're
like me you're very private reaction too
in that regard so so open me up kind of
to this new community and and to see
people that gave me in the community it
could be extra it could be very extra I
mean think about it you read every week
let's play with each other's joysticks
this year yeah and it's like it's giving
me a a different level of empathy for
people of just understanding where
people are coming from and kind of
getting me out of my bubble
um because despite being generally I am
kind of extroverted I used to be
introverted I'm extroverted but I still
sort of function within a certain bubble
of what I like and don't like and
whatever
and it's just like
seeing the amount of people that
gravitate to us and and the content and
and what I remember just one time
somebody DM me something specific about
and I can't remember his name right now
but he's telling me something about how
about his brother and how his brother
meant so much to him and his gaming
journey and
that was the first time that I saw that
what we do here matters in ways that we
can't even fathom sometimes and it's
just us here talking about gaming and
joking or whatever and that could make
somebody's day who's had the worst day
possible and to see that little bit of
power that you have there I I take that
very seriously and I and I really you
know I'm grateful for the people that
are here every single week to share this
with us
um because again it's just us being us
and the fact that we can get here and do
that and and to share that with
everybody and again like I said for me
the most selfish thing
is that I get to see my friends every
week which is something that for years
wasn't happening and I have new friends
again like I said when it comes to King
when it comes to you know Cog when it
comes to my brother Kai everybody who's
original iron Lords right channel five
channel five channel five
that's family that's all family and when
they when they say somebody's cool your
family and I said and for me that was
we're addict and it was hard for me to
add it because again I just spoke about
the bubble that I live in and I'm like
he's a younger kid he's excitable he
likes to be angry I don't know about
myself he'd like to be angry and I'm
like that's not really me and it's just
little by little just getting getting to
know an addict and just you know him
seeing him feeling more comfortable with
me confiding and meeting more things and
whatever it's just I love this dude and
then and I will repeat to the end of
time what everyone else repeats you guys
have no idea what he does for this show
to make it happen so
I love y'all I love y'all hits the 300
more read 100. let's go and talk about
the uh the Superstar of the group
look man we had a born
is a guess
and it's just that magic that that
Synergy the energy the the temperature
come up the volume come up you know we
should do one day like for like patreon
a member or something React to Old
content oh God bro when I listening
episode what do you know what I'm saying
I was like yeah I forgot attic was
hosting you know what I'm saying I was I
was that was a journey but now when King
came through I was just like yo this is
just magic right man like this is just
sometimes King doesn't realize like
after the show that I'm really
meticulous about this
every IOP I re-listen
and then I'll search for his parts
and I sit there watching IOP whether it
be in the car or whatever
and when he goes on a classic rant
it is like no other like it is literally
like Noah I will sit there I don't tell
him this like I'll be like yo daddy
that's him there you go
dig and I just and I literally entertain
myself in this before shorts before Tick
Tock before all that I would do that man
so like what is it man with you King
like how how did this thing come with
feel with you for as far as 300 and then
like what was kind of your your favorite
moments of inside the show outside the
show
um all right so
attic and I started different like me
and addict started playing Destiny the
main attic was doing our you know think
now I hear him talking about y'all doing
the podcast or whatever
and um like whatever I don't care
um and you know it's about Destiny uh me
and attic really clicked very early on
separately I didn't even know he knew
you oh this is the room room to kill
days yes
I didn't know that he knew him
I had a Yahoo email was for my for my um
my Xbox Live called room to kill
yahoo.com and for a while I was using it
and then I realized after one day where
a business associate asked for my email
I was like yeah I need to change that I
need to get a new year
when I have to write an email down and
explain why it's that email then yeah I
gotta make a new email
um um I'm super protective over this
dude because one I didn't get a chance
to see what he looked like yet right so
I didn't know that he was my height my
size and he could fight himself right I
didn't know I didn't know I'm protecting
a giant baby bear I didn't know this all
right I didn't notice this damn case but
um you know one dude that jumped out the
window and said something and I
I'm very different right you guys think
like I will put hands on them right so
but all these dudes on this panel is the
same dude just don't don't get it
twisted if you push them to that same
level they're all King
so and I see a lot of young guys getting
misconstructed yeah they get it twisted
we of the same oh this is why we rock
with each other we have the same elk
right and that's where the respect
coming
I've never had an issue ever with
anything ever in this life you know ever
that's the craziest thing like if we
ever had a disagreement it's so minor so
so minuscule it's so mundane we've never
had an issue so if we do drift apart
let's just drift apart and you know if
you're doing this let me come right back
so me and him has been
me and him share a lot of of underbelly
Dirty Secrets those late nights yes
the New York City Lights operating in
the shadows if I'm reading the Dark
Shadows of the underbelly of New York
City and it's never been a judgment nope
like it's never like it's what have I
have done he's never looked over me and
said nothing this is nothing there's
never been a judgment it's always been
uh operation with it with each other
like a like a brother like oh my God
like I'm cool like if something's really
troubling me
I can really just talk to him without uh
uh thinking oh he's gonna think this of
me like and then if you don't ever have
that individual in your life you don't
know how secure that feels like you
don't know how like I'm telling you like
the wildest thing and you can just call
them and talk to him and without their
judgment and he doesn't know how much
that means to be able to have that just
not to use it but to have that
individual in your life that you're able
to unload whatever troubles that you're
going through and be there be the he's a
be there dude yes
yeah let's talk about it
I effed up
you ever f'd up so bad that you knew you
after when you effed up and you said
some stuff that you couldn't take it
back but you thought you took it back
with the internet I'm stupid with the
internet right so I'm thinking I took it
back it did not know so you know how
when somebody call you out or something
and you lie about it no I didn't know
and it screenshotted and said it to me
the receipt news yeah yo
um
yeah I don't have much family
all right and then when you let's okay I
have a bunch of family
F those dudes
um they're not really family
I've learned over this journey over this
whole period of time
family isn't exactly just because you
have blood
family is the people that cul-de-sac
that group that you
feel family with
you you feel a sense of home
yeah there's a difference between being
related to someone and being a family
with someone yes Cog is my sense of home
love when I was buck
I got a way to him to get away from the
madness
every time
so girls that come and try to come in
between Saturdays I'll I'll break up
like nah
I know how much he means to me
in a sense of without him
y'all probably be hearing about some
wildest thing like I'm watching this
King Von documentary they'll probably be
like oh yeah yeah he is
um yeah he was that dude he was a wild
boy back in the day you know and and I
protect mine like yeah I I you when you
when you meet somebody and you go
through certain things and you claim
this person is is your person I really I
messed up so I I drove to him one thing
and I went to give him something and
that's when I realized he was a man
because you're not going to violate a
situation and just think it's okay just
like that
isn't this just not gonna happen you're
going there for that day yeah you're not
gonna you're not gonna do that and
you're going to you're going to learn
hardest thing in my life you ever drive
crying Drive crying drove crying
in a brand new Camaro
the Green Camaro the Green Camaro that
you pulled up I remember just let me
interject for a second I remember
playing intermediary yeah
during this time during this moment and
it was tough because I've never seen
King that way
and I've never seen Cog that angry
and it was a minute like you guys don't
know there was a minute there was no
combo and there was no middle ground to
be found I had to tell addict to history
too so he understood yeah like years or
nothing yeah there was no middle ground
to be found that was hard I've never
ever ever seen King so affected because
usually we're of the elk like effort and
and Cog was so hurt that he like he was
you know anybody talked to [__] now
stubbornness is not what comes to mind
but but he he was he was right in his he
was justified but there was just no
there was no looking past the anger yeah
so I will say this
it takes it took us growing up growing
up to really be like no we can't allow
this to continue this way and I don't
remember exactly again
telling 166th Street faithful faithful
two two cars approached at the same time
as fate would have it yeah
I'm sorry uh um I've seen him on TV
and
he was in a foreign place
not me never I've never been to
California
but I tell you this I heard that it's
crazy dangerous I heard that that you
know it's like the Bronx in the 80s to
me this is what I'm thinking yeah and I
said if anything ever happened to my
brother my my cousin my my family I
would never be able to live with myself
I said he's never going over there ever
again a date a day by itself ever ever I
don't care what it is and see the way my
job and my life is set up I can't be
away for now they know I'll be up all
night on the phones checking making sure
everybody doing whatever they supposed
to do I'm they said I don't even know
how the hell you operate how you sleep I
don't know what goes on with you it's
ridiculous but
I'd rather risk all of that than risk
him
so
whatever I gotta do
I'm gonna get there to get to this and
you know we start doing the show I don't
know which came first or whatever the
show is really secondary to to my love
for these guys
um the show just allows me to unwind
unpack for the week forget about
whatever it is for whatever hours and to
bond with you guys
this this is all the show is
uh if if you guys think anything is
funny and hilarious it's because of
these guys if you ever see me on other
people's shows people be like hey King
do your thing
go do this
for me monkey dance for me okay and it's
like well you know we come from that so
but it's like that's not how it works it
works with me feeding off an attic it
works with me feeding off a cop it works
for me feeding off of sovereign if you
ever hear me going on any of these rants
Cog is in the background tell them King
when that happened what's going on
for a long time I could not listen to
myself talk I could not listen to the
podcast back I would for a long time I
still like that I was like oh I can't
hear that dude
for like six years and I still can't
stay on the sound of my voice oh no
you're good bro but I gotta I gotta I
got a couple of DMS one dm really meant
probably absolute the world to me it was
Sith Lord yes and I didn't know because
we will always interact all the time
and Sith Lord
says that and I'm sorry for putting your
business out there said Lord it's got to
be a little bit detailed
he that he goes to dialysis and stuff
yeah
and he told me the times how long it
takes and all this stuff and
this guy gets and then he tells me I'm
going to work after them yeah yeah
whatever I'm going through in my life
I look inside my DMs I see because my
stuff is open I play video games with
people I'm a regular person so don't
don't you know you hang out with people
we hang out
but he grounds me
Sith Lord and other people ground me to
stay humble
to stay respectful
I respect every penny anybody donates I
respect any time that you put through
I respect everything but most of all I
truly respect the commitment that each
and every last person on this podcast
puts in I respect uh addicts
he puts in so much so much work so much
work I respect solve with these super
chats that he got to read today which is
going to be hilarious
I had an amazing voice I don't know what
to talk about oh thank you I appreciate
the voice I thought you were talking
about a specific Super Chat
and I respect cogs
Cog Works a thousand jobs like he's
really Jamaican
no he is the best lady I'm watching
Everybody try to copy
your intros I watched everybody I've
I've been on everybody's show I've
watched everybody try in vain to copy
how how you deliver
introducing the name they don't know
they don't they don't got the formula
at all because some dudes probably don't
got the wrestling background some dudes
don't got the boxing back they think
it's just wrestling it's boxing it's
wrestling it's MMA he took it all and he
formed him and then it's him so
and then how you control it
like how you control it you feel Jackson
in his prime
like you gotta make sure Jordan get the
rock but you got to make sure that
Rodman stay in control who you implies
and then you got this Centric you know
you know Sovereign any given day could
be Scotty he could be anything any any
given days he's like a specialist
yeah like a specialist three-pointed
then we have a lot of net yes I'm gonna
say to dizzy and I know I'm going along
a little bit Yeah I want to say the
dizzy
he gave of himself yeah
he he pulled us to the side and said you
know what this is failing yes I believe
in you guys and he's dealing with a
terminal
disease he's dealing with this so he
understands that I don't got enough time
to be playing around and um if we're
gonna make this happen we gotta make
this happen now
he's fighting but he understands the
reality of things and
he gave of himself
a hundred percent
that blew me away yeah
so and a bad game and shout out to
playback gaming yes anybody that came
through
uh log knit
shout out to the new Michael Jordan of
the Jazz
[Music]
uh Justin all these all these people
that Josh Josh everybody that work hard
Cog works on that side but we get a
chance to hang out with these dudes and
talk to these dudes and meet these guys
and
um the undead and every I voted for him
that I wouldn't approached
I was like we got to get him um
um I just I'm really humble and I
appreciate 300 means more to me than you
guys think because
um be honest with you um
without this I don't know what's up
without Cog I don't know where I'll be
without sovereign's uh help I don't know
a lot of things whatever want to be what
and then attic just came along at a
right time when I needed him the most
and um it just all accumulates into you
know one big Infinity Gauntlet so this
works that way so you know here's the
300 more 300 watts no doubt I'll say
some quick words as guests I know I'm
coming in and I know time is limited for
some but um yeah man you guys you know
hitting hard so we got to talk about it
um yeah I didn't know what this would be
I would never in a million years think
300 so it got it has to start with the
Xbox Live party chats it has to start
with Anchorman V it has to start with
addict and this room to kill guy kept
coming in the damn room being boisterous
and had these strong opinions and I'm
just like who is this young kid like why
is he nothing's changed yeah
and I'm just like why is he so strong
and fear but I like him he funny you
know what I'm saying kind of thing and
you know I never forget you know from me
E3 was the dream getting the VHS tape
you know and saying one day I want to
beat it you know kind of thing and I
remember during that time as king
brought up you know we're kind of all
distant we're all you know as far as
that me and kick it wasn't talking at
the time but sorry we know we were all
this we're older life draws apart and um
I remember saying if before I die I'm
going one of these and I took that trip
and I went out to you know I went out
dolo you know and it was the time of my
life you know I met so many people and
the ruler you know what I'm saying
Megatron was there L bugs um Inferno and
I remember sleeping in a Hollywood Bowl
a Beverly Hills Mall
Jeff for the opportunity to go to the
Xbox press conference because to me the
press conference was what about I didn't
know that E3 was even an option and then
um I was told hey guys that you know if
you guys stay you got to be rewarded I
remember the executives came out I
remember the great Bill Stillwell who at
the time no one knew who he was you know
said about the pad and obviously Phil
and the team came out everyone came out
that was the year back that was
announced yes 2015. so I came out there
and I remember putting the pictures up
on Facebook and I remember
all the channel five because we were
channel five before we all pick and um
everybody said oh my God yo and Kate hit
me like yo bro you never going out there
dodo like that ever again you know kind
of thing and then was as we fast forward
and IOP now's form I mean I know the
history but like I remember one of my
moments with addict I'll never forget
and I'm probably trying not to tear up
but the moment I had an attic when I
think he realized you know it's a
Brotherhood here
is trying to convince him to get on a
plane for the first time
and try to get him I'm like brother I
want to change your life I want you to
see I'm telling you you're gonna have
the most fun you ever had just come out
to E3 don't worry about it we got you
and he did it he trusted me he did it
and he came out and our dream was
shattered as far as the Xbox fan FS
we're doing a raffle all of a sudden
that at that moment I had his fate in my
hand because it was a raffle it was it
wasn't a guaranteed thing like it always
had been prior and I ended up getting
the winning ticket
and it was that was the end of the
situation so it's either me or him at
this point
and I gave him my ticket and I said no
brother like you've got to go I've
already seen this before I've done I I
don't mind sitting this out because I
know what you sacrifice and I saw it in
his eyes like we were brothers at that
moment you know what I'm saying he he
got rid of emotions you had me the
ticket like I didn't want to take it I
feel very uncomfortable
he's like what am I going to owe this
dude
but tell them how God works
because I do this sacrifice that for my
brother and literally the executives
come out we say we're doing an
additional you know rant or what have
you a raffle drawing for some more
additional doubles for the chance to get
into the show and at that point
they call the number the other number
that I had and I was able to get it no
no that that's not how it went down
after I won after he won I handed him my
ticket then he won my ticket then he
handed that to another person
twice
three times okay so so then he had that
person's ticket he won another stuff
it's meant to be
and then it was got to the point where
everyone else was in Black Magic and saw
Cog was about to give him the last
winning ticket was like a black match is
like dude I just came here to drink yeah
I can't hear the Jake party have fun and
just to see like people don't realize I
get my attic story I got you will be I
gotta see the message oh you know what
I'm saying the thing is
um the attic stories means a lot to me
because I know I'm not to put this
person but I know it's history where he
come from so there's nothing better to
see my brother smile
and have a good time you know what I'm
saying like watching addict play games
is a very it's a very emotional moment
for because I can see him just
whatever's going on in his life but he
having fun right now you know what I'm
saying so that was my moment for him for
solve it's just like I I just have such
an appreciation for how intelligent he
is the way he carries himself like to be
honest with you like I've been awe
sometimes like cassava's always been the
smartest person I know you gotta
understand I went to third grade with
this guy that's sad so it's just like
bro it's just always the smart and a
plus valedictorian he's that guy right
so there was a moment King and now he's
talking like he ain't being himself but
we're going we're going we're going yeah
yeah like we just get mad when I'm like
he ain't in his bag like how we know him
in the crib and it was moments
[Music]
so anyway
that was that King the stories speak for
itself but for me it's just going out
at E3 seeing you come through handing
out the shirts and saying no like you
used to tell me like yo I'll be honest
with you like I didn't think this was
gonna be none of this I did King was the
only he said bro we're gonna be on the
beach somewhere we're gonna have drinks
this gonna be it and I'm like all right
but you know let's let's save somebody
we had 12 people in the chat you know
what I'm saying so I'm sitting there
like bro okay or around these cameras
I'm like I like yeah cameras I'm like
why we got to be on camera like like man
attic were pushed back it was so crazy
like it was just like but he had that
Vision he seen it and seen it like he
really did like I'm not a dream man one
of the things I had to learn is never
stunt my brother's dream
you know what I'm saying because without
him dreaming we ain't where we at right
now yeah you can argue that it's like I
said that that shirt and Logo thing yeah
fruit
whatever I'm saying
it's it's underselling the significance
that decision had going forward yeah
that's why
you could ask you yeah you you could ask
uh King like like to this day don't we
have conversations he's like dude I I'm
feeling this I'm like dude I was wrong
about the shirts my vote yeah
I stopped arguing on certain things I'm
like because okay you felt the same
thing right no no the same thing because
if you know me I'm the pragmatist and
the money guy so I'm like I don't know
it's gonna cost too much and I'm just
like you know what
let's rock with it if it if it fails we
fail together and it doesn't matter
right and because at the end of the day
not trying is even worse and and he's
always had that mentality always had
that mentality and now I I love that
about him because I I'm terrified to
work that way yeah he's Fearless
I see what awaited everybody there I got
you out a minute but it's like I'll
never forget big struggle or being
developers yeah he'll be like yo if you
don't care about your game
then why should we give you a shirt or
promote anything like like he he gave to
the point where he would it would be the
most obscure indie game but if that
person shot the fox in Forest he was one
of them got Fox and Forest packs easy
yeah for some clarity that we we we kept
a bunch of shirts just for developers
that like taxis and stuff and if we
really felt the vibe we felt like he was
passionate we would just give you one we
would just give you an IOP shirt a kid
was like yo you see not a lot was given
thanks hold on I was given but he was
like you see what he did see how much he
care about his game
and I remember King if you think three
four maybe a year ago
that fox and Forest developer had the
same gray IOP shirt that you had in him
and he's now moved on big in his career
he's like I want a shout out to iron
Lords you know
you know you know what it is you know
what it is with that and and when we
came up with the shirt logo and all that
stuff because we had to fix it we had to
change the brand of the shirt and they
was like yo do this I'm like I got a
good idea so we came up with that and
you know with the team and everything
but when the handout came out I always
felt
it took it back to Halloween with candy
yeah right if you showed up and you they
did a good treat and everything you got
canned you got good candy and they had a
separate candy I knew this lady on the
Block she gave you the big candy bars
right
you get the good candy bar and you go
and you like yeah
if you didn't get up there and you just
had the paper mask you didn't you know
you was like trick or treat
she gave you the white candy
and you had to go with that so that's my
whole operation with giving the devs the
shirt so when the dev got the shirt and
I will never forget that Dev that looked
over at the Fox and Friends dude yeah
we we did his his game he wasn't
enthusiastic he was like I thank you
good all right right next to him
standing right next to him he had to
interview everything and he's like oh
here's the shirt the dude looked like
the other Dev was tight yeah he was like
you're giving up sure I didn't know yeah
you gotta put your best foot forward at
all times you wasn't passionate about
your project you know what I mean you
didn't you didn't care to respect you
know the energy that we would try to
give out there but you know look at the
end of the day the conventions the shows
so many moments in Ife so many funny
moments so many there's moments I would
say that you know me and addict after
this show it was just all of us we know
it we're all basically like yo we did
that one we did that that one you know
what I'm saying like though as a group
there's moments where you then I I don't
want to eliminate anybody because
there's so many of them and there's
times when we would thought like yo this
is the peak moment of iov and this stuff
like we'd be like young most people yeah
it was crazy like yeah people like
you know
what kind of a victim of our own success
sometimes or how much grinding we do
because we'll have like mental notes of
what we think we should be hitting every
episode and then like six months from
now we're we're like 30 40 more of that
and then it's like hard for me to some
evaluate like where we are in our grind
on our podcasting career because we're
just moving along so fast and that's
that's everyone that's watching this all
the people that shows up like we
wouldn't be nowhere without the guests
that came on and exposed us to their uh
their Community the the viewership that
trust us with their their time shout out
to you with the you know because I'm
terrible with analytics in the YouTube
game and he's crazy I'm saying like he
really attic really bridged the gap for
some old dudes to learn the game you
know what I'm saying let's just keep it
a buck but I love y'all 300 episodes we
got I don't know how many more who knows
how long this thing Gonna Last but we're
gonna have fun doing it toast to the
bridge you know what I'm saying raise
your cup and stuff like that we got some
amazing guests here and around I want to
be respectful of everyone's time because
I know everyone you know got things they
have to do but I want to start with
showing Capri I don't know if he's still
in here Lord Sean Capri are you still in
here right over here man oh yeah
absolutely Canada is in a building
just to go to the uh to the full screen
like there's so many people in here now
okay
I'll give it a shot a minute but um yeah
I just want to say like really quick you
can approach it anyway because we want
to do a celebration you know what I'm
saying yeah so just you know either what
IOP means to you or your favorite IOP
moment I've got things to say
um so thank you so much for having me on
um I was so excited Cog you know this in
our chat I was so excited to be a part
of this that um I might have like
forgotten a little bit that it's my
son's birthday party
uh so we're gonna take we're gonna take
the family swimming and we're meeting up
with a bunch of people my wife is like
packing up the truck we're getting ready
to go but I'm like I've got to I've got
to be a part of this when when when IOP
calls you show up and it's just a
special thing to be a part of so I
wanted to make notes because I do have
to I do have to jet but I'm honored to
be a part of this 300 episodes is a huge
deal and I did the math and I think if I
if I'm correct it's about 35 000 hours
of podcasts that you guys have gotten
done here you do what like 10 hours
every Sunday rewards day the dedication
is is unmatched and you know there's
definitely there's there's countless
moments the stories are endless and I'm
sure there's going to be it's going to
be difficult to say anything really
unique because a lot of us really feel
similarly about this show and the
community and what is represented
through through all of it but I'll do my
best
um you guys make people feel welcome and
you make people feel special from the
moment that a guest is brought on I
think that is so unique and you've kept
that from day one and you've got it here
through episode 300 from small creators
like myself all the way up to Hall of
Fame creators like Cliffy B you treat
everyone this the exact same and I don't
think I've seen that still I'm still
looking and I don't think I see that
same respect that same offering to
everyone no matter where you come from
where what you've done you know it's
like a Backstreet Boys song I think no
matter who you are
um I just think there's a huge amount of
respect that needs to be shown for that
and I've respected that and known that
from from day one and day one actually
was not me discovering you guys by
myself it was uh the late great Bobby
Pauls the Nintendo Guru was on episode
119 which I was re-watching earlier
today and it's funny King you brought up
you brought up um cog's love for boxing
and wrestling you guys talked about that
on that episode and the reason I bring
him up and it's one of my favorite
moments that's sort of like meta is kind
of outside the podcast was
Bobby calling me after he was on the
show and he's like and I wish I could do
a better Bobby impression because he's
such a character like he he deserves to
be I love him and I noted by the way you
say rest in peace you changed the title
of that episode to reflect his passing
Cog and it's like the worst that's what
I mean by the respect it's it's the
things that people see it's the things
that people don't see like who's going
back to that episode unless you're me
and I miss Bobby every single day of my
life
um and I love that there's just this
catalog of him and and so many others
who who we've lost that's what is so
wonderful about all of us but you did
that and you guys had such a great
episode and he just he couldn't wait to
tell me about it I was like Sean you've
never seen anything like these guys like
this is amazing they've had they had
hundreds of people in the in the chat we
were there for like four hours and he
just went on and on about how great a
time he had with this show and like
Bobby always did he he introduced me to
a wonderful podcast a wonderful
community of people creating the show
and the people who listen are so
supportive and it's because you guys
lead by example you show us what it
means and it's it's a little bit sad
that that's so special because I wish
that it was it was more prevalent and
more common but you really do lead by
example and you do it in a way that
isn't look at us look at us being great
it's just the way that you are so I
wanted to I wanted to recognize that and
Cog um you know dizzy pass very shortly
after Bobby and we lost both of our
brothers me and you at the same time it
was a tough and that's that's the thing
is neither one was more or less
important than the other we were just we
were able to be there for each other in
the time that we needed it at the time
at the most and maybe even still to this
day it was a very very difficult time so
my moments with IOP are like of course
there's a million with the 35 000 hours
that you've done the show for over 30
300 episodes probably closer to like
1300 I I did the math but it's it's the
support that you show that is the the
reason that I forget about my son's
sixth birthday party that is that it's
about to happen
um the other the other thing I wanted to
mention is a couple of years ago maybe
last year you had Colin Moriarty on
and you were you and and SOB I think as
well at the time Unapologetic about
having him on yes especially at the time
maybe less so now I'm not sure but
especially at the time it seemed like
controversial in this stupid way and you
guys were very courageous it's dumb and
that's whatever I'm I'm a fan
um and I was proud to see him on the
show and I was more proud to see you
guys show us what it means to allow
everybody on the podcast you had Jason
schreier on a couple weeks after that
and you know I just think that that
demonstrated the the polarity that can
happen and can exist and you make no no
apologies for it in fact you create the
space for for every single person
regardless of their beliefs and
I just think that that's special man I I
was really inspired by there was a
couple comments during that episode that
that I I took away from that like why
are we shying away from creators who we
genuinely think are great at what they
do because of a public court of opinion
and the way that you dealt with that
changed how I look at that sort of thing
and that's really important and I think
there's thousands of more examples like
that through the many episodes that you
have and that just um that jumped out to
me that was prior to you working for him
Cog I think I think that was I think
that was before yeah
so that was you know a couple of moments
but I just want to say congratulations
to you guys 300 episodes long episodes
um and everything outside of it the
grind is real
um the community is here to support you
uh the super chats are off the chain and
the way the way that you cultivate this
community is second to none nobody can
match this so I just wanted to celebrate
that with you I'm honored to be a part
of it and that's really that's really it
guys I just appreciate you and I know a
lot of other people do as well love you
brother thank you so much man thank you
so much it definitely meant a lot and I
know the episode and I think that was
solved I felt I thought that was Saul's
magical episode I felt Saul really
poured his heart during that episode
where we had Colin and thank you I mean
I I don't know what to say about I
remember how long it took me to get him
off yeah that was literally it took me
like six months to a year because the
first time I sent him an email he didn't
respond and then I was remember talking
to Carl Cox like well you know at least
she tries like no I'm trying again
absolutely and salute to Sean you know
obviously we lost two people very dear
and dear to us us and I love the fact
that we got a chance to build brand in
New York City and hang out just do gamer
stuff and go to comic shop for comic
story
no one could tell me about Sean Capri
like short Capri pulls up but brother I
know it's a long one I wanted to make
you make sure you got your flowers I got
a lot of people here I love you anybody
that got words for sure before he heads
out because I got so much love for him
man you have no idea thank you for that
for real yeah we were supposed to been
hooked up yeah we've been crying like in
the back I know we've just probably like
got to get on wheat again yeah
um and I'm just available just letting
you know
was like just like uh we have web Dave
here as well I love having those
conversations because it just it's not
all about games it's life and sometimes
just just talking about your life is
cathartic for you and it could be
helpful for anyone else as well so I I
again I love that conversation I have
with Sean fantastic Sean thank you so
much brother love you love you guys
enjoy your day congratulations
happy birthday no doubt and um of course
I wanna I wanna be respectful do we have
nlg gamings oh Mike Muller says he's
still in here I'm here I got nowhere to
go today it's Sunday it's the Lord's day
I don't go anywhere on the Lord
what is so funny about about the length
of you everybody jokes about the length
of your shows but there's times when I
leave to go out with my family come back
at 4 30 5 o'clock I'm like and they are
still on yes sir yes sir I I gotta tell
you guys
um
you guys know that I've I've known
ILP and and known you guys since the old
days since the tech days yes
um
yes rest in peace
um and an anchor who brought us in as an
affiliate to try to do the affiliate and
that's how that's how we met you guys
and uh there's something King was
bringing you guys are talking about the
shirt thing earlier
I remember when I dm'd you when I saw
king walk into walking the E3 line
handing out those shirts and I said then
you guys are about to blow up because
that
what what makes me what puts me in awe
of the success that you guys have had
um is you've done
what many and like I what I can't do
like I'm you know with my situation I
mean our channel is really small
you guys put the work in
and and I I watch you guys every year E3
going up to PAX East going to going
cross country right be it taken out
going out you put the work in and yeah I
I love listening to Kings rants
as part of what my my joy
so but I also know that I don't know
many other people
that are as gaming intelligent as the
four of you uh you know addict I don't
know you quite as well
um as you came on late and I haven't
gotten a chance to really get to know
you I've talked to you a couple of times
but
um that's something I like to change
um because yeah oh brother yes Cog
you've been on you've been on with us
got to get solving King on but yeah one
of the one of the things that
that continues to draw me here is what
is what what Sean Capri said you guys
it doesn't matter who you are it doesn't
matter how big you are it doesn't matter
what your gaming background is
you you invite
like I've been on a couple of times when
the when the Activision news broke yeah
I remember you dming me you know Mike
get in here right that's that that's a
huge thing that I think people overlook
and the the industry the industry guests
you have on
are it's a it's
a product of that right because you you
know you do bring on the folks that are
very polarizing but you do that because
you want people to see everything and I
think that that is a that is something
that's missing out of what we see on
game originally like the thought process
of IOP was look as long as you ain't
done some crazy stuff we're going to put
the information in front of your face
let you hear and you ultimately make the
decision on it
yeah
and so I I I'm I have the utmost you
guys all know I have the utmost respect
for what you do what you have done and
it's not just the success it's the
growth it's watching you guys move into
your own individual Channel
and just Skyrocket and it's that hard
work you guys put in that that again I'm
just in all of and it doesn't it doesn't
hurt
that you know some of us are brothers in
Sega
it doesn't hurt
you know the same conversation was going
so well
brother Mike I just want to say this um
because I have a Keen Eye oh I'm sure
so it's an interesting story yeah so
I was on the realm
and then not shortly after that
Cog came onto nlg yes we traded we
traded shirts we signed we signed we
signed a treaty between the two yes yes
right and that's where I got this shirt
and and I always have this shirt even
when you guys change change logos and
names all that stuff I will have the
original and I will have this with pride
I I know it's an original shirt because
I'm looking at it right now because we
send them to get custom-made
now I know it ain't a Teespring shirt
because how many times have you washed
that shirt how
oh
shout shout out to shout out to graphic
God who who also makes our shirts
I got to talk about a Teespring yeah
yeah we try to we try to talk ourselves
out of it
my shirt now says my shirt now says like
n uh e yeah
yeah yeah so uh do not ever do not ever
wash Teespring shirts in hot water or
problems
no but I'm glad I mean I'm I'm proud to
have this
um and and I'm just you know I know I
know wilmie's gotta gotta get up so I'm
gonna I'm Gonna Roll you guys know I
talk too much so
um thank you guys
um congratulations on on 300. I I cannot
tell you the one thing that's left for
me and you guys is to break bread and
that's gonna happen yes so we are we're
gonna figure that out
um King Sav addict got to get you on nlg
for a night to come and and get bars and
um keep going I can't wait to be back
here at 600 when we're all good
the legendary the man from every
convention y'all don't realize the
history of of Mr Mike Mullins and I have
so much of appreciation for his gaming
knowledge of course the Sega love and
everything he contributes to the game
man thank you so much brother I love you
guys
we'll talk soon no doubt no doubt got to
be respectful of time I know we go along
Mr wilmie Hood I need you to come to the
front of the congregation sir
oh boy here we go
hey you put a tattoo on my chest
I want to say something to Wilby you
know often you get me in trouble with my
girl when I'm scrolling through Twitter
and you post some crazy games like what
you looking at I'm like oh it's a gift
it's my whale me it's my willmie
took me down a week ago
that's not my original account yeah
that's why my account's been so clean
here lately okay
well I just I just you just rated me
again yesterday sir
at least a new account all right I'm
gonna try to keep this short and sweet
but it's going to really be hard I'm not
gonna lie okay you guys as you know I've
said it on every podcast it's pissed a
lot of people off you guys are the
reason gaming Beyond The Box even exists
I first saw you guys I wanted to do the
show I wanted hours to be similar to
yours
but with a little more colorful language
speaking
of dizzy oh
is he used to message me all the time
going William you can't say that crap on
YouTube man you've got to tone it down
you can't say that
and you know Disney was the one it was
one of a kind there's just no other way
to put it oh yeah I miss dizzy really
really bad I know you guys probably more
than me I have no idea but a lot of
people didn't realize it I thought the
Dizzy every single day
um
now I'm getting myself upset no you're
good but um you guys
you know we're always an inspiration to
our show that's never going to change
last year when I was in the hospital
um and my wife can vouch I wasn't able
to do a lot but my tablet was on and I
still listened to you guys I wasn't able
to type or no talk in the chat but I did
listen to the show on Sundays and I had
people coming into my room you know the
nurses and the orderlies but what in the
world are you watching and actually I
ran into one guy that knew
one nurse he came in he knew who you
guys were yo yo he totally I've had that
happen at Taco Bell before I'm not even
joking I get food at Taco Bell and I'm
playing the podcast over over the
speakers because I wasn't there that
week oh you watch Ireland's podcast
I do
I was like oh so you watch Star Wars my
dude I've been on the iron Lords and I
was like yes I got a collection of their
shirts you gotta collect them their
knees too yeah
I just before will go I want to tell you
um I love you love I really do
um and I hate you at the same time
um and and because because I love you
all the way okay I don't hate you
anything no no no no no no he got to get
this special you gotta get this work
special
um we had they already gave you the work
though they had me participate in this
patreon stuff that I didn't want to have
nothing to do with right and I put the
most outrageous stuff there that I knew
no one in a right mind would pay for and
small Pockets you you my friend I did
not know you existed
you my friend have picked only two my
two who the hardship challenge which
almost killed me
I don't care what that he did check on
you he was considered he DMV he's like
it was yeah no I was not all right I was
not all right because nobody tells you
about when it's coming out
and I was crawling I could fall to the
bathroom all my knees screaming your
name Paul
when I got the tattoo I was not all
right but one thing I'ma say this will
on both occasions told me I paid for it
because I love you guys both occasions
um that's the only real reason yep and I
respect you guys you don't he said you
don't have to do it yeah he did say that
I said I respect you making a commitment
I respect your money I respect your time
and I respect you you know following I'm
going through with my commitment so
anything that you know that I did I did
it out of total respect and going on to
your show I gotta say that gaming beyond
the box if nobody's watching game be on
the box please do so for sure those
dudes are hilarious and he has
cultivated the same environment there
thank you I just want to say that no
doubt no doubt well King you hit it
because you know I love you guys and
even after when I got out of the
hospital and I actually mentioned this
on Bloom's podcast when I got out of the
hospital I realized something really
quick the amount of people that I
respect in this community is really
shrunk and you guys are still on top of
that list matter of fact you're still
number one on the list and Bloom is a
number two
um I lost some respect for a lot of
people
because after I got out of the hospital
you know we weren't we weren't able to
do the show of course because I came
home in a wheelchair and on oxygen yeah
brother you know I wasn't in any shape
to do much of anything and uh it's like
um some people treated me like I became
the plague and these were dudes man we
we donated
[Music]
to the community yeah me and Adam used
to talk about that and I'm not gonna
name any names
I'm older than that I turned I turned 50
this year so love piece of hair grease
today
[Laughter]
but uh you know you guys will still
always be the number one thank you and
I'm I've if I'm if you don't see me
typing in the chat usually because I'm
working but I'm still listening so I'm
always gonna be in the in the chat
listening and that was definitely one of
my favorite episodes because the look on
solve
the patreon yeah it was an addict that
says how they love he was like yo
oh
no
I think it was Blaze was the guest
wasn't he yeah
he's like well hold on King it might not
it might not be good oh no man that
money came from women
I just shake my head and when I had to
find the the the the the tattoo artist
I said um do you mind I set up the
GoPros he's like what the hell you doing
that for
I like I had to give him the back story
and he looked and said he said somebody
paid that to do that I said yeah and
then I had to show him you
I said this dude he said he don't like
you I said nah he actually he's mad cool
he's like bro
[Laughter]
thank you for everything you do thank
you
had a great time with you Cog last week
on the show I laughed so hard man I've
not laughed that hard in months bro oh
he's definitely needed trust me always a
pleasure I've got to get out of here
because I've got a ton of stuff I got to
do no doubt but I hope to see you hit
Episode 600
and by that time we'll all probably be
in a nursing home yeah and you know we
can like ride our scooters
oh man thank you so much yeah man you
can get that iron Lord Banner on the
back of the hug around you know hell
yeah nice little flag Mr Young anymore
we're not spraying chickens as we say in
the South man especially Mike Mullins
I'm a rooster thank you so much I
appreciate you brother always love you
guys love you I'll be in the chat no
doubt
108 dragons TV Brooklyn I need you in
front of the conversation let's go you
already know what it is
yeah what's Good Fellas what's good
brother jersey look at crispy that's
that's crazy
um what you got on there yo it's
exclusive yeah
but listen of course I'm wearing this
because it matched something that my
brothers gave me oh okay oh my posture
for gaming is propping them
this is just game and Glory baby you
know what I'm saying go out there and
get this valari you know what I'm saying
yeah
you'd be surprised at how long we talked
about who got those pillows no listen
we're ready
let me say this man let me say this
first of all
y'all dudes represent greatness from you
Brotherhood
genuinely oh my God support and that's
why I'm starting with addict first that
was like an RPG team brother lemon man
okay first I'm gonna start with the
magic man you know when you got that you
got different four characters and
everybody got a certain ability so I'm
gonna start with addict man first of all
addict
I didn't know how special you was until
we sat down and have these conversations
and people truly
do not understand what you bring to the
team preach you you work so hard me
being with you at Pax I said God damn
there is somebody else that run around
like me acting crazy getting interviews
and jumping in the mix and being you
know he's not an aggressive guy but when
he gets into this gaming world this game
encircle the energy that comes out of
the attic I was so impressed with you at
paxis let me say that my brother and and
you get your flowers
now appreciate it I'ma get into my men's
sauce my coquito brother
spoke to him several times never hung
out with him seen him in passing and e3s
and
we got to packs
now he's more like the the Wizard right
because you know he's the master behind
his craft but this dude we got we gotta
let me tell y'all what he did to me okay
we go to pass East I'm 6'5 me and King
is in an attic we big dudes when we walk
the sun disappears
he said limit
I gotta give you this room
and it's going to be a small bag so I
said yo I'm not the problem
anywhere I do this game and stuff we
don't get these interviews we gonna work
those beds but not for big people
looking at me like what I'm like yo
listen I'm not I'll sleep in life that's
how passionate we are
so this is what my brother did I we
walked past the rooms we put in our
baggages everywhere I go upstairs I look
at this bed I'm like Little House on the
Prairie I'm in trouble
after this so my man sobs comes upstairs
and looks at my bed he says no I can't
do this to you
I see your bro it's all good I don't
care if my feet is off the bed and I'm
garlic you know I'm like I'm like you
know uh Gandalf you know what I'm saying
I'm sleeping at the hobbit's crib it's
good he said you sure I said bro brother
I'm good so we got to hang out I got to
know who this guy was and he is the mark
of Excellence at what he does yes he is
and y'all dudes are absolutely amazing
and let me shout out this other guy man
well I know for over 16 years my man
hip-hop he's another Stone in in this
this this this this game in life that we
love that constantly supports me and man
we're gonna get into my mind my man
Incognito yo yo
from them Saucy midnight calls
drunken conversation yeah listen listen
you always going through a lot recently
so
the phone you put your
put your you are definitely
you are definitely the Tony Stark of the
situation
you make things happen
you're the way you reflect the people
the way you give back our many
conversations I know you know I'm a tech
guy I'll call Cognito at night yo this
video didn't sound right what are we
doing yeah
and he'd be like yo you know it's funny
uh after Pax this year firstly the first
day the first thing me and Cox said how
long you think is for a living yeah
that's how bad it is I didn't because I
was on medication
you know it might have came my wrong but
you know genuinely I love y'all and I
always want to see your content at the
highest peak of efficiency so you take
those calls you make those adjustments
and when you need that information you
call right back yo bro what's going on
yes I'd be like listen let's get it
let's let's figure it out but just the
just the reflection on our conversations
back and forward to how you help me do
many things I didn't even know because
you know I'm a one-man team so
so I need the support absolutely and um
y'all y'all three are the Staple in the
foundation but then we got this movie
star dude man you know what I'm saying
my Incredible Hulk brother the
absolutely amazing black brother that
listen let me tell you something
me and this guy we got the same history
matter of fact me Cog and South got the
same game in history same stores we
bought our games from going to the deuce
playing games Penguin Village Brooklyn
bizarre Flatbush let's go meet each
other in these spots and we all around
the same evening sounds like such a
nightmare
I remember meeting King for the first
time and the Embrace man usually when
you get to juggernauts in a room there's
a problem yeah there was no problems the
Embraced the the love we felt man that's
why we call each other block brothers
because he's been here I even had this
man eating some [__] the other day I saw
that
we putting up Sushi you don't think I
ain't gonna partake we eat nice around
here
but I'm gonna say this man on some real
tip you was the foundation of being
bringing me to your Three Brothers trust
and then uh trusting me with them and
you know everybody get a feel-up you
know this guy crazy this guy energy I
just got nothing but love for y'all
dudes man and the support that I that I
have from y'all I mean when y'all
celebrate I'm popping bottles celebrate
too that's what's amazing and it's vice
versa same thing with hip-hop man that
dude has always been in my corner always
supporting I think me and him got to
believe the hypers two dudes on the end
yeah yeah definitely the most louder
um
God has a plan for y'all man and the way
I lead this community you're giving
people that Jay-Z's blueprint on how to
do it positively bringing good energy
giving good reviews and bringing when
you bring the people that people look at
and don't even have respect for when
they leave your show people still got
that respect for them
that's what y'all bring to the table man
I can't even express anymore how much I
rock with you dudes it is absolutely
amazing that I think I should be at a
million man but we will be here for 600
episodes Wheelchairs and all
it might be on them
Professor X that's right
pillows yo yo facts but we gonna do it
in style and I think y'all dudes for
being my supporting team and yes people
stop tweeting me yo you down with the
Lords all right you see it now stop
asking me that these are my brothers
it's a Brotherhood over here and it's
genuine one thing I'm gonna say before I
get out of here last time we hung out
shout out to Addie man yes he got that
New York love I had the crowd screaming
oh yeah 42nd Street yeah yeah South
Square yes what the hell
amazing time but the humbleness man as
people walk up to us it was like yo can
we get y'all autograph I'm like we
regular people like that's the
humbleness that y'all bring man and
please stay yeah I ain't even got to
tell you how to stay positive God has
something planned for y'all and it's
just going in the right direction and
y'all dudes is amazing that's all I got
to say shout out to y'all
thank you love you too brother thank you
so much tremendous respect for you
helping us with the tech aspect and
being critical and honest and you know
the love is there brother you already
know I had to have you come through and
it wasn't gonna do no video for this I
appreciate you and I know you're scared
crazy and what you've been through for
through your medical journey and
speaking of which I have to be
respectful because I know we have so
many people in here so many so much time
and speaking of medical Journeys there
is a brother in here
who I it really was my heart to see his
face right now to be honest I was
speaking with his wife and um there was
some there was some moments first of all
she's an amazing person how strong she
is
to save the life of my brother yes and
someone who I feel has one of the most
tremendous gifts in gaming
the way he breaks down merges and
Acquisitions is something of a sight to
behold his snark his personality his
energy man I remember when I saw his
content for the first time I'm like he's
special he doesn't even know how special
he is for this community and to see him
Live In the Flesh looking like himself
talking like himself whole Glory come to
the front of the congregation brother
you know I was hoping that was me
uh yeah it's been a couple months so fun
and yeah one of the things I wanted to
mention to folks who don't know is that
I've had the the great pleasure of
working with the iron Lords and Lord
Cognito outside of just the making
content space and that's been fantastic
and when I had my stroke at the end of
last year one of the real primary voices
that my wife told me reached out and
offered comfort and tried to help as
much as he possibly could was Lord
Cognito so I can't give enough thanks
for Cog and the iron Lords for going and
trying to take care of my family in a
very trying situation in the past three
months so when he invited me to this
even though I knew as they say in
therapy that you run out of spoons a
little bit easier you run out of energy
a little bit easier when you're going
through rehab that I was going to try to
my darndest to make it to this episode
and I want to celebrate your 300th
episode and I hope that you have 3 000
more oh thank you brother thank you
brother is it is it is a blessing to see
you you have no idea man it it
truly warms our heart to see how the
community came together for you and now
that you put your journey and educating
us on all the trials and tribulations
and how strong mentally you are with
your rehab brother it's a pleasure thank
you so much for coming back yeah I'm
doing I didn't know if he was gonna be
able to make it so this is really was my
heart well I was pretty standoffish with
you I think all my responses are very
loyally I am certainly going to try I
meant it oh big as long as I wasn't
asleep on my bed
[Music]
send the family send this home Glory My
Love Again The Great whole glow always a
pleasure man you have no idea thank you
brother that means a hell of a lot no
doubt no doubt would it be respected so
much gentlemen and you were one of the
few things that I watched on the
hospital that in the hospital that I
didn't hate
well I appreciate that I appreciate it
appreciation so I would also be
respectful we got a couple Brothers in
here I want to say great about Paris
Lily I see
I don't see you still TCL apparel I just
want to make sure it's the same brother
how are we doing
first off how can I follow the last two
people that were just on and
like I'm literally at a loss for words
you know I'm usually not at a loss for
words but as I look at everybody that's
in here right now
this is why what you guys do is special
because you bring people together
um I know when you wanted to get all
this like what is your favorite iron
Lord Mormon things like that I can't
even give you anything specific other
than to just say every time I tune into
this show every time you've invited me
to be a part of the realm it's always a
good time it's always respectful it's
insightful it's hilarious I mean look
that's King with his foolishness
that's the whole point man I mean y'all
y'all are doing something special and
it's been just a pleasure and an honor
to watch you grow excuse me to grow over
the years and probably the only thing
that I regret is I've not met any of you
in person yet oh yeah because of this
circumstances yeah just with the
pandemic and just various things I know
like y'all even we're just at PAX East I
was actually going to go and then stuff
came up I wanted not being there but now
E3 got canceled so who the hell knows
what is going to happen but I mean
that's that's on my bucket list I got to
meet all of you in person
yeah then book it because I'm going to
be there this year for sure but no you
you
congratulations on 300. I know this is
just the beginning for what what you're
doing and
I will say even more importantly what
you're doing for us as the black
community in gaming is special because
like I said before you bring all of us
together you set an example for what it
should be in this industry right not
just even the black community but just
just in general because when it's time
to have fun you have fun clearly King
yeah
when you need to bring on a guest and
have those thoughtful and insightful
conversations those tough conversations
that need to be had in the industry you
do it you do it great you do it
fantastic and like I haven't even heard
what you're going to talk about with
redfall but I know it's going to be good
don't worry I got you I got you we got
you we got you coming you might have to
cut your frames down but oh yeah it's
perfect oh stop it don't you do that I'm
glad you brought it up because I was
talking to Cog offline when he first
brought us up and I was like I'm gonna
have to do something TC yo trust me I
can have a TCL TV in here right now with
like a TCL jacket
because you know what's up
but but seriously like I said I I look
at all the people that have already been
up the people that are waiting still to
come up to talk and to celebrate
everything that you're doing and it just
makes me happy because that's what
gaming should be about love brings us
together we don't always have to agree
addict
I'm glad y'all working this out
always have to agree but I don't mean I
don't love you and respect you all the
same and that's how it should be you
know what I mean so again I don't want
to take up too much time because I know
you got a lot of other people that want
to come up and talk but I just want to
say congratulations again
um I can't wait to the day that we can
all sit down and break bread and have
these conversations in person but until
then stop trying to have podcasts during
football season because you know
last night we were hanging out and I was
gonna tell him I was coming on to do
this and uh I was even saying just how
happy and and proud I am of all the hard
work and just the things that you guys
have done uh you know to to get to this
point but I did joke around now he was
like you gonna be on for the whole show
I was like hell no they do like 12 15
hours
brother I appreciate you so much and the
entire team and obviously you have so
much respect for for game attack radio I
mean you guys are pioneers you know what
I mean and just to see you guys be a
part of our journey obviously salute's
kind of funny and all those guys and
it's just really cool you know and the
respect yeah they definitely got a loyal
base yeah I kicked the nest a little bit
they came out my head yeah they came at
you they came at you until but it's just
the respect like you said to
respectfully agree disagree as the cops
go by the typical IOP trademark of the
fire department accounts but um no man
it's really cool that you're here and
the fact that we can kind of bridge the
gap between communities and at least
even if we disagree everyone has that
humble respect for each other that
they're in the realm of the Lords and
that means more than anything to me so
salute to you salute to the team you
know what I mean and thank you for
pulling up I was hoping to wear
something TCL with it it's all good
trust me I tried
everybody everybody supports iron Lords
and everything behind the scenes of all
that you do
um I'm a big fan and can't wait to see
you continue to grow and have huge
success love that is one person in here
that just
haven't seen them in a while
and it really touches my heart because
in my opinion
this man for me personally as a content
creator I feel like but we had him on as
an interview
it legitimized us it made us
yo they not only they were a fun group
but they could have an industry guest
and he took time out of his busy
schedule
not only his accomplishment speaks for
itself we talked about back compact
we talked about mixed reality talked
about VR
now he's doing his thing over yeah we're
talking about Bill Stewart I didn't know
who he was talking about talking about
one of the greatest beer hockey goalies
but just a genuine man you know what I
mean a man of the people someone I'm
very proud to call my friend I don't
have a lot of friends in this industry
but Bill is my friend and I have to say
it publicly I'm sorry if you're
embarrassing you right now but you're my
man and it's so good to see you you know
I know you got a lot of things going on
in your day but brother I just wanted to
thank you because for you being here is
Iconic for me personally I remember
being so proud of having you on and
learning about the industry and
sometimes this game is we misconstrue
things we think we know how it go right
you know and he's like [__] no this is
what happened it is it was a learning
experience so brother Bill Stillwell how
are you doing and any moment starts to
share and just to clarify I do know I
guess you know everything
and I'm just sort of talking to some
crap webcam that I use for zoom in the
office but uh the first thing I got to
say is first thanks for having me it's
amazing to see everybody here
um because what you don't realize you
talk about me being in the industry but
at the same time like I'm still a fan
I'm still a gamer and you are the people
that I listen to you're the folks that I
turn on and hear you know what do people
think about games what do they think
about just what's going on in the world
in general and it's an honor to actually
be included in this so I think it goes
both ways
um it's funny because there's something
about this group and when when Cox said
can you come on I'm like well yeah if I
if I can't I'm Gonna Make It Happen
um because you guys are as much a part
of my life and it was an honor to get to
be part of yours I mean there's just
some amazing people in this group and I
say people not personalities although
there's some amazing personalities with
this group as well uh but when you get
past the personalities and you get to
know the people we have the opportunity
to go see a baseball game yes
can you get to know the individuals
involved
um and that actually meant more to me
and so when you talk about support and
talk about health in some ways it didn't
feel like that it felt like just being
with friends just being with family and
uh getting to know you guys getting to
know your personalities your Styles it
doesn't always come through in an
individual podcast it doesn't always
come through
um in one conversation but you start to
learn who people are and and as and as
big and as loud as king is is as big and
as loud as his heart is and it's hard
work that addict puts in addicts break
because he's actually work addict I mean
he just puts in the time he puts in the
work uh solve
that dude you are like the smartest man
I have ever heard and the more I hear
you talk right every time you talk I get
more impressed with just how brilliant
you are how well you understand things
and then Cog is I mean he is my brother
he is he is family and uh we've gotten
to connect and have a really really
great relationship uh and I'm just I'm
honored to be here um I'm disappointed
we're not talking more about Stanley Cup
finals that's what you would Ainsley to
figure out you and AIDS can talk about
that yeah we'll talk about that later
bill yeah NHL 94 stories
um so uh but but seriously thanks for
having me here um it's meant a lot and I
think it's meant a lot to the community
to see uh you know I'm I've been gaming
for a long time and when I started
gaming was not part of culture and
Society the way it is now this kind of
thing didn't happen it was almost looked
down upon right and now you get this
where you bring people from all walks of
life you bring people from all
backgrounds and everybody comes together
and they can talk about this this
amazing hobby so
um it's just it's been a pleasure to be
here and it's pleasure to be part of it
so thanks for having me thank you
brother and like I said it's so it's
funny how how life works you know me
sleeping on a concrete fall ball it
wasn't Beverly Hills somewhere just for
the chance at the first uh Fan Fest yes
to try to get into E3 and I'll never
forget you know obviously the team comes
out and I had no idea like no one knew
who you were and I I had no idea
everyone was like flocking to everyone
else and you know Phil and agent Ellen
all these guys but you know I just
remember you know seeing you and then
after the Showcase went back backward
compatibility was was announced from a
tech standpoint I was just super
impressed I was just like I'm I'm from
the era where you know the the old
Hardware had to be a component of the
new hardware like you know whether it be
saying a bad system in Genesis and
you're like no we did this through
virtualization and it was just so
mind-blowing your knowledge and passion
for the game and brother you have no
idea I'm so good to see you haven't
talked in a while we will reconnect
again I want to say something please
please and I just want to say thank you
um it was a time where
he wasn't scheduled to work that day
and um I was texting him saying that I'm
heading over to the convention center
and I was like if you could have
somebody there you know so I can go over
the xcloud stuff and he was like no I'm
going to stay
I'll stay and I was like oh you don't
you don't have to this is like this is
like probably like around our first time
uh hanging out and he was like no no
I'll stay and he stood there on his time
off and he walked us through everything
and gave us a Hands-On yeah
um that's just the person he is and then
he invited us out to a Dodgers game
um first time at Dodger Stadium and like
he said it was just like hanging out
with friends and family then you get a
chance to let your hair down you know I
let my hair down too long
um but uh nah it was a great time and
you have always been a genuine person
and I do want to say thank you for uh
befriending us and actually being more
than a friend with Cog and everything
and I just wanted to tell you thank you
and I do appreciate you sir thank you um
so the respective both ways it's been
really clear really cool to see you guys
evolve um I'll tell you it only got a
lot of people but you know what the
highlight of yeah what's your vote are
you a part of this it's gonna sound dumb
I got to beat cog's cameraman
and literally walked around completely
silent didn't really get involved and
just kept filming and it was so cool to
see
um the interactions and and just the the
professionalism and the commitment um
actually that was my that's that's the
greatest moment well that was fun and
just going like no one knowing who you
are and others like covering indie games
together was awesome like that I forgot
oh brother that was that was so much fun
that trip brother thank you so much it's
also the best filming you've ever had
yo you off point yeah you kept that head
that kept that camera steady man you're
doing good
I appreciate you Bill the legendary the
Great Wall himself thank you so much I
would say some stuff but we got like 30
I know I don't know
jerseys for his birthday
custom hockey jersey
you had to do something very special and
I made sure that I went and did the
utmost film did a great job still one of
the coolest churches I have oh thank you
I thought you left already
I'm gonna fade in the background let all
the other amazing people talk I
appreciate you man I got for a brother
that I gotta respect his time this is
extremely busy person as well we have
two but I'm trying to respect this time
but I want to start with one My Last
Stand media branching you know a person
who is very opinionated stands on his
own square but at the same time when you
get to know him I think one of the best
things about knowing him
is seeing him laugh
and enjoy video games and it would he
lets people in there's a side to him
that I think is really special it's
probably one of the smartest people in
the game
Last Stand media Zone Colin Moriarty how
are we doing sir amen thank you I
appreciate the kind words thank you for
having me today many congratulations to
you guys thank you thank you
um yeah so I was outside uh the
Islanders their Series starts tomorrow
so I'm trying to like clear their
playoff series so I'm starting to trying
to clear my schedule and I was out like
cleaning the pool and like gardening
being very domestic and I was trying to
think about what I wanted to say today
and and uh you know I think part of it
is it's like
I think part of the reason why I like
you guys so much and why I think I I
find myself so simpatic with you guys is
a little bit of the New York flavor
um and you know the humor that comes
through and
um the joy and the Insight that you guys
bring it feels very familiar and very
much at home for me and so when I was on
your show you know I was really
impressed I actually continue to be
incredibly impressed especially in a
very crowded ecosystem where there's so
much content that you guys do such
wonderful and insightful things and and
I'm a little surprised you guys aren't
even bigger I suspect when you
congregate for your 400 500th 600th
episodes you will maybe not be surprised
that you will continue to grow
um I love your spirit
um I love you guys kindness and and
again
um I think you're just really funny and
that's fun for me and Kyle getting to
know you has been a real pleasure you
know at Last Stand we don't let many
people in to our roster we try to keep
it small I don't want the company the
company is already so much bigger than I
ever anticipated it was going to be and
I don't really I don't know like how
much more we can possibly be doing
um and Cog was a person that actually
came in and really helped us save
defining Duke
um when we lost ACG because he's the
only person that's ever left the team
the entire time we've been doing it
since 2017 every all the other shows
have stayed exactly the same with their
rosters
um and I really appreciate what you did
for the show
um and I really appreciate it's so
interesting because I've been in
PlayStation for so long
we've really cleared the field pretty
well with with our show and there's like
a few big shows I'm always really
traumatized from the outside about how
much of a Blood Sport Xbox coverage
seems to be
um I don't know why that is but it's
just like
and there's so many people that are
frankly so bad at it
um all you have to be is be on social
media for five seconds to see any of
that and so I'm so impressed that in a
space so crowded in uh an environmental
vitriolic I think sometimes that you
guys bring a real joy and metered
insight to your coverage and I just want
to congratulate you guys I think you're
just really you're really wonderful guys
and uh I appreciate you know everything
that you guys do for your own Community
it's something to replicate and and look
at and try to learn from and
um I think a lot of people look at Last
Stand as
um this interesting project that turned
into uh something that it it wasn't
intended to be and I think that actually
if you look closely enough you'll see
that everywhere and I think you guys are
another one of those things so many
congratulations on I don't want to go on
and on and pontificate too much but many
congratulations once once more on um I
consider our shows kind of like cousins
yeah you know thank you I appreciate
your brother now thank you so much and
obviously you solve you know I know he
had a lot a lot of respect for you as
well and you know the episode having you
on I think really meant a lot because
you know I think one of the things that
we pride ourselves on is is like Paris
said earlier which is different voices
and hearing everyone out without you
know creating that environment and the
fact that you trusted us to respect that
you know and and be in that environment
you could be yourself and I think that
meant a lot and so I was very passionate
that episode oh yeah he let everybody
know you know that kind of thing but I
think it was a special moment and I
always you know I want to thank addict
you know for being persistent and trying
to get you because I'm the type of
person I'll shoot my shot one time and I
learned very quickly you know through
addicts persistence you know that you
you have to you have to keep trying and
he was the one and as a result that
developed that budding friendship
between us and then me joining you know
obviously Last Stand and and defining
Duke and and the rest is history right
so salute to you on that and uh addict
solve everyone quickly if you have any
words real quickly for call before you
heads out yeah I always uh you know even
though some of our uh fan base uh they
they don't like your opinions too much
that they disagree
it's one of those things where you know
I've had to keep multiple of them checks
like look if we want to be an echo
chamber we would literally just invite
people with similar mindsets like we
don't even agree with each other half
the time facts why why should I insist
on never having guests that's going to
have a different opinion than the ones
that we throw out there and you know I
always put passion over everything and
regardless even sometimes we disagree
certain opinions I know the passions
there and I respect that well let me go
before Sovereign because he's gonna be
super long-winded
I don't even have to assume it I just
know it it's
um okay so there's talk about Colin and
I just didn't even really know because I
I just I'm I'm really off of the
internet as much as people really think
I am not but
um but when he was on and they were
telling me you know be careful you know
we have to police the the chat because
people going are going to have these
weird opinions about this guy and I'm
like what the hell did this guy do right
and when you're on I'm like
why I'm not I'm not canceled why why
they're not going after me because I
share a lot of his opinions
I said I said and I'm listening and I'm
listening for the life of me I really
could not find it and I really said you
know like certain guys that we have on
the show I really like this dude I
really do and you're just one of those
dudes that I really like and I really
like your opinion and it made me look
more into you uh and you know then when
car goes over there it's like a great
thing like so like you said like we're
like uh cousin podcasts and I do feel
that same way so you uh got me watching
defining Duke and awesome sacred symbols
huh thank you yeah if you can get
through the hour and a half of nonsense
sacred symbols is pretty good this one
it's a it's funny uh some people get mad
at me and be like oh I like the finding
Duke so much more than sacred symbols
such a better show and I'm like that's
great because I own both of them
thank you thank you you guys I
appreciate the kind words you guys are
awesome
um I love the entrepreneurial Spirit by
the way I totally relate to that I think
that's wonderful I can't stop either I
also love money so I can I can I can
sense my own and I think that that's
really awesome to like work hard try
hard put yourself out there do hard
things and think about how wonderful it
is that people like leave you you know
these super chats into all these things
they can get gaming content for free
anywhere yeah it's really says something
when people want to pay for something
that they can easily get for free and so
I wanted to say that to you guys too I
think it's something to take very
seriously and and uh I think it's so
it's so impressive so yeah that's it you
know I'm sorry to go on and on but all
right brother thank you so much brother
really appreciate you being here taking
the time out today the Cobra Commander
himself by GI Joe Brethren Kyla Moriarty
thank you sir I appreciate you guys be
well I'm gonna I'm gonna I don't mean to
be rude no no no no no we understand
totally okay don't worry about it don't
worry you hit solved someplace
it's like that mave on shorts like that
he's like let me stick around so I can
hear stuff he said no wait wait let me
hear this off
I really I do feel that that the episode
you came on was special because I think
a lot of the Flack that we got in the
background was the first time that we we
got that kind of flack and it and it was
you know I think people really got to
know us for Who We Are by how we dealt
with with your appearance and on the
show and it was just one of those things
where it's like well
I guess we'll see you next week and if
and if that isn't the case well then
we're sorry but we're gonna have him on
and we what we want to do is give him a
fair shake and I know that it was a
point in time when I think you really
you weren't coming on to a lot of shows
because if the way I saw it was you're
gonna go you're going to be on the show
and you're they're going to find a way
to attack you in some way shape or form
and US convincing you that that wasn't
going to happen on this show I I
imagined it had to be a little bit
difficult so for me the fact that we
managed to get you on the show and we
even turned some people's you know just
just just the willingness to listen to
you and be on you know be on our show
and be like hey this guy is a normal
person I don't know what all this
vitriol is coming from whatever it it
opened people's eyes to hey maybe I
should judge people
on the
based on what I've seen of them rather
than what other people have said and I
think uh
all around it was a special episode I
think we grew a lot in that in that
episode and people really learned to
sort of understand us you know the human
beings and and kind of how we like to do
things so again I I always appreciate
that that episode and uh yeah thanks for
coming on man I appreciate it no thank
you that's really kind of you to say and
it was really nice to like be able to
spend a little time with you in
Pennsylvania when we did the first Last
Stand show which was oh yeah it was
awesome yes we were gonna do and you
know we had no idea what the hell we
were doing that was fun and that was a
fun experience to have together and
um yeah it's it's much appreciated I I
it's I I trusted you guys you're not one
of the like weirdos that will make that
like I'm not I don't really like content
that attacks other people I try to I try
to focus on people more powerful than me
you know businesses corporations and
whatever
um and politicians and all that I don't
really give a [__] about attacking
people in the space or whatever unless
they're doing something that affects the
body you know affects the product that
we all have so I didn't see you're not
one of the weird like Gremlins making
[__] 20 minute videos about me or
something like that out there you know
what I mean and so when you when you see
that when you see that kind of stuff
then it's like well I trust you because
I when you're authentic that's why your
product is successful because you don't
have to put on any errors when you make
that kind of content a very adversarial
content that a lot of people make you
have to keep that up yeah that alienates
and isolates you from people and burns
Bridges and uh I'm not interested in
that I knew immediately you guys weren't
interested in that and that's why I
appreciate that so thank you and thank
you for trusting me and I I I'll have to
have you guys all back on you know we
would love to have more of you on I
don't know you've all been on defining
Duke right
okay awesome so yeah maybe we should do
some sort of bigger crossover like last
stand cross
um Iron Lords that would be really fun
maybe do it for like um charity or like
a charity that we all care about or
something like that absolutely brother
right um but but I'm sorry I I don't
want to take up any more you guys time I
appreciate you guys many congratulations
to you much love to everyone that's been
here before and after as well and to
your audience thank you so much for your
kindness and congratulations again bye
guys the Legends all right thank you so
much Brother Gotta respect Tom and we
have did anybody reach out to Jason
schreier I really love him shout out to
Jason yes we did yeah the schedules wise
I don't think it worked but speaking of
Jason's
there is a legend here in the building
and I am so glad to see him you know
this is we affectionately call him the
wizard not only for the Glorious beard
that he had but for his technical Acumen
the the man knows Hardware the man knows
Tech and more importantly he's just a
gamer and he throwing through you know I
had the pleasure of meeting him in
person he's awesome some of the best
food I've ever tasted I have by the way
that oh my God about still thinking
about that man that was amazing but uh
look man we have the series X and S the
father you have the father is here Jason
Ronald is in the building sir how are we
doing
doing great how are you guys doing
congrats on 300 episodes that is an
insane accomplishment and one thing that
I've definitely learned over the last
couple years is how much of a Hustle the
content creation uh game is and for you
guys to be able to hit 300 episodes is
just insane so huge credit and huge
kudos to you and the entire team
absolutely thank you so much man it
really really means a lot for you to be
here at no schedule and everything
that's going on with the team has to be
busy but for you to to take the time out
your day means so much to us you have no
idea and then obviously just learning
your background and the times we've had
you on has been special it really has it
really has uh opened us up as far as
just learning how the process work and
things work attic definitely had one of
the questions of the year
you know what's funny about that I was
like okay we're asking Jason a lot of
Heavy Hitters let me ask him something
just a fun uh fun little question and
then that's the one that everyone talks
about
no for sure for sure it opened up uh so
much and you know I think it was Forza
Horizon at the time the entirely you
were most excited for as far as you know
graphical Nelly and showing what was
going on and that that was super special
but I just love how passionate you are
about gaming and like I said it's always
pleasure to learn from you and to hear
your story and what's going on with the
team man thank you so much any words
real quickly for from solving King for
Jason because I know his time's limited
well Jason knows I love him to death
like absolutely
um I do appreciate everything that he's
done I do appreciate him uh talking back
to me in the DMS uh so uh just thank you
for showing up I know especially around
this time uh gearing up with all these
games and stuff and everything and uh
working on stuff you know your guys are
hard at work so I do appreciate you
stopping through but I appreciate you
more as a person and taking the time out
to answer any silly questions I do have
thank you yeah to me it's just Jason
again same you know contacting me in the
DMS or whatever just congratulating us
for things so I remember one time it's
just to me it's just being a human being
and he contacted me because I made a
comment about how in the past Xbox was
just not a huge important part of
Microsoft and I think I I called it like
a hernia on the side of Microsoft
he DMS him like really man you're
kidding
me you know what I like I like when when
adequate called me out about my
knowledge of music and I'm like yeah
that's great heavy metal and he's like
um
this is what you need to be listening to
that actually is in the genre Green Day
At Seven Nation Army that you talk about
is not heavy metal sir and I I was
really educated that day
I got your disrespect for that
conversation
the same thing from my side with the New
York hip-hop scene so uh you know we're
all in this together the thing that I
love about you guys is you guys have
been lifelong friends you know and
gaming was the thing that brought you
together and honestly just as a
community that that's what we all love
you know we love this industry it gives
us an opportunity to meet people you
know from different parts of the world
with different backgrounds but at the
end of the day we all love this medium
we all love this uh form of
entertainment and the more that it can
bring people together it's just good for
everybody no doubt appreciate you
brother thank you so much for taking the
time and solution to the team at
Microsoft at Xbox always love brother
thank you so much thank you guys very
much congrats again thank you so much
Jason Ronald now speaking of music
I see someone with a Wu-Tang background
I don't know if he still yeah he's been
waiting a while he'd been patient he's
still asleep without let me tell you man
without this brother
I'm gonna be real you know like first of
all you know it takes something for
someone who I feel is one of the goats
in the game you know as a man as a man
of color you know I didn't see a lot of
people that look like me doing content
creation
and can you remember I was sure y'all be
like yo let's do it with this shots
fired yeah
and he compared video games he'd be out
on the show floor and I'm like oh he
from the town yep he's from
in Brooklyn I'm like oh man I just
became so fascinated in watching him you
know what I mean and he would just get
the biggest interviews and he'd just be
on the larger stage wherever he go he
himself nothing changes and I remember
us starting and I'm like addict man
think we could get hip hop cable you
think we can get it he's like yo let's
shoot it let's go for it you know what
I'm saying and literally one of our
first guests ever
was hip hop gamer like hip hop gaming I
don't understand how this man puts down
for the culture but not only that
he educates
and he does it act bigger around like
you know what I'm saying you know some
people who are huge yeah but try to Sun
Sun you humble man yeah like just humble
you know what I'm saying and one of my
favorite memories for him is just coming
on obviously his first time actually my
second with addict you'll appreciate
this is when you know we had the hip-hop
couple you know it's like they haven't
read and that was so dope to see them
come together who you know we've had on
separately so we actually needed to do
that we need to do that again and a
Herman King Classic Reds PlayStation
versus Xbox the jokes you know what I'm
saying hip-hop brother a pleasure to see
you the floor is yours brother thank you
so yo we gonna go straight to it right
before I even talk
I want to go around everybody all right
so shout out to Webb Dave in the
building building big Luke in the
building I was in the building the one
and only kids move Best Buy
thank you
caught low in the building you already
know Colton Eastwood my patrol
Dutch but man Chris yo solely Legend
Chris Grinnell so now listen
this is how we gonna set it up right
there's a lot of people that you know
came through and had to bounce you know
what I'm saying I see Jay servano bill
you know what I'm saying Paris everybody
that came through won the weight dragons
the reason why I want to set it off like
that because for your for all y'all to
be here supporting my brothers yo y'all
all family to me that means everything
for me to see that I love that this is
amazing period so that's the first thing
right
the second thing is that's my Niche I
heard in the background
something that I want to say is like
it's
when you be around the iron laws and you
see like the whole click come through
and you see the gold on them shirts and
everything popped off
everything different you don't say
everything hit different yo because
their energy and their love for one
another
is the heartbeat and the soul of the
culture that we are in
period you know what I'm saying and I
love y'all so much for that you know
what I'm saying so one thing with my man
at it yo adding is one of those dudes
where you can't tell him no yeah that's
a fact tell him no that's a fact he's
gonna figure it out and get it done yes
like when it comes to like the college
thing I've noticed that you know it's
not necessarily people won't they're
always obviously people that won't mess
with you regardless how hard you try how
much you grind uh but a lot of the time
people
won't return even stuff not because of
they don't mess with these they don't
think that you're a good podcast they
don't know you and it's just like that's
why I have like this uh this Moto it's
like okay you know you won't come on now
I'ma get our numbers up
[Applause]
you know what I'm saying attic is
literally his name yes my attic is his
name son this
is the truth love addict you know what
I'm saying now my man
yo
put some respect on my man Saul's name
right now again 300 you know what I'm
saying yo the fact that this is 300
episode shout out to my man Gerard
Butler I was rich Rob Butler like uh I
think three weeks ago and stuff like
that because um him and my man Michael
Colton Luke Cage
yeah you know what I'm saying so you
don't already know Gerard Butler that's
300 you know what I'm saying yeah doing
the 300 episode so when you see the iron
Lords yes
sponsor like this for Glory's sake
whoa and when it comes to Sovereign yo I
want to tell you straight up sovereign
where his level of appreciation for
everything that he has and like one of
the slogans that I got that I do in the
schools because I'm partnering with the
schools character is your currency yo
Lord Sovereign his character who he is
as a person and the way he approached
life the business the the the culture of
what he says the way he thinks about
before he says like
his carefulness yes is what allowed him
to be so great and he don't have to do
too many like uh oh dag I I did this I
should have did that I did this or not
he takes his time so when he does
something he needs it he can stand on it
it is not just for him this course
around him and that right there is
special so sorry if you already know
what it is son love you bro
so now yo I gotta go to my dude
let me tell you something right now son
King
is not just security
[Laughter]
it's not just the Undertaker of the team
you know what I'm saying that's that
he's not just him son yo
Ting is so Flawless with style yeah you
know what I'm saying that's my dude with
style you know what I'm saying that's
one two the way he approached all things
he has this wisdom about him that when
he talks about what he's passionate
about it don't matter if he feels he's
right it doesn't matter if he feels he's
wrong about something you can't beat him
because he owns everything that he puts
out you can't take nothing away from him
it's like the eight it's like the Eight
Mile battle at the end you know what I'm
saying when Eminem just took everything
away from what Papa dot was about to say
you know what I'm saying it stood on
that and owned it
aside from that though
um
just as a brother bro
yo love you man like period man yo King
is one of them dudes like just like with
women you know you could talk to about
anything at any time yeah I'm gonna tell
you a quick story just long story short
I had this event with my man Jack
Thriller you know I was about to tell
the same story so
um I'll let you throw in the other side
I got my signs
so I I'm actually uh going to the event
cause I'm gonna be a guest on my man
Jack Thriller show right so I'm like yo
yo King like you know we gotta rock with
each other more so like you know pull up
you know what I'm saying pull up so he
pulled up but um he didn't just pull up
he came through ready to like protect me
hold me down make sure anything go wrong
yeah facts ain't nothing gonna happen to
me like in fact I was like bro you ain't
even have to do that you know yo it's
just love it took me like
when you wake King
you're with a king
like that when you wake this thing just
isn't his name when you wake King I was
hard with a king blessings let me tell
you where he was at he was across the
street from the Rutgers he was around uh
it's around the corner from the rooftop
so I know where he was at because that
was my area while I hung out man and um
it's a dangerous area very good right so
he said yo I'm going to be this area I'm
definitely gonna come I'm showing up so
I parked my car uh I gave the uh the
parking attendant a little extra fresh
off my car in in the front just in case
things get weird
um so I go around to the event I get to
the event checking it out so as I'm
coming through I'm coming through like
he said you know um
checking it I'm making sure my brother
is safe yes all right so we get inside
the event and he's doing his thing but
when we right there we were thrilling
them and his people's dead and
everything Jack Thriller was like yo you
coming through like you like what are
you some super drug dealer what's up I'm
like nah cut that out
um but um I'm there to to hold down my
my my guy so they're doing their whole
conversation and you know I'm in the
crowd one dude says something slick I
said you watch your mouth man that's my
brother
because oh no disrespect big homie I
didn't even you know I didn't even know
nothing like that I said exactly you
don't know who's with who watch your
mouth that's my brother and
to see him in that environment hip-hop
goes everywhere anywhere to spread his
message
and I respect that and he's the same he
doesn't flake on you he's not Hollywood
he could be with anybody he's just with
the highest exec at the Omni Hotel he's
with the highest exec same energy he's
not different so the same guy y'all see
here he's authentic 100 like hip-hop is
authentic and can right to the roots
he's authentic to the roots he's 100 him
so that's why I respect him and that's
why sometimes it's too much I remember I
was going at the AMD I said the story
before and I'm sitting there walking
down because uh you know I'm still not
used to like people calling me out like
in the middle of like this crowd and so
it kind of like makes me uncomfortable a
little bit so I'm walking and I think
you were doing something with am uh AMD
yeah
he's outcasting AMD she's got a
microphone okay a microphone and I'll go
through that and all I've ever seen oh
his addict and like keep in mind we're
not talking about just just
just uh hip-hop just talking like he is
now we're talking screaming in a
microphone the whole convention floor I
remember I remember thinking like this
man did not just do that
that's the energy man that's the energy
so now yo Lord [__] me teasing yo listen
I'm gonna tell you right now bro
like
you the glue that holds everything
together B
period son like I'm telling you right
now
you know how they call Chris Paul to
point guard
like if there's a position in gaming
where everybody leaves and you're the
point that's you you own it that's yours
you're the point gamer like whatever it
is you want to call it but you the point
guard of the culture so I see it I love
it it's amazing man and I'm gonna tell
you something and this is for all of
y'all that I'm a I'm a bounce
this is for all of y'all so 2008 and
this is why I'm gonna tell you this
seriously yo Cog this is why your role
is so important that's why you're not
just wanted but you're needed and you
are not just a heartbeat but the soul
or the culture B I'm telling you that
man I know it when I see it I feel it
there it love you man coming from you
means so much no do that go I appreciate
that dude period so I'm gonna tell you
something right now right 2008 right
um I go to you know E3 for the first
time right
and
I remember clearly
trying
to
bring more people together try remember
y'all it's a different time oh yeah oh
yeah it's a different time like you know
what I'm saying in 2008 the way things
was how extra quickish it was to give
you an example
what you see here
was even allowed back then what I mean
by that is if IGN employees was caught
talking with like game spot employees
and things of that nature you would get
fired
exactly it was on site it was a
different coach it was so Cutthroats
crazy
so
I'm there doing my thing and y'all know
how my energy is I'm trying to get like
yo get everybody together getting very
hype
couldn't do it like I wanted to do it
couldn't do it it was that crazy and it
was a lot of animosity it was yo it was
just a different time now y'all know
that my grandmother rest in peace who
taught me how to play video games so
when you look at this gaming culture
when I see everybody it hit different
period for me because it's sentimental
value it's not just playing games having
fun this is my life like thoroughbred
period especially with my grandmas
so to see what the iron laws have
created which I'll put together and how
y'all able to bring everybody together
something that I tried and wished to do
at this scale to see it be revealed to
me and I could just be a part of it and
I can just take part and witness it
y'all together is one of the best gifts
I can actually receive and appreciate
and be a part of so every Sunday is
Christmas all over again at every ILP is
a gift that we get a chance to open so I
love y'all Forever For Life
congratulations on the 300. you know
what it is baby the goat of the game
I love y'all love you brother thank you
so much oh man it will be right we'll be
right without hip-hop man the energy the
positivity Bro you've been doing it for
so long you've been putting it down for
so long and it's just a blessing to be
friends with you to cross paths with you
every single time you have no idea man
always love brother and humbling that
you hear you have no idea brother thank
you so much
always give a brother you already know I
gotta be responsible so many people I've
messed up on time if you're waiting I am
so sorry as always on the Lord's day it
goes crazy so I want to get some time
stamps because I know the acceptance
goes I got Seasons gaming I gotta take
care so I want to do it in this order
because yeah they've been here for so
long
but I got I gotta respect Lord first
season gaming then Dave so let's get the
ghost in separate ghost expansion Game
Pass let's go
what's up guys hello hello there hello
happy 300 thank you for having me uh
really glad I didn't have to go after
you know Jason Ronald or Bill Stillwell
or anything like that because that would
have been really difficult to do
um so boys congratulations man thank you
for letting me join this incredible
panel you have some of the legends of
our community and it's cool to see
justifiably how they've rallied around
you guys to help celebrate you uh and so
I am privileged to be a part of that
um you guys have taught me there would
have been no xcp no Xbox expansion pass
without you guys and that is uh the
God's honest truth whether it's advice
India and talking to me having me on
your show uh I'll tell a quick story I
met uh I met King at E3
uh at E3 to play battle toads and he's
just there he is this big dude
sunglasses and he's just he's looking at
me I'm looking at him I'm like hello
good sir
um could not have been nicer gave me a
business card that I still have I I I
keep it uh downstairs it's I still have
that and it reminds me of just how
humble you guys are and how willing to
be kind you were because you have a
panel with Bill still uh with Jason
Ronald with so many great names and you
still uh you know allow me and that
Ainsley Bowden guy to come on
really cool of you to do
um
I'm sure I thank you guys for for having
me thank you for the advice uh Cog you
were just with me like what a week ago
yeah
um and literally in that week taught me
to do something that I needed to do to
help me get better uh because for me
it's an Enthusiast hobby that I'm I'm
working at and so it's always
appreciated uh you know I love uh each
and every one of you and so I'm just
grateful to have been on here and I'm
proud of you guys happy for you and I
enjoy celebrating with you and
um I've always got a a 45 hour VOD of
you guys on standby if I need something
to do
that's great we help you through your
day for sure with the length of the show
The Ghosts man thank you so much brother
always a pleasure man I love what you do
at this casino so you continue your
journey and thank you for spreading some
time man with us on this 300 this is
what's crazy is
I was super enthusiastic for battle tops
I don't care what anybody says y'all I
was super enthusiastic and I get there
and it was somebody that was sharing my
enthusiasm
like he was he was down for this like
and we sitting there like oh this is
crazy yep and we're vibing as Gamers and
I handed them my business card because
I'm handling I don't know who he is or
what's going on but he's he's my brother
because we're gaming and we clicked so
much we had such a good time then when
we had him on he told us a story I was
like wow you never know yeah Who you
gonna run into who you meet and who
you're going to affect or whatever but
I'm gonna tell you this I remember that
day it was a great day and I walked away
from battle toads saying that the people
around me was having a great time too
you understand so and you was the person
around me so thanks
I'll never forget how long like people
look at those business cards it took me
like 18 different versions before yeah I
like that like I was very picky I was
like I was like is this good he's like
yeah we got it
he taught me something last week it was
your work addict I don't know if Cog
wants to share that with you separately
he used your work that I got to use as
an example to help me with something
yeah
um absolutely just credit to your talent
man that's that's really cool
brother you have no idea what he does
behind the scenes the ghost my man Xbox
expansion fan Luke law appreciate you
but thank you for celebrating this with
us I want to keep it moving season game
its own Ainsley Bowden
what's happening guys how we doing and
where's Travis at I know he's hiding out
there
well I'm glad ho got to come over too
man
um it's been special good seeing him
come back as you already said so but man
we got a lot of people here I know
there's so many people that want to
speak and be quick so I'm going to try
and be as quick as I can but uh I know
especially King cargo laugh because the
first time like create a season gaming
big Cass was like no one was watching it
and uh you know content was real small
and back in 2019 you guys invited me on
the show I think I just written an
article about Xbox or something that had
kind of blown up a bit and um you
invited me on the show right and
remember Cog I was like damn I got a
hockey game but I think I can make it
home in time
and I was like I think I can make it
right so I set up everything before I
left for my game because I knew it was
going to be close the hockey game went
to overtime right so I'm yelling at my
team on the bench in the middle of an
ice okay we gotta score F and go right
now because I gotta get the F out of
here so I get in my car and I'm texting
him I'm racing down the highway I come
in I'm sweaty as hell if you ever
smelled a hockey player it's not good
um and I jumped out of my seat and I'm
apologizing the chat's waiting and I'm
like oh my God this is one hell of a way
to show up for my first Iron Lawrence
podcast and right away I jump on and
King goes let's not worry about that
he's he's like let me talk about those
two statues right next to you and I was
like all right all right all right I
feel better now I got a brother over
here in statues so I knew I was in good
hands so but um no for real you guys uh
everyone has said it and I'll just
reiterate it uh the four of you
represents so much that I like about the
gaming community and we've talked about
this so many times when we chat we've
been on shows together we've done events
together it's just the camaraderie it's
the Brotherhood it's the old school
gaming Brotherhood from the 80s the 90s
that era the arcade era the the classic
era where gaming wasn't popular and you
got along and you just it didn't matter
where you were from it didn't matter
anything other than the fact that you
gained and kind of got that together and
that's what you guys represent in the
community I think for all of us that's
why we're all here we're all here
because we love what you represent in
that space and many of us that have been
around a long time
know that right and it's a it's a
feeling you can't really explain to the
young Jen right it's just different
nowadays it's not necessarily bad
uh but you know what you know what I'm
talking about it's just something
special about that and
David attic I'm trying to say something
here
um but no I love that about you and the
conversations that I've had with you
guys and I remember like E3 uh 2019 we
had some good times and uh you know we
had big plans for 2020 man before
everything was was screwed up but um
yeah just love what you guys do with the
site with the show with the community
and everything and you know I respect
the hell out of you so
um I'll keep it short and sweet but I
just wanted to say that thank you for
sending the invite out today thank you
for letting me speak uh unfortunately
you have to listen to Travis
but but you know I love you guys thank
you so much and thank you for uh for
everything honestly for the community I
want to say home
the rooftop party whoa
yeah me and you kicking it and you would
think that we're sitting there talking
about video games me and this man talk
about statues
um and I respect that because uh that
let me know that me doing Kos and doing
something that's different we have
different interests outside and to see
your basement because I thought my
basement was lit until I seen this man's
basement and I said I've never had Envy
in such a way
yo you brought that Envy out and I
salute my brother because we are uh like
snowflakes we have many different
diverse uh aspects to us and everybody's
different but you can respect and love
everything and I really respect and love
everything that you're doing at the big
cast and stuff and so when you have me
on I had a great time with you guys so I
respect you guys thank you so much for
showing up love thank you okay the
legendary easily man appreciate you
brother even though you know we had our
differences with Mass Effect and other
things we were able to come here
[Laughter]
if I recall correctly we all came
together and said Mass Effect 2 was the
best right now
don't worry slow mo is after Travis
don't you worry I was right over here
the Mass Effect cast with Hulk and
everything oh that was awesome
that was a great debate
it was so funny because we thought Hulk
was like the Ace of the whole entity
[Laughter]
I was like I was listening to him I was
like yeah yeah and then he's like you
know Andromeda is really good and I was
like no no no
[Laughter]
listen man my last word brethren I could
talk Bill still won't be quiet I see
that super chat about it
we don't need we don't need that energy
bill
brother thank you for taking your time
for episode yeah man uh I'm glad to be
here
I'm glad to be the least famous person
on this uh stream I'm glad that you I'm
glad that you represented that
delegation and also there's been a lot
of great IGN talk I'm glad to see so
many people on the stream love ign.com
at all
funny because I hear people like ains
say yeah I started season gaming because
I hated the media companies that are out
there and I'm just like I know who
you're talking to just call me by name
um yeah um I I don't have a a I've only
been on one uh show with you guys so I
don't have
um a best memory because I don't watch
your guys's show because I don't have an
extra 19 hours
[Laughter]
my best memory is the time you guys had
me on the show because I have never
gotten onto a YouTube show and felt like
I walked into a barber shop and that is
what I get when I join this uh this
group you guys are very friendly you got
that talk show feel to you and it helps
that all the people on this panel that I
have come to know especially you [__]
who I have known in real life and and
hugged those media arms
it's true it's true love love has no
boundaries
yeah it helps that they are all very
fine people that I would be happy to
call friends even if you guys are a
little hard on my favorite Outlet IGN
um and um
you know that oh yeah I mean I mean you
can't afford me
um this is true but I'll give you a
couple of Game Pass together
I do want to though be the bad news
because I I'm I'm afraid that this is
not your 300th episode
um it doesn't count guys if you if you
don't stop the stream and you just make
it one long episode
I feel like you're still on episode one
you just haven't turned off the camera
so I don't know if that counts but I
guess uh I guess 300 weeks we'll have to
we'll have to matter but really
appreciate you guys uh letting giving me
a chance to give you a shout out and I'm
happy to see so many uh beautiful faces
here uh and and yeah look at look at the
community we're all here it's like E3
who needs E3 right
I appreciate you brother thank you for
taking the time and again I want to
apologize for everything there's a lot
of people here you know waiting and I'm
trying to be as respectful it's very
difficult I'm trying to be as respectful
as possible for everyone and and I
really appreciate everyone that has come
through so far and everybody get a
chance to speak yet I apologize I'm
trying to make this happen as best as I
can slobo I know you're on time I know
Fame was on time I apologize I apologize
to um Fonz as well because I know he was
on time I'm trying to get as many people
in as I can slow-mo I I believe you're
your next as far as time is concerned
this is supposed to go completely
different yeah
this is typical IOP but I really and
everyone is still here I really
appreciate y'all still holding it down
slow I know if you have any words uh
quickly that would be really appreciated
for IOP 300. absolutely absolutely and
and just you know uh one thank you for
inviting me for this uh you guys I love
you guys and fortunate us too he
couldn't he couldn't stay he had the you
know he's at work he's probably trying
to sell somebody in the Xbox or and a
PlayStation all at the same time over at
GameStop but
um I I a couple couple things I wanted
to say real quick uh I remember back
like my earliest memory of this podcast
was was Finding you guys and then being
one of the like the six people that was
in the patreon and I used to love
patreon day because it was like I'm
winning something because it's just like
it was so bad at the time it was like
man I'm coming out of here with like an
Xbox gift card Playstation gift card a
couple T-shirts it was great up until
like it started to blow and it was just
like well damn I ain't never gonna win
this again it was people like HP at one
time it was just like it was either me
or Fons like even me and then it was
like then it's just like random Billy
Bob one I'm like who the heck is that
guy I haven't even seen him in the chat
or anything people were just winning all
the time so he's like you know what it
is it's people fast people fat out too
like you know what for a couple dollars
I could win a couple more right right
it was like I was loving to see the
growth in hating the fact I couldn't get
a free t-shirt anymore but it was great
I bet you this year was horrible because
we're actually taking patreon seriously
this year right right but don't um I
when we when being Forte came on the
guest for the first style like Forte
never seen the guy so excited in my life
like even now we do a podcast 128
episodes he's never been as excited the
guest on your show as he's been I mean
like I'm like well damn like what what
am I chop lover just like you're not
excited to be on our show but like close
close
I'm out slow slow time out this is the
300th episode
the 300 episode you couldn't put on your
best clothes today oh my God no man I
can't I can't
let that man live continue
like I mean best memories we we are the
original beta boys no Incognito
I mean it was hey look we we out here
testing these games today you guys out
there don't have to deal with all the
bugs and glitches you know this is what
is what we're here for uh uh shout out
to dizzy recipes dizzy
um just I I met him through you guys and
I just I just always remember how like I
know I could get I didn't even know
whether dizzy was listening or not but I
could tell he's like let me just throw
some shade towards frostbite
and then out of nowhere it was like the
bad signal went up and dizzy would just
be there no matter where I did it too if
I did it here on our show anyone else's
show I'm just like man frostbite sucks
this would be like a slow wash your
mouth I'm like wow
but um you know you know of course we we
go back and forth I thought they'll show
you that Destiny he deserves it
um you know I I have to be the balance
because you guys give it so much extra
love that it doesn't deserve and I have
to balance things out by just you know
slandering and eating chances but but I
mean overall I uh not to be long-winded
love you guys like dearly this is uh
one of the podcast decks to make sure
I'd never miss you guys are the gaming
Switzerland wow of the gaming community
and I say that because
big about all the people that have come
through all the people who have very
differing opinions and very differing
ideals and how it's you you will almost
say you would never see these people all
together
but for the iron Lords they all come
together because it is not that you guys
are neutral in your opinions it's that
this is a neutral ground where people
can actually say how they feel and and
speak about gaming and it be respected
and people will be respected and even if
there may be people in the chat that B
may be disrespectful that
disrespectfulness in the chat isn't
reflected on the panel and in the in the
community overall so I appreciate you
guys I appreciate what you guys do for
the community your Pioneers the things
that you guys do are reflected and then
kind of like circulated among the rest
of the community because they see the
level of quality that you guys put in so
again respect love you guys congrats on
300. thank you brother appreciate thank
you so much I mean hopefully you can get
infected by the camera bug
s
but now brother thank you so much man
slow more your opinions and obviously
you know what you bring as far as your
knowledge with the PC Community DPS
podcast I see your brother Forte just
pulled up here as well but I do want to
be respectful on web Dave you've been
here a very long time and I I want to
respect kiss move I know you've been
here a long time Chris Grinnell I know
you've been in low test I want to try to
respect everyone Cole I see you
wandering Dutch I see you log that you G
and I see you you know saying so I want
to get web because I in order of people
who have been reading the locus and I
want to be respectful of this so just
your thoughts brother I'll pick 300 well
uh thank you again so much for having me
this
um the crew you've had on uh the four of
you uh there's such Chemistry Between
You and it really shows and it really uh
it jumps out and you're you know you're
really the bar that everybody strives to
to get to and I'm and I mean that and
I've been blessed to have three of you
on on interviewed and uh Lord Atlantic
I'm going to reach out to you on the
show to get through to you because we
need to get you on because you have a
story to tell too and and all these guys
Praise You So I know I know how much I
want to know more about you because like
I said this community will you guys the
four of you together absolutely just
knock it out of the park every time and
like everybody said it before and
there's more people coming on and I'm
gonna make it quick
but the fun that you guys have is
genuine and the love you have for each
other and the respect it's like brothers
of blood all the way and it's so great
and um it really is it's a it's a joy to
watch and again thank you so much for
the invite the last thing I got to say
is because I know you talked about the
favorite moments yes I know that King
always likes to show off or I'll say
show off King you know not King
okay
oh hello I like Daddy 300 Flex hello I
guess I guess you
merchandise for 300 and we did it
I was on your show yes sir I had a great
time and it's a little inside joke that
me and Dave has
that's right sir
okay we guess we ain't gonna know what
it is no he knows when I say yes
everybody's sitting there trying to
figure out the joke you're not gonna
figure it out because you have to watch
the episode but uh it's it's so you're
wasting our time correct okay I want you
to go watch your show I'm sorry
oh I heard it okay
I mean he's such a respectful dude nope
yeah he's such a respectful guy I love
the fact that you know he's rocking with
boom
um and and that means a lot because you
know we all click as family and and and
I knew automatically once I uh your
demeanor your approach your uh attention
to detail everything about you is
fantastic and I look use professional
sitting there I'm sitting there like we
got to get Dave in yes we got to get
Dave you got to get Dave in thank you
professors back to all of us yeah when I
had the interview with Dave last week it
was that thing like he has that calming
voice
[Laughter]
of the legend man appreciate you
outbreak name is goes listen don't
support he's passionate he loves giving
it it was a pleasure to celebrate 300
with you brother thank you thank you
very much I'll make room for everybody
else they'll reach out yes Legend Chris
Grendel the legend of Sony F1 Wipeout we
have royalty and development here and an
entrepreneur an entrepreneurial Spirit
Liverpool in the building one of the
lovers brother you know what I'm saying
they love the passion I know you've been
going through a lot physically so again
I apologize for anyone you know who's
been waiting so long I know you've been
going through a lot brother so um any
words man it was an honor to to work
with you on IOP and hear your story you
know as far as development and how
things were what got you what are your
best stories is like seeing the seeing
the cars in a lot from psychnosis you
know saying you're coming out of the
record store and you're like yo I want
to be a Game Dev so salute to you
brother talk to talk to the people IOP
300 what's up
congratulations guys thanks for having
me on
um yeah there's been a lot going on over
the last
okay nearly 12 12 months um I said I
don't know we've obviously spoke quite a
bit we've tried to try to make a few
things happen and we couldn't
um and obviously I don't want this to
turn into a kind of what was me type
story brother talk yeah obviously just
for those that don't know
um I'm doing dialysis so like the king
when you were talking about dialysis
before
um Joe brought us a little tear to my
eye because I'm I'm going through it
myself at the moment so three times a
week four hours a slot
um but you know what these things make
you go stronger so I'm still I'm still
hustling I'm still building the business
and starting to put um my my figures
into the us at the minute started to to
do some things over there so
um yeah these things just make us
stronger and I think you guys are
full of kind of energy authentic I think
I always enjoy speaking to you guys
because you're knowledgeable
you'd like to create this kind of
neutral environment
um where you talk at all aspects of
games you you call it how it is
um there's no kind of sugar coating
things when when things need calling out
um and obviously I need to need to get
on the show a bit more
um that I have done and as I say we'll
make a move to the background to sort
that out
um but yeah I've I've always followed
you guys I enjoy as I say the
authenticity of things
um and I think there's a lot of fun
that's going on as I say there's four
four people who work really well
together
um
different personalities complement
really well and obviously 300 episodes
is just test them into to how good you
guys are and how good the show is and
obviously I know there's a a lot of
people waiting here so I don't want to
keep I want to keep time from others
um I'll carry on this into the show
obviously
um
we'll we'll make some old memories and
I'll get over to NYC and we'll uh we'll
look up we'll have a drink man yes sir
yes sir brother thank you so much man I
know physically you you're going through
a lot just to see you you know in good
experience in yourself and talking games
and that smile it really means a lot for
you to be here brother and again from a
development standpoint you know we love
to hear it the stories from the creators
and you helped educate us a lot on what
was going on so absolute to you brother
much love okay I appreciate it I just
want to say thanks to you know Chris uh
when I first met Chris I didn't know
that he was the author designer or
everything behind one of my favorite
games one of the games that uh made me
smile on my PlayStation
um and we had a huge you know talk
around you know uh the Genesis and how
everything went with that uh one of the
first games to have round tires
that was a huge thing I don't care what
anybody says facts completely round
tires and if you didn't understand that
that didn't mean nothing to you because
today y'all take it for granted but
Chris and his team made that possible
for other teams to do that uh and you
know he has a wealth of knowledge behind
the background um I do
um I'm kind of saddened right now
because of what you're going through uh
again I'm I'm here for you love you my
brother I do appreciate everything that
you have done and I it means so much
more now knowing exactly what you're
going through to be here today so thank
you again so much I do appreciate you
thank you I wouldn't miss it for the
well so I'll say you guys uh deserve 300
more showers so hopefully I'll uh I'll
be up anymore in the future and you guys
have a great episode and I'll hand the
floor over to other people and wait
patiently they'll appreciate you brother
thank you brother thank you guys love
kids move I know you've been patient too
brother please please kid and then I
know miles I got you I see Paris in here
I got you Colt you've been playing Dutch
next I got you in the long I got you
trust me but I gotta I gotta try to get
some
what's up man how you guys doing happy
300 episodes
um I'm not even surprised at all that
you guys are at 300. you guys got like
if I had to compare you guys to like
um like a sports team I'm I'm talking
like New England Patriots Chicago Bulls
you got one of the greatest starting
fives not even really five of you guys
like for you
yeah that's starting uh starting for the
mount uh Rushmore uh podcasting you guys
are like the you have like this crew of
puzzle pieces that fit perfectly right
um
attic
workaholic right
attic now I met addict I don't know how
we met but we've been like connected
since what maybe 2014 2015 maybe I met
you through Anchor Man Anchorman all
right attic was room to kill
um and addict like you know he was on
like the like you know wanting to when
he wants something he goes for it
YouTube was a a big part of him and um
trying to get no obviously we were you
know trying to get our you know candles
off the ground and find something that
breakthrough he used to find different
things to go viral and stuff like that
um and obviously he's a really good
gamer the thing about addict that you
know I can appreciate and I appreciate
him for you know introducing me
um to you guys but the thing about
addict which is crazy
is that
attic when he's working on something
something that's his
he puts his all into it yes and one of
the biggest things that I never bothered
asking him why right and I and you know
usually get into your conversation but
one of the things is
I watch the Attic
put his channel
on the back seat
to push ILP forward that's a fact and
I'm like dude
like that's a fact that's so like
like I mean there's a lot of selfish
people
you have a right to be selfish and try
to bring ourselves up but I'm like dude
like I get it it's like but like you
gotta Opera I was like this energy you
put in an eye you can do to your channel
and it's like and I'm watching
everything grows from you guys getting
like obviously the website The Branding
the the content that you're putting out
and then he's migrating things over
there and I'm like dude that is some
like it's it's a sacrifice right but
and but if he's not gonna do it if he
didn't believe in it and that's the
thing he we get in the party so about
yes what we got going this is what I'm
going to do I'm gonna do this I was like
which channel are you gonna put this on
um I have to put this on iot I was like
giving up all the content
the gaming addict was bigger
addicts addicts are also like a brother
to me my wife knows him as like when she
was like ah we gotta get attic down here
you know my birthday we were my birthday
is tomorrow hey you want me to try to
get attic around like then I mean attic
has gotten me through a lot and matter
of fact believe it or not
the addict should be on a payroll but
attic has pretty much if you understand
the production at a high point in my
time where I had a lot of production and
stuff going on my channel to my videos
was coming out regularly attic was
responsible for about 75 of it
whether it was ideas obviously 100 of
the thumbnails and and like he'll be
like oh you got your video oh jump on
this jump on this it's like you I don't
want to do the video and he's telling me
to do the video I'm like all right well
I guess I'll literally I'll I will go to
put the thumbnail because I'm a manager
on his account I'm like this you should
put no tags are you serious
attic has saved a lot of my videos from
flopping actually because because once I
hit uploads like all right I'm done he's
like nah no tags man yeah yeah
um but like you guys as a core like
obviously I've always always give you
guys your flowers
um have been obviously one of my uh
favorite podcasts favorite group of guys
uh being able to meet you meet you all
in person I don't think I've met
Sovereign in person but
um but like you guys are just cool
listen even when you guys go off and do
things like obviously you're on like um
the finding Duke I'm able to watch that
uh I've caught a few episodes of Last
Word with King with his when he was
doing the statues and then uh the the
combat talk moments and then now the
movie r r with attic it's like it's not
like I can watch you all like wherever
you go and still get that same quality
you know what I mean which I can't say
that about a lot of content creators and
it's crazy you guys have a monopoly on
content creation on YouTube at least
on my uh on on my YouTube because I
don't watch a lot of people and
everybody I watch has some sort of
Association
which is crazy and obviously you know
sometimes because a lot of my videos are
you saying when you say you go off and
you have the IOP yeah
is that what you replied yeah
I'm like man I
because I was like hopefully they'll
take a hit for this because I'm wearing
the IOP shirt and usually it's a video
that will probably get a lot of heat
for coming through with the surprise
with a box let me let me explain how
that happened I wasn't your biggest fan
I know and me me and you had a
difference but to add extra to I respect
my brother boy yeah I don't know and
attic was like yo King you bugging
uh you got to give them a chance you got
to talk to him and you got to fix that
Carl came to me when your situation
happened when we was in packs Carl came
to me and was like you know everything
is a democracy all right so yo um would
you have a problem with x y and z
and I said no
um because if I said I had a problem
and you're not able to to come into the
cul-de-sac
that it's going to affect attic
right so whatever issues I had I had to
put that to the side and yes bring them
in because I put addict before myself
um so when you got to the cul-de-sac
me and you chopped it up on some other
stuff
all right we we play games over at some
other stuff but me and you chopped it up
on some other stuff and then um after we
chopped it up on that stuff you guys
played the uh it was it was live I think
we played a lot of smack going on we
play live but um
after the fact I saw me put this care
package together for my brother to let
him know that I really buried the
hatchet and I really like this dude
send you the care package brother it has
been
the best gift I gave somebody because
the level of appreciation that you've
you've shown with it it has exceeded my
expectations by a billion so any any
video you want to do besides a crime
fantastic
just don't do crying
[Laughter]
I appreciate you brother your passion
obviously your friendship with attic is
how I met you and then one of my funnest
moments with you is obviously when you
were doing the Dark Souls type
challenges at facts you did it you know
what I'm saying live it was so cool
you're one of the funniest and best at
that and uh bloodborne
it was loved one I jumped up nearly
broke by that game yeah
brother much love man we was yeah I was
gonna say I was in uh your room because
we was working on editing videos for
paxis and all we hear is get smooth just
start screaming I did it they said he
couldn't do it they said he could do it
again it's like I guess he beat the
street
he only had that light yeah he had to do
it that night yeah challenge I remember
to anybody who didn't meet any of you
guys in person like I'm just letting you
guys know like they're they're like
super solid super solid the people that
they are on like the podcast or the
people that are a person and I've gotten
to meet Cognito numerous occasions come
through the Clutter we're not too far
from each other and uh I've gotten the
experience that with like uh experience
obviously the movies and stuff with them
had dinner with King David King David
Big Spender
I'm like buy more of that stuff he's a
king stop playing the flex
King's awesome like um in the soccer
likes it I can't wait to get the
opportunity uh to meet with you you're
like the the softest voice on uh the
Internet it's good to see you on like
other podcasts and stuff you know what
Sabra is it's like
it's obvious what open AI is today chat
I just I just whisper in your ear like
no I was like I need to say something
but I need to say it with the right
words and and I'm like Sovereign how do
I write a letter
all the right words and I'm like wow why
didn't I think of that I'm like that's
unfortunately we have open chat GPT but
I was like after my father I'll get
close enough to Sarah I'm gonna need him
write words out to the right people so I
can get the job that I want or the
opportunity I want but you guys are a
solid Bunch man and I'm so happy for you
and the crew and you guys got so much
stuff ahead of you and I'm happy to be
this close to it and to witness it and
you guys have blessed me many times over
and looking forward to many many more
episodes that I know you guys are going
to have something major within the next
year that's going to blow us all away
again so thank you brother much
appreciated the best of our kids move in
the building had to celebrate with you
brother I gotta get wandering down touch
and I gotta get Eugene for blog that so
Dutch you are up sir
you'd be patient yeah yeah of course to
our patient but I'm willing to wait it's
worth it it's worth the time it's been
I've known you guys for best part of
three years now and it was way before I
started podcasting
um and it was everybody every one of the
iron Lords don't even know why or how it
occurred but everyone including dizzy
yourself King addict Sovereign everybody
kind of moved in there and started
following were connected
um and it's it's the inspiration of you
guys that has drawn me to where I am the
dean and my content creation
um but it's not just the content
creation that obviously keeps us all
close there it's it's behind the scenes
it's everything that's all the private
conversations I've had with Cog it's
King letting his hair down on the on the
midweek mix-up and doing what he needs
to do obviously it's very PG on the iron
Lords but you can get that moment when
he comes on at midweek and he can just
let his head down drop some luggage
um oh it's it's start to finish you guys
have always been there for us and it's
it's always a pleasure to hang out with
you guys and speak to you and it would
have been an absolute blast to
eventually meet you guys at E3 this year
but unfortunately it's not to be
um so hopefully one day whether or not
I'm in uh NYC or whether or not uh it's
Parks or yeah it's uh it's Gamescom you
never know if the Lord is Europe one day
we need to do that
um but no it's uh it's absolute
privilege to know you guys again more
than just create as of course a close
close friends shout out to to Cog King
addict Sovereign and of course dizzy uh
God bless you soul
um
but no that's I just had to show up and
uh show my respect for you guys it's
been a blast and thank you once more for
for everything you do for for the
community and for me personally thank
you well that means a lot coming from
you man especially you know how much we
touch people on the other side and on
this planet you know what I mean and it
just see that that common goal of gaming
that kind of brings us together so it's
awesome thank you for taking the time
brother always loved the Dutch no doubt
salute lawyers and gaming.net's own Gene
you've been patient I'm sorry I'm trying
to get everybody I see Lady Infamous I
got you Carlo I got you I know I know
everybody's waiting Cody's whipping dead
patient in the suit I got everybody
miles I got you I know trust me I got
you try to do this as Fair as possible
my managing launch gaming.net talk to me
brother
um don't worry about me and having a way
but I'll try to make it short so
everyone can get going here and this is
going to be a really long episode uh
no it's been um or four years now since
I met you guys and um I met you guys
were in line playing Mortal Kombat at
PAX East with uh hip-hop gamer and I
just I didn't know people like you guys
existed and I do kind of mean that in a
your your attitude way and also uh the
race element right you know uh I think
Paris was talking about uh uh black
voices and uh I just so I honestly
didn't even know people like you guys
existed and getting to know you over the
past couple of years has been great and
your your attitudes and
um the unique approach and working with
you guys has been uh has been awesome
it's been fun and if it wasn't fun I
wouldn't do it it feels like this cool
like I'm living like my childhood dream
of like being in a basement punk rock
band or like sleeping on mattresses or
whatever you know it's just like or not
I'm still gonna Force but like uh that's
kind of what it feels like you know
we're not doing this for uh the
popularity we're not doing this to be
cool we're doing this because we love
video games and I really enjoy
um uh working with you guys and and
hanging out love brother now brother
meeting you in the flesh and we're
calling you the magic man you had that
suit on yeah that man getting these
interviews making it happen you know one
of the best you make Lords of gaming.net
you know so respected and just your work
ethic and the way you move and brother
it's a pleasure it was an honor to to
for you to reach out and and join the
team and it's always a pleasure go with
you to the events the game awards
everything man like you are about gaming
your passion show so you representing
with us as family so love brother always
Lord I I have a special Affinity 4G yes
of course
um because Gene sometimes says things
that my brain is thinking
right and um that lets me know that he's
in a proper company you with your team
like you know sometimes we like you said
you know you wander around until you
find out oh sweat people like that exist
like
and how can I get closer to the
situation and um it was certain things
that let me know that Gene you are
definitely part of us and the fact that
you you know with Lords of gaming.net
that's an extra bonus
um but I think God would have put you
close to us regardless to what because
no matter where we are on this
hemisphere the magic man is standing
there always and uh just last night
um
I uh I thought about you last night and
you know why because of you know what we
or talked about the last time we was at
Pax and how you helped me out the last
time we was at Pax uh to help me you
know get some good rest
um pause
[Music]
I just want to say yo uh thanks Gene for
being who you are and definitely you
have found your cul-de-sac in your team
and uh we welcome you with open Homes at
all times all times brother and you know
uh standing next to you you would think
that maybe you and I don't have anything
in common but minus the fact that I I
don't have I didn't grow up with any
arcades near me uh we have the same
exact uh video game background you know
uh finding our way to the Dreamcast
you know very similar uh background
growing up through games yes sir
appreciate you Lord G you already know
miles Don PA
the horror expert the man the myth the
legend episode 300 hot diggity damn you
guys realize how long that is
how many laughs how much hard work how
many fraud alerts happen in 300 episodes
oh my God it's it's wild to think about
it's it's been awesome I'm stoked to be
a small part of this
um I want to give a huge out to you guys
obviously for putting in the work for
having the funniest podcast the funniest
gaming podcast that exists I've said it
before I'll say it again
um every time that I watch this show I
am dying of laughter when I was on this
show I am not exaggerating at all when I
when I say at the very end of The
Gauntlet the four and a half hour
Gauntlet my abs were in pain I was
physically in pain because of how much
we were just laughing and having a good
time and that's that's what's beautiful
about you guys and everyone coming
together here
um when you reached out to me via dmcon
no hesitation hey I want you on episode
300 let's go and then we see all these
other amazing people here hanging out
ready to celebrate this moment the
community all of the people in the chat
throwing support uh
sharing In This Moment it's it's amazing
because you guys represent what I think
a lot of us want more than anything is
you are a bunch of really close friends
who are doing exactly what you want to
do you're doing what you love and that
is that is not something that can be
phoned in or Faked it is like one of the
most genuine authentic podcast
experiences that is on the internet
um yeah it's iron Lords it's one of my
weekly go-to's because it's just
it celebrates what I love about gaming
and it's that's the people it's you I go
to the show for the people regardless of
what the news is that week
um I go because
I want to hear what you guys think about
the situation I want to hear your jokes
I want to hear the slander
you guys remind me of getting in an Xbox
party with my friends and just [__]
around with the news and having fun with
the news and that's what it's about we
get fixated on the drama and the hot
takes and the dunks but no that's not
why we're all here that's not why we're
all talking about video games we're here
because we love it I remember coming on
iron Lords and King was stoked and we
had our moment where we connected over
retro games and that we and and going
through the history together Lord addict
when he reached out to me via DM and
he's like do you want to come on iron
Lords I'm like me why does anyone want
to hear what I expect video game and I
think it's important for all of us to
realize and you guys to realize
especially like what you mean to people
and and the fact that you're doing this
and and being this voice for for an
audience is it's so important and so
huge
um one of my favorite moments and I you
know attic probably was hoping he could
live this down but oh no we're digging
it right back let's go I remember coming
on the iron Lords and having Lord addict
tell me the the wondrous tales of the
legendary vampire hunter from the
Castlevania series Trevor Belford
Trevor shout out dude
I was dying I was dying dude I could oh
it's so good and that's just every
single episode has a moment like that
where you're just you're just laughing
and so thanks so much for letting me be
a part of this moment and thanks so much
for uh you know just being who you guys
are it means a lot love as always they
love you Eddie G you know your knowledge
you gave it always speaks for itself
always a good time when you get a chance
to work together link together I had you
at Duke also as well but every time
you're in the realm it's fantastic
brother good to see you man as always
best last name of the game
the best no doubt please thank you for
being patient I know a lot of people in
here so that's what really means a lot I
want to get more than games at this
point if you come in here you should
know what's going on yeah what a
gameplay Four Guys of quarters and of
course
Infamous Niner fan of mine she also so I
got to give her the plus week I've been
in Paris to Lockhart bang bang let's
start with with more than gameplay
ban the myth the Legends some of the
best videos in YouTube you know what I'm
saying
devil xnc podcast the man is dressed up
very spiffy right now I got a chance to
link with him many times you know fun at
Pax West got a chance to have me you and
Bill uh got a chance to sit down talk
have dinner as well talk to me Cody
Eastwood man good to see you brother
congrats guys uh 300 episodes
um I I wouldn't know what that's like
but you guys one of those that inspired
me to do a podcast and so I'm coming up
on 100 so I'm like hmm math three times
more shows than me they have you know
ten times bigger you guys are awesome
and I've only been able to meet half of
you
but the reason why I'm here today is to
call you guys out you know it's fine can
I get you guys
some of us didn't get in that exclu we
met you on the walk to the E3 show
like we've all the funny thing is you
met King but we met you but you didn't
meet us
so your question coach was how to get us
man what you want us to do yeah I mean
What's it gonna take to get you guys to
LA to come hang out do the watch party
or whatever you know maybe uh I don't
know what what's going on why aren't you
guys going to go to the uh this small
shrunken down totally not important
anymore E3 I can give you the short the
short and long of it pulse
um Microsoft needs to fly us out
look they need to fly us out they need
to put us up and they need to fly let me
get something to drink I'm like an IG
model
um my cash Gap is available
we here at the eye Lords dude that all
right
listen don't listen to him Phil Phil
Dominus Maximus if you do fly me out put
me up then fly me back I'll show up um
but other than that no no no sir
anyway continue sir no no I mean I'll
get it done I'll you know uh thank you
have any connections
I just I just wanted I wanted everything
to get back to normal I thought we were
going to be there and we were all going
to do this thing and then it just
everything just kind of falls apart
doesn't it but yeah yeah I'm you're
really glad you guys made this podcast
and it just amazes me that you do this
you know you have the one of the longest
podcasts ever
like you you guys go five six hours and
then you're on 300 episodes and just
congrats to you guys and you're all
amazing thank you so much for
teaching us how to do this in this space
teach us how to talk to other people
about games we really appreciate it love
brother always man coming from you it
means a lot the quality of your content
speaks for itself brother and uh again
it's really cool get a chance to to know
you to meet you you know what I'm saying
that that's the difference and I like
that you you're outside a lot a lot of
content creators you know either don't
get a chance or just refuse to so the
fact that you you put yourself out there
is always respect you mean put put my
face on a camera
you say hey don't you come from an Xbox
two in here they got back up my Xbox two
brothers don't you do that well you know
um I I would like to take credit for
that um because I sat there and I
pleaded and I talked and I bet and nah
just to see uh the stuff that you
accomplished sir
um in that short frame of time I already
knew it was gonna happen anyway because
I said you have one of the most
electrifying voices next to funds
um yes yeah
absolutely I love fans voices I mean his
voice is just ridiculous
um and like you're right there you're
from the same elk shout out to dealer
love this stuff too yeah um you know the
strong voice yeah the form of dealer has
put out Excellence
um and you know that your team has shown
us love and so we show that love back
you know I thought me and you'll have a
Showbox on Fridays just me and you will
have like one
um at some point but that's me throwing
that out there today
um but I I like our chemistry and I love
the fact that you're here so I
appreciate you always sir thank you for
showing up thank you guys much respect
the iron Lords much better thank you for
taking the time out thank you my man
four guys with quarters the clowns is in
the building how are we doing sir hey
what's up man thank you for letting me
pop on here to give you guys some
flowers uh you know I've I've known you
guys since what it had to be like 2013
2014. uh first episode I was on I think
was like 15 or 16 around there and we
just bonded over Toys R Us man yeah Toys
R Us stories yes oh man and King and I
we tried to save Toys R Us but nobody
back they're coming back they're coming
back
can't we try to save her remember nobody
supported us that Kickstarter I mean
we'll never let y'all know where the
money went but um you know hey we tried
um but you know I gotta say something
man like um
there's that quote if you build it they
will come and in your situation iron
Lawrence podcast
it's not that you went out to the whole
Community the community came to you you
built something special and the whole
Community came here to tell you that and
it's we see that every week and the
growth and the potential and the reach
of the iron Lord says it's just humbling
and mind-blowing and all of you on this
panel solve you attic King all are
humble and good people and it doesn't
matter
how big you are in YouTube it doesn't
matter how small you are
you let people come in to the realm and
come on the show and you go to their
shows and I'll never forget the kindness
that you showed Flemish and even though
he didn't have the biggest uh following
you guys all of you went on his show and
um that just broke my heart man that was
that was amazing that you guys did that
for him
um something I'll never forget and I
also got a shout out to I Desi
um when I was going through a lot of
stuff man medically
dizzy was as well and I'll never forget
the pep talks that Disney had with me
and it kind of kept me going through my
turmoil and we kind of bonded over that
a little bit and that that is something
I got to give a lot of praise to that
man right there because he would be so
proud of you guys today and how far
you've come and where you've come from
to build this
and there's so many stories that you
guys have uh of Verizon up from the
neighborhoods you grew up in I mean
growing up in the city back then in
those parts were not very easy I used to
go down to those parts with my dad and
there was a lot of scary stuff going on
so easy to get sidetracked and and not
find a focus but you guys are always
above all that and gaming brought you
together and brought you through that so
man and when uh
I wanted to do something from Parker and
I was going to do it regardless you guys
came through and and you guys made it
even better in fact it was so good that
I still have stuff to send
um to Disney sun and it's just crazy
that I was able to do all that with your
help as well and that's something I'm
going to continue doing I'm not ever
going to stop that
um I want them to know that
you know
he is always going to be remembered
absolutely absolutely and uh you know
another quick thing I want to tell you
guys is that when I was going through a
lot of stuff Cog you and King were
talking to me a lot constantly behind
the scenes and you guys kept me
level-headed you guys kept me um going
I did not know at the time that I had
late onset diabetes as well and uh I was
just going through so much with my
wife's accident RDX was there um helping
out getting that out there as well but
going through so much with that and my
medical issues was just taken over
and I remember you called me up one day
and you were talking to me about how to
help naturally some things that you
could do yep before I even knew I had
lean onset diabetes you guys still may
cut sugar out to save my life man yep so
welcome brother Health as well you guys
are always in my heart and thank you so
much for letting me come on here love
you guys so many great people came out
to today to to talk to you and and give
the flowers every single person that's
come out today is a good person in this
community
um and shout out to my Marvel brother
Paris Lockhart over here
gotta give him a shout out man yes sir
yes sir shout out to you for knowing
exactly it hit me straight up he I'm
sitting here my phone I'm like what
clowns was like get me in there
and I'm like I got you brother always
you know I'm a phone call away uh and
that's
that's how it is like as a community
you're supposed to if you're in trouble
if you need any questions or you need
any help with anything you're supposed
to be able to reach out to your brother
right across from you and I'll have that
contact and not just use somebody just
for their Community or their likes and
stuff like that or what they can give
you this week it's supposed to be
something different than that and I'm
glad that we've built that we've built
that able to reach out and talk if
somebody's in trouble uh or if not or
you know just whatever but with here and
you do it and not do it to you too as
well so I appreciate you brother thank
you love clowns man you already know the
history we go back you know I mean you
guys uh showed us love when we you know
when we were starting we were smaller
and um I'll never never forget that you
know humble beginnings and one thing is
we learn is as you go forward you'll
never forgot the people who got you to
the dance you know what I'm saying so
salute to you you got a big heart we
love what you do for dizzy and his
family and his son you know obviously
you know from your history and going
through that as a person without a
parent you understand the pain that is
involved with that and your empathy
always shows and and Rose you know Rose
really appreciates you know everything
we do and we're gonna Keep Us Legacy
alive you already know so salute to you
clowns IOP three honey my man salute
thank you so much for taking the time it
really means a lot and we gotta talk
about some grown women now
we've been patient
grown women gaming the love that's like
our sisters you don't say the equivalent
that's that's also the other side you
know what I mean it's over here on the
West Coast
yes
salute Charisse Delilah HD the crew
reference the end of course my daughter
sister lady Infamous bang bang you
already know what it is Paris fix your
face it's not a talk now but anyways
I'm gonna fix that face that's right
appreciate you here sis any words for us
I'll feed 300. well I want to say
congratulations first to you guys
um you guys worked extremely hard to get
where you guys are right now and I think
today it shows that the community really
appreciates you guys
um
when I think about you guys tenacity and
determination and consistency because
you know podcasts come and go but every
Sunday y'all always there
um I appreciate your guys individuality
because not everybody on the panel likes
the same thing and it's okay to disagree
with your comrades about certain things
which is fine y'all never go below the
belt y'all can get a little bit Patty
the song might bring up old episodes
with time stamps
I had like an opportunity to meet some
of you guys I think I met I met King
David on the line of Fan Fest and he was
doing heavy promo so I guess you bought
a bunch of t-shirts that day yeah and
you were just tossing it everywhere and
you you was like you don't know who ILP
is here get this t-shirt we on here on
Sundays and uh you know just pitching
what you had and I think that's great
because you know it takes a lot of
footwork to you know promote your stuff
out there not just through camera lens
not through a microphone but you gotta
step out there in the world and
you know tell people who you are and I
think I commend you guys for that and
then when I met Cognito an attic at the
Rooftop at E3 yeah
sharing dreams
Karen dreams and just
just talking about the passion of what
we all have you know 300 is a lot not a
lot of folks can go up to 300 and
what I really appreciate you guys that
inspired me as a content creator
um you guys are friends you guys take
the time out to talk to each other on a
daily basis it doesn't necessarily have
to be gaming but just the love as a
family for y'all that inspires me
to hopefully you know get where you guys
at one day and it's good to see you know
on a Sunday I can be able to sit back
relax play some Call of Duty and have
iron Lords in the background you know I
like that
people that look like me are succeeding
in the space that they want to be in
which is very hard and very difficult in
this space so yes you guys deserve all
the flowers all the love
all the praise because you guys
genuinely genuinely work hard and I
appreciate you guys taking the time out
to let me in here and to speak on the
ladies side about what we really see out
here in this space I appreciate you
since appreciate it means so much I'm
sorry I love the fact that um grown
women gaming exists yes so you know me
and you had a chance to talk in the
background on certain things that y'all
could pick up and then you know you took
that information and you implemented
that information I completely agree with
you it's education the education is key
because there were some things that I
wasn't aware or I personally wasn't
versed or well known for and I think it
was a couple of times or two David that
I was like hey how about I do this and
you were like well yeah you can do this
but how about you do this instead yeah
maybe that will help you more and you
wasn't demeaning you wasn't like rude or
you didn't you know stick your nose up
at me or anything you just gave me you
know education about it and I really
appreciate that because
in my personal case not everybody gonna
help me out if I exactly but for someone
to volunteer to help that is great and
it grown for me to be like a business
owner have a merch store have a patreon
you know have hot wing challenges
it's all about growth you know and it
wasn't for me and my ladies Delilah
Sharice and L boogie yeah I mean we will
not be here where we at and you guys are
definitely like
um a definition of what it should be and
I appreciate that I appreciate you and
thank you
your voice isn't needed your voices are
needed in the space and we we are proud
to support and to be friends you know in
this space and y'all always show love we
try to always show love back and
developing that friendship over the
years has been really cool and I
appreciate you successful pulling up and
what you guys what you all represent you
know to be honest you know it's
something that we need to see more often
always got your back you already know
sis that's what's up I really appreciate
that I ain't gonna take too much of your
time because I know you got more people
to talk yes y'all better show love in
the chat I swear I swear we're gonna
read all these Super Chat well sovereign
so so I'm trying to be respectful who is
the one that most likely probably boom
I'm gonna think they have to go quickly
and then because uh yeah I'll jump in
and out okay yeah yeah listen for first
of all I want to say thank you for the
invite this is
this is amazing watching
people don't know that iron Lords the
iron Lords podcast this cast of
characters these guys that I consider
Brothers
actually struggled to get to 1K like it
is it I mean again they're closing on
15K now everybody knows who you know
addict is and King David and Sovereign
and the ninja himself but there was a
time folks where nobody knew who the
iron Lords were but my brother did my
brother Neil mental was like yo you
gotta check out
these guys
and then I reached out to them mind you
at the time I think I had like 2 000
subs whoop-dee-doo and I said you know
I'm all about trying to help others
because that's what you're supposed to
do in this community you're supposed to
lift up everyone around you that's the
whole point of it and I did a double
barrel gaming Spotlight and live on the
air they hit the Thousand which was
amazing and look at what they've done
folks like that's the I think that is
the craziest thing and I will say that I
have one badge of honor that makes me
the definition of iron Lord and that's
because no one else can claim this
unless you steal King David's Whip and
if you do that you can get the GTA
badge of honor that keeps you ahead of
everyone so I'm sorry to be Petty but no
honestly this is Boomstick and I this is
how it's done folks this is how it's
supposed to be done you're supposed to
have your
show you're supposed to get out there
and you're supposed to do the right
thing by the community that supports You
by involving everyone and never
forgetting where you came from that is
to me is the most important thing but
listen they've done it 300 episodes
there's nothing to sneeze at nearly 15
000 subscribers to be honest with you it
probably should be in the hundreds of
thousands at this point but we'll take
the Grassroots I think when you look at
some of the the shows that are our size
Xbox era iron Lords double barrel gaming
there were a few others in there you
know Gaz and ASA over at game on daily
we're all kind of in that you know 13 to
15K
we probably are gonna eventually hit
that 25 and 50 and 100 but we're doing
it the right way and that is not by
using click bait and that is not using
hate mongering to for you know to to to
get people to click on we have fun and
that is the one thing that every time
you tune in to an iron Lords podcast
folks They're laughing and that is what
you're supposed to do
appreciate you brother man I don't even
know where they start with you it'll be
obviously you know the relationship is
real and um you know you're you're a
good friend you're a good friend and you
you always come speak from your heart
you know you get extra passionate
sometimes
reel you in but I still love you man I
still love you because you again it all
comes from a good place and you know
again like you said we we're never gonna
forget you know our beginnings and you
were one of the people that came to me
and say hey man you guys I love what you
guys do and you guys should be way
bigger and whatever I got to do to
support you know you I always will
appreciate that the episode you had us
all on kind of almost like a spotlight
to say Hey you know check these guys out
you know it meant so much and the
friendship over the years you and Mrs
boom as well you know and got a chance
to actually go to a convention with you
and work with you and in the park like
it's been so much the history speaks for
itself brother thank you so much for
spending the time all right
okay go ahead first first I was the
person I was looking for the most today
was boo you know like like no no
disrespect to anybody else anybody else
I mean because you know
um I think me and boom have a special
connection I think we certainly do
um but you know growing up kids you know
you pick cops and robbers and obviously
he picked cop and everything
um
wow
we grew up in the same city and yep same
circumference in the same area
uh and you know we gravitated from
certain areas but we're still close in
in circumference to each other but what
what keeps us grounded what keeps us the
same is our humbleness and our
willingness to help others boom has
always showed that humbleness and
willingness to help others if you go to
any of his shows you see any of his
panels you see the diverse groups of
everybody that he puts on
is I I say he's the Apollo yeah he gives
you a shot yeah
that's a fact you know he gives you a
shot and if you can make it on Boom show
you can make it anywhere and um and boom
it's very fair and he very firmly very
honest
um and I truly respect him I I had a
chance to uh share a place with him
and uh had a [__] a chance to uh go and
and work the floor and he got a chance
to see how we work and
that level of comfortableness is not
easy with with people all right he's a
guardian individual just like most of us
are especially in an environment that we
grew up in to let your guard down and to
go out with people and to merge with
those individuals and to continue to
keep that friendship and that bond
together through this whole period of
time we were going to do some things
this year you know we hopefully we get
the chance to go to packs or whatever
but I am truly humbled by you sir and I
thank you sir I appreciate everything
that you have done when he did when he
did his merch I'm probably one of the
first people that he reached out to like
yo King check this out yo you know oh
yeah my Teespring stuff is on back order
oh but um
I love everything that he's doing and I
love the fact that him and his wife
attend toes down together
partnership she's a writer she is with
boom and everybody needs that special
person right next to him to help that
motivation keep it going because boom is
the hardest working person in business
yes thank you bro that's very kind
that's very very high praise and I
unbelievably love you and appreciate
everyone on the panel for it uh we
listen we real quick I'm gonna get I'm
going to make this short and I'm gonna
get out of here because there's a lot of
people but what people don't know about
ILP
is a hundred years ago before we even
even thought of being podcasters I met
King David behind the counter of
grandfather's Boulevard
and my brother Neil mental and I met him
and Cognito in that store that was no
bigger than six by eight and that big
old man was sitting behind standing
there behind he was a muscle there's no
one no one messed with Grandpa that was
the muscle and it's crazy that we never
knew that until that one episode where I
told the story of grandfather and then
like wait a second are you talking about
Queens Boulevard and we connected and
from then on it's they've been my family
so listen congratulations to 300 here is
the 300 more you guys have rocketed uh
past anyone's expectations I'm sure that
even at some point some of your own
expectations it is well deserved the
hustle is real folks and like I said if
you are thinking about getting into this
business
follow what they do lay our leaders they
are leaders in this community and they
do it the way it's supposed to be done
you have fun you put your family and
your friends first and you never never
submit or subscribe to hate driven
content love you guys enjoy the rest of
your day salute Captain America himself
thank you brother appreciate you always
love you guys talk to you soon brother
what a respect uh uh send the link to
hoggy I got you I got stumble down with
a respect as well who's Xbox everywhere
you know what I'm saying who's cloud
acupan is azure active in is second to
none you know he's he's very gracious to
give us some time right now I mean the
man's schedule is insane he could be
doing a thousand things but he's here
with us and you know proud to call a
friend you know he's just he's just
really a humble individual with passion
for gaming his story was inspiring when
we heard it he came over just his
journey and his love for video games and
to see him doing his thing for Microsoft
right now is really really impressive
the legendary Paris Lockhart in the
realm today
yes yes yes thank you thank you for uh
uh uh this is incredible I mean like uh
just thinking thinking about like when I
first found out about LP I was just like
who are these what is all that's going
on what is all this you know King's
messyness
we've got some content here this is this
is hilarious so
um you know I subscribe and and you know
kept in the shadows and watched the show
and you know things like to another end
up getting on the show and do an
interview which was awesome
um one thing uh
uh about this show that you all do
that's really incredible um and it's not
just the ability to communicate what
you're talking about to be it's the
ability to relate to everyone that's out
there in this this gaming atmosphere
people who plug in and play right
um is those little
decorative details of how you guys
communicate that information to everyone
is is valuable like and is needed in our
space
um and I am so happy that you made it to
300 episodes
um here's to continuing on uh your
journey to ensure that you know you're
still out there you know providing that
great content you know even though it
could get messy but it's all good you
know you know that you talk about me
I'll go back to you the other boy the
classic
I don't know
yeah
well as someone who's um
who uh just loves the entertainment
industry in general like um you know the
other stuff that you do like the the you
know talk about the movies and and you
got the figurines King I just I just got
what's that that's um six uh six scale
sideshow
I think so
um uh Captain America uh that's a good
piece Sam Wilson yeah I had to I had to
call out a few favors because I ordered
it over half a year and a half ago and
it finally came in so yes yes yeah so I
I know you're into that stuff Mega he
got me hooked on to it
I'm telling you I'm loving the room
yeah it's gonna I need to do some stuff
back here and make it to make it all fit
individually but um yeah those are the
soles so those are the certain things
that you bring to the industry right
it's just not you know I mean we can
talk about gaming all day and night
right because we gained right
um but it's just the other things that
that diversity that you talk about right
um and
just the ability for you to communicate
like that is just people just don't I
don't know people understand how
valuable that is but it is really
valuable now I haven't asked because I'm
looking at the chat I see 600 likes and
I see over 600 people that are watching
the video like the video oh appreciate
you guys subscribe to the video
subscribe to the channel I mean like
to be honest I mean you know we talked
about subscribers and stuff like that
and how long you get how long you all
been uh doing this it's like you just
for me
listening to all the stories and stuff
like that and I've seen some of the
other podcasters jump on that have over
100 000 subscribers and I'm like why
doesn't I what where's the hey YouTube
what's up with the algorithm
you know what I think it is I think is
once we if we would ever get to uh get a
conglomerate to push
yo I don't care I'm shooting my shot
because they watch it
um
but it's it's not that people don't mess
with us yeah they do right individually
everyone does and I'm pretty sure that
they share it out as much as possible
right we're gonna hit that bubble when
we hit that bubble one thing I do
appreciate because I don't really look
at that because what I do want is to be
able to do just like we did on Saturday
that Community Day I didn't even know
you was in the room I didn't even know
me and you was conversing right me and
you conversing we're joking we're trying
to level up our characters to join these
other dudes okay
um but it's those little moments those
little nuggets those little things like
that that mean more to me than having a
million subscribers right the fact that
I'm still able to connect
and still have a good time with each
person individually
I like I said I didn't know that was you
but you're here today right and all that
stuff matters because at the end when
all this is done
a million subscribers don't matter
it's just those little individual things
so when somebody's telling my eulogy or
they're having a conversation about I
met king or I had I was playing with
King in The Rocker blade point
they can talk about those little things
and those little things mean more to me
than anything else yeah
sure like you guys are doing some really
good stuff
um I'm gonna stick around and read those
stupid chat and I did post a Super Chat
and I wanted the super chats come in I'm
just cracking up I'm looking at am I you
know people that I'm around are like
what are you who what do they say
no brother I appreciate you so much man
again your love for gaming also you love
for comics and and just like I'm gonna
have them on the um
Kos is changing what I wanted to be and
I got the chance to sit back and watch
what everybody else did wrong to so I
can do it right brother does that mean
you sat back and watched what you did
wrong too
yes you you always gotta look at your
mistakes
I I love attic but he has to work on the
audio please
anyway
the person sitting on the sidelines to
tell me to work y'all behave listen is
brother thank you so much I I'm so cool
to get a chance to to build with you in
person you know what I'm saying us to
sit down and actually talk and it meant
so much man and again the respect that
you show us and we're just on it we're
honored to to maintain that relationship
and friendship and again the passion for
video games the passion for pop culture
just talking to you about colleagues and
what's going on at MCU I could do that
for hours it's fun and it salute to you
for actually you know when we do stuff
with the community you know to see you
one thing I have to say you guys play
games
like you play games bro like that is
always going to be so I play B yeah I've
played Alden ring with block a bunch yes
you know what I mean he's up in the
rocket stream with us like it's lit man
it's salute really appreciates you and
the team and everything you guys are
doing and it's always it was always a
blessing to get the education from The
Source sometimes when we don't know
what's going on
so appreciate you though the legendary
Paris Lockhart no doubt and we got a
patient brother at uh GameStop who had
his camera on I hope the man don't get
in trouble for even being here hopefully
he's still there his DPS is old you know
my destiny Brethren yes
last word family yo so many words for
this man right here working on the job
it still came through to show love my
man gaming for Tay what's up brother
what's going on man
um first thing I have to say is when you
said two o'clock I was like damn this
IOP
it's a two-hour curve on top of the two
o'clock we got we got a grade on the
curve here yes
nah man but um yeah it was just off and
on I said I'll jump back in if it's
towards the end ain't no big deal I just
jumped when ain't no people in the store
and take a break and stuff nah man it's
it's first of all I appreciate
um the invite as always you know uh I
think last time we did the celebration
me and slo-mo did a video for you guys
that y'all did the beginning of the show
so I said for 300 we got to pull up
somehow Subway but um
he had to have Xbox branding on the back
I'm pretty sure that's up to GameStop
I mean I can walk up to the I can walk
up to the breath of the wild which is
going to be Game of the Year
Final Fantasy 16 section is there a
final fantasy 16 section you can put it
on
that no
no no
what's that we'll stand where a game of
the years oh all right all right all
right
no it's a small space
no but but for real the biggest thing
um
kind of hard to come up with just one
thing but I guess I'll just talk to
individual
um Cog yo
you ever since I met you have been
nothing but amazing to me you know you
have been a person that I could pretty
much just talk to about anything
um personal life anything you know our
connection with Destiny goes you know
have no bounds we sweat it out and
raised together and we get mad and we
cry we come back together and have fun
again
yeah
you guys have come a long way I I think
I when I met you guys you're around 200
subscribers and or two thousand
subscribers and look where we are now
um
the grind never ends I'm still sad that
2020 we didn't get a chance to do the
thing and that's what we were all set to
go we had our jerseys we had our hockey
jerseys and everything
foreign
no one is the leader the heart and soul
of IOP but if anybody had to come up to
be that person in that man so that's you
you've always been the person that keeps
everything together and uh I truly
appreciate you and like I said not too
many people in the community got a phone
number and a direct way to get a hold of
me and you're one of them
Jimmy G is still going to be missed to
the 49ers you see he was doing well
I gotta give it to you
um moving on to attic addict man I just
spent hours
just sitting up in party chats with you
talking about YouTube talking about
strategy talking about things that could
just help the channel uh you bounce
stuff off me y'all bounce stuff off you
and
um I really appreciate you giving me the
opportunity to actually give you a
chance to do something like that that is
something that a lot of people just
don't trust in other people and um I
really value your opinion and I'm glad
you would value mines and uh
yeah
you are not in any way
um given the credit that you deserve bro
I just want you to know that nobody
nobody really truly knows how much you
put into that channel into that brand
um and I know the people that's there
the people that came on the show know
that but you definitely deserve more
than that and I could always just give
you more and more flowers but there's
never going to be enough so I appreciate
you
um solve the man with the bank
you know every every time I mean I
remember
my biggest thing with him is like every
time I would win something he would
answer me like 15 emails saying are you
gonna like tell me what you want
tell me what you need this is very
particular and he's he's all about
making get that business stuff done and
that's the one thing that's the reason
IOP is the way that it is now you know
you guys are a team you're
um you take care of the most probably
the most important side of it because
you know we're we're on camera camera's
cool but that stuff got to come from
somewhere and somebody got to balance
those books somehow keep us under
control yeah and I gotta have that I
gotta have the uncomfortable
conversation sometimes yeah yeah we've
been known to get the lashings
exactly so you know you're never going
to be appreciated for what you do
because you do a lot of stuff on the
back end and I just want you to know
that again the person that is not even
though I don't talk to you all the time
I know what you do
and everybody else should know that too
so for you that's it and hey boo boy
you see oh
man I don't even know where this all
started at I just know we were in a
party together
and it just seemed right
I don't I don't say this lightly
of all the people I've met in this
community you are most probably the most
sincere i-hearted
person I know like you could probably be
the most scariest person in the world
because you like six four I don't know
how tall you are I know you Tower over
everybody you see but you're like
literally the most genuine nice
kind-hearted person you're gonna give
the energy back that you get from other
people and that's why I always try to
give you the best energy I could
possibly give you and uh you are really
important to me because we all come from
the same place we all we all started as
one thing that we're trying to grow
something individually and the only
thing we're going to do that is by doing
it together man and that's one thing you
guys have always done for me for
everybody in this community for slow-mo
for DPS podcast for everybody and I want
you guys to know that I really
appreciate that and King
thanks for being amazing thanks for
standing on your Square all the time bro
no matter what adversity is in front of
you and that's all that matters bro so
I'll let somebody else go shout out to
everybody else that came through I
really appreciate you guys and uh we'll
definitely do this again man
appreciate you so much the legendary
Forte man oh Forte um do me a favor make
sure that you learn slow-mo your camera
yo and don't let no
body was not showing the PlayStation
section 14 okay
slow mo will jump on camera whenever
he's not he's not his job isn't on the
line
don't worry tell them I got mad
disguises for him
at work that you pulled up
that's love thank you partner you
already know I'll see you on Destiny
suit all right yes y'all have a good
rest of the show you already know of
course we got the legendary
Germany UK Chicago South Side
let's start with the management delay
let's not before we start abandonment I
got to start with that the real star of
the show
tonight
prepare a little bit I love you baby
that's right talk to chat first
wow surprising he doesn't have audio
issues on IOP but every single time we
start Xbox two I gotta spend 10 minutes
fixing his audio
it's becoming a real issue man
I I don't know what to say really you
know I I can't remember how I can't
remember what happened yesterday and and
then addict Incognito do you ever May
sign oh can you come in and share a ILP
memory bro
[Laughter]
so and I got up at 8pm so I'm just
completely frazzled at the moment but
like when I can't like remember
specifics I can remember emotions and
feelings this is feelings-based jazz
right now and every time I come on IOP
it's just a bunch of people here have
said it it's just such a great time it's
just such great energy so genuine so fun
laugh out loud like I have to mute the
mic sometimes because like I'm laughing
when you know when kings popping off and
all that sort of stuff all right I got a
bone to pick with King as well I think I
might have said this on the last show as
well but he's got it got me addicted to
statues now you're welcome
I'm literally like because I live in my
girlfriend's parents house right and we
have we have a tiny tiny space to work
with I'm like man I need I need to save
up for a mortgage my girlfriend's like
oh we need we need to settle down and
start our lives as like grown adults and
stuff and I'm like I need more space for
statues
but yeah you guys are awesome and you
know a bunch of other people have said
it as well you deserve way more
recognition way more subs
you know than you've got and um I'm
definitely it sort of reminded me that
you know I should work harder to you
know promote you guys and using my
privileged position that I've stumbled
into for whatever reason
um you know
until musk takes it away
because I am paying for Twitter blue man
I'd say right uh maybe I can invoice it
to the company I don't know
I don't know man you guys are just
awesome and like uh I just want to give
a special shout out actually to Cognito
because
last quarter I speak in quarters now
because that's how my brain works where
you know now working in a corporate
entity where it's like everything's by
quarter budgeter by quarter and all that
crap last quarter was really tough at
work for me
um we had budget cuts and you guys have
seen like in the media like there's been
layoffs in in game journalism and all
that kind of stuff I was like it was the
hardest few months
for me professionally ever you know I've
never had to lay people off before I've
never had to be like which of my friends
do do I allocate budget cuts too it was
it was horrible you know obviously way
more horrible for people losing money
but I've never been in that position
before and I was like
I was I've never been that stressed in
my life man but you know Cognito has
always been
in the DMS offering support and all that
kind of stuff and a bunch of people have
always you know about all some of your
other guys have done have done it as
well no because I I get I wear my heart
on my sleeve and I get my feelings on
Twitter you guys have seen it we like
Helix based yet
frequent meltdowns and stuff like that
but
um that's the thing like
um some of you guys have said on the
show and and um boom was saying earlier
that the community comes together and
we're all sort of
count from nothing started roughly
around the same time
and and all sort of grew together in
this community and the way that people
come together to help each other out is
you know something
you always got to remember where you
came from and you guys kind of
epitomized that with the humbleness and
remembering that we do have a community
to take care of ultimately and um I will
try and
keep playing that forward where I can
yeah so thanks to you guys you're
awesome and um
I'll let the uh
the other guy
cheers bro I really appreciate you man
we we know how hard you work you know
and and you do weigh your heart on your
sleeve but it comes from a good place I
never felt you know any Mouse even a few
times we disagree you know they gotta
dig it's all it's always love and I can
see one of the Friends In The Biz and
you just you know you just got good
energy you got good energy and I love
what you guys do and the fact that you
know obviously Windows Central as far as
Xbox two you know the support you guys
have always shown IOP means a lot you
know to get the respect from your peers
means so so much and it's always a
pleasure to see you brother no doubt and
your other half no I ain't gonna talk
about him yet hold on okay
yo I I remember hearing about jazz jazz
jazz jazz right didn't know who Jazz was
yes yes everybody on the central
got a chance to meet him in Fan Fest yes
and um
that was great
very humble guy in person
um measured words
but funny
and I appreciate you I appreciate
everything that you do for the industry
I appreciate the fact that um you know
the Xbox 2 is always on my TV some weird
reason
um but uh I I like when you check people
my best Twitter fund is sometimes
checking in on you checking people
and somebody to put something up that
you know is false and you're just
jumping like I don't think so and just
leave it just like that just for them so
um I appreciate you being who you are
and uh thank you for showing up today
brother no doubt just recorded Window
search and then there's this other guy
you podcast with that is he he he's a
real one he's a real one um ran I don't
even know what to say that like you
again we had hip hop on earlier
and I see Barbie in the chat who I'm
gonna give him his flowers too you know
but there was like a a group when we
were trying to just got started get
established we would really be an ad
really struggling to get guests like no
one would rock with us you know what I
mean it was just like damn we just want
to do stuff with the community and I
remember hitting you up because I'm
listening to you you know for for a
while always respect sometimes it's hard
not to let something it's hard to listen
to you because I have to not listen to
you so because our thoughts are very
aligned a lot of times on opinion so I
have to sometimes make it think I can't
listen to Xbox two until I've had my own
thoughts and big ends and then I could
listen to it afterwards because I don't
want you know there to be overlap but
then sometimes I listen to it after I'm
like a red said the same thing I said in
another way or whatever like that you're
so balanced you play these games you
know what I'm saying play a lot of dudes
talking let's do playing them games
million dollar game score and all that
but you know I wanted a few that
actually got a chance to meet the baby
in the yeah and um I consider you a
friend brother you know it's always good
to catch up with you with my crazy
schedule and I just love you know that
you've been a part of our journey you
know with IOP so I want to give you your
flowers and you know you never played
any of that Hollywood stuff what I
consider how do we know how much you
love the Hollywood stuff yeah know how
much you love yeah go get it today
but nah brother you're a good dude man
you're a good dude and I'm so glad you
you had a chance to to make it here so
300 episodes random thought of 300
episodes and I got you know first off
let's talk about the no camera
discrimination
let's talk about it
I know King is you know that wants
people on camera but I'm an OG I don't
have to be
I'm grandfathered in because I was on
what IOP episode six or whatever it was
yeah
but don't get it twisted King allows
that that's where the respect comes in
um if if you're one of these people
first of all I I personally blame you
for platinum trophies right because I
have to do with it the reason why I'm
blaming you is because they saw the Xbox
game at school
they saw they saw you on stage and
Microsoft giving you plaques and all
this oh that's what that was it was it
was like a whole lot of second we need
something like that over here I'm pretty
sure
but let me tell my story
let me tell my story let me give Rand my
flowers
um but not
that dude when I saw a million because
see me and my boy Jay
uh we we Mr High we would go back and
forth trying to get a game to score up
in fact right oh we we every week
renting My Little Pony or whatever crap
right okay and playing it yeah King Kong
when I saw your million I was like oh
that's it
thanks nah I I really respect that
aspect of it but then the ability to
take that
that whole tenacity and transform that
into a show that is hugely popular that
is uh well liked by both individuals and
to do it with no camera
brother
camera at all because you've been doing
this thing
this isn't about me today it's about you
guys because 300 episodes is quite an
accomplishment not a lot of people get
there uh the guests that you've had on
the respect that you have from people in
the industry is to be admired right
um I I know SOB's not gonna like this
but I will say this is the best Xbox
podcast around oh Jesus here we go you
know you could you could say it's not
but let's let's let's let's be honest
here let's keep it up this is the best
Xbox podcast on the internet right
um you guys are amazing it's one of the
very few podcasts that I make
appointment viewing you know sometimes
you know may not be live but I always
will catch it on replay thank you for
the time stamps by the way so I can skip
the
thoughts about something I want to hear
what attic says about the new game that
released you know I want to hear SOB's
take where he makes a prediction about
Microsoft buying ABK that nobody you
know had said before so there's always
some important things that you guys are
talking about and all four of you come
together to form this incredible Voltron
of a podcast that has inspired you know
Xbox two we're you know I used to get on
the phone and because of the show I I
talked Cog like two times a week we're
talking like you know hours on the phone
we we have a great friendship he he's he
was here when he was in Chicago
yeah
that's crazy
I wasn't that gangster with his shout
out to Shadow he's on the sound
what else is to say you guys are all
just completely amazing
um and you know every time I get the
invite I'm like hey you want to come on
LP of course of course because I know
it's going to be a fun time despite the
fact that my ass is Gonna Hurt by the
end of it right because oh there's
always something you've been on yeah
yeah
that's the reason why we want the camera
on
look man appreciate you brother we
appreciate you man the Xbox 2 is a
staple in the in the community and um
just look what you guys do is inform but
if you have such a unique Dynamic you
know what I mean from the journalistic
standpoint with jazz and then obviously
Ram represents the common man but like a
knowledgeable gamer and the fact that
you have a million Gamers score you guys
are as large and respected as you are
and the fact that you you know you
definitely were part of our journey it
really really means a lot to have you
here man and you know Journey continues
but appreciate you so much ran out
though thank you Windows sent to Xbox
two I see a legend that came through the
door
really quickly whose time is extremely
limited who I'm so honored to see right
now I mean this man I mean where words
can't even describe I think you know one
of my first E3 experiences after
watching him so long I never always have
to tell this story is that I'm on the
show floor going from convention to
Convention you know I'm in awe of being
the perspective of the LA Convention
Center E3 probably my second one at the
time but my first time really kind of
soaking it in and then across the aisle
I see one of my gaming Heroes I see Ryan
McCaffrey bags in head the man had
busyness and all type of work things
that he needed to do on his face
you know when you try to try to do your
job and you're really trying to be nice
and I could tell he really didn't have
any time to talk to me and I said Ryan I
said I know you're busy right now I just
want to shake your head I'm a huge fan
of yours I love what you guys do with
the industry the way you talk I still
think one of the greatest shows in the
history of having the Xbox leadership of
all generations feet of War Phil you
know to be Sheamus I've been the
interviewers the who's who you're one of
my gaming here you're on my Mount
Rushmore as far as you know just
knowledge of the game and passion and
then to be honest you know the biggest
respect I could have personally as a
content creator was being invited to
podcast a lot that that changed that
changed me it really meant a lot and to
see the community respond to what you
were doing not only just for me just for
during a time when it was very tough for
Content creators of color and just
anyone in general to have a voice and
for you to reach back and look at
yourself and do that man I have so much
respect for you the fact that you're
here you're gonna be reason a lot the
less Dairy Ryan
McCaffrey ILP 300 brother talk to me uh
I'm gonna go
there's nowhere to go but down from that
uh I thought we were supposed to be
celebrating you right now uh that was
way too much but thank you you're very
very kind my friend you've always been
very kind uh I am officially the worst
guest on this Milestone I'm three hours
late because I got the time zone wrong
who's been doing this for 20 years
time zone oh my goodness I'm so sorry
I'm good brother you're good to be here
appreciate you uh just crowbarring me
into this thing
uh Cog you are you know you've been
wonderful every time I've ever talked to
you on the air off and it's uh you know
just just seeing seeing your journey and
seeing you grow has just been been so
great for me uh you know I I'm lucky
I've got this big platform and you know
whatever little tiny minuscule way I can
help uh Shine the Light on other people
doing great stuff I'm happy to do it and
and you have uh I'm proud to call you a
friend and you're a great colleague and
I just appreciate you hello brother
thank you thank you so much and you know
again for you to trust us to to come on
the platform and get to hear your
journey to hear your story it means a
lot it means a lot and you know as an
independent Network you know it's it's
very difficult sometimes right it again
to get that respect for the peers you
have no idea man really quick soft King
addict any words for for Ryan on IOP 300
well one thing I would say is well thank
you and I'm you are right on time you
know three hours a week we didn't even
get to the topics yet yeah
you you are early
um now I just want to say thank you for
having my comrade on the platform
and you know we talk about it in the
background a lot of times you know we
push Cog forward you know he's our Obama
and um we push him forward uh to open
the door up for the rest of us to come
through
um and we appreciate that a whole period
of time where you guys uh took the
awareness to look back and to see who
was in the community uh to come on the
platform and to talk about their journey
and to talk about what's going on to
talk about gaming what keeps us uh close
to each other and I appreciate you
showing up today because you could have
did a one-off right you get to do we had
car gone we did our black guy of the
week uh thing and that's not it all
right so for anybody that thought that
was it uh you showing up today on uh
random Sunday uh to celebrate a 300
episode is important to us it's
important to me myself and I just want
to say thank you for showing up so it
was not late he was definitely on time
and I hope that my for me it's yeah it's
it's about it's about normalizing uh A A
diversity and normalizing you know
anybody and everybody that that can show
up on on IGN or any other platform it's
you know that's I want to get to the
point where nobody notices right that
it's you know that's that's my goal uh
and I'm you know working towards that
all the time I'm not there yet but I'm
I'm trying to you know
I'm trying to just build a stack of
receipts to go back and to go back and
look at and it's you know there's no I
don't know when enough receipts is
enough I know I'm not there yet but no
it's uh it's just it's important it's
like you know
um
I've had this I've had I've been blessed
with this opportunity to do this for 20
years over almost 11 at IGN and yeah
it's uh it I'm sorry it took me so long
to just wake up and go wait a second I
gotta I gotta invite some other people
on here and just make this more than
just about me and and the people that I
work directly with so you know it's it's
a process right and it's uh and the
thing is the best part is uh
or at least one of the one of the best
parts is that having people like cogon
has made has actually made unlock better
it's not just about you know opening
doors to to welcome other people it's
it's actually made the podcast better
you know it comes in he brings his
energy you know uh we'll have uh you
know when we get we'll have um
uh you know guys like parison that bring
their energy and it's just like it just
re and it just reinvigorates what I'm
doing on on the basis on the regular
basis that I get to bring people in so
yeah it's just uh it's been awesome it's
and we're we're still at the beginning
of this ride beginning of this journey
no doubt so let's solve any words for
the legendary Ryan McCaffrey yeah I mean
Ryan you talk about you know having this
this this great opportunity that you
have in this platform but make no
mistake you've earned your keep man you
you did you've earned your keep and you
you've grinded for a very very long time
and I think for us
um a lot of the example that you said
about how you carry yourself and how
professional you are and how you just go
about your business every day has been
inspiration to us because it really has
and you know when we think about how we
want to be seen and carry ourselves and
you know we do interviews and things of
that nature one of the the pillars of
that that we look to for inspiration has
been you so um yeah man I appreciate you
coming on I definitely appreciate you
giving Cog that you know that
opportunity to go on to the show and I
think you're right I I think another
thing that it was really impressive to
me was the fact that you know when all
that stuff was going on and people
started coming on the show and you you
came out and said hey I've lived in my
life in a way that I have not been
around a lot of people of different
races and colors and I grew up in a
specific situation I don't know
what what things people go through and I
I'm gonna make it a point to to
understand and and and and empathize in
a way that I can be helpful because I
have no idea what other people go
through and to say that and to follow
through with it is is a special thing so
I appreciate you thank you yeah it's uh
yeah just like I said that's where the
just trying to keep doing it all the
time regular basis not just black
history month not just
quickly
I see that you know I even like I've
even I've tried I've tried to diversify
my Twitter following more you know it's
like it's it's got to be every because
it's you're right it's like I did say
that uh publicly on online it's true
it's like yeah I I came up it just it
wasn't a a choice I think even by my by
my parents it's nothing but it's just
that's how it was and it's like no it's
you know there's a bigger world out
there and there's there's other
perspectives that need to be seen and
heard that and and I need to do my part
to to understand and that you know that
makes me hopefully a better person a
better father to my daughter so you know
it's uh and like I said it the the
beauty part is it's it's made unlocked
better as it's as uh every every time so
it's it's just it's been a last and and
it's you know just going to keep going
until until it's so normal nobody
notices anymore that's right when they
see my face there then they'd be like
it's normal
blood added any bonds any words for the
legendary
appreciate you coming on uh Ryan so
definitely a good look that uh people at
IGN uh respect us enough to be on our
platform uh and you know here here's
here's one to many more yes that's a
good thank you so much brother it's
great to see you Robert Cafe IOP 300
intervened great thank you so much for
taking the time brother absolutely
here's the 300 more uh yeah it's it's
appreciate you having me on three hours
later or on time or whatever whatever it
turns out you guys uh trying to cover
for me no let's make it very clear to
the audience literally eight hours right
because I don't understand clearly
labeled time zones
oh my goodness now you guys are great uh
have a great 300 show and and and 301
and 400 and 500 600 and keep on rolling
and uh and thanks for having me thank
you brother what's love right but
Carefree in the building podcasts are
locked in the legendary IGN
let's talk to you brother I mean it's
great it's great to see you
um you know you you've you've been in
the chats I remember I'm like who is
this person that always agree with cake
like I'm doing way too much oh my God
instigating I'm like and I got a chance
to beat you know you know I'm like yeah
he's a cool dude and finally he agreed
with me one time when he didn't agree
with King I couldn't believe I was like
wow so how's that I don't I don't
remember I must have blocked that out
absolutely and again brother get a
chance to beat you you know in person
and you know you're awesome in Boston
but just more importantly just to see
your growth now on shows yeah get to see
your voice and I'm like okay he's
outside with it now you know to see your
passion for Content creation but good
it's good to see you here IOP 300.
what's yours brother anything you want
to say yeah yeah so like the way I got
introduced to ILP was uh you know I
first saw your videos and I didn't see
them live and I'm looking at the time
and I'm like it's like five hours I'm
not gonna watch five hours what what is
this and then I think it was King was on
somebody else's uh podcast and I'm like
dude this guy's awesome I gotta watch
this stuff just to see what it's like
and and I I watched like just you know
not live just watched one of the
episodes and I'm like oh this is awesome
like you just don't even know the time
just goes right by because you guys have
such awesome energy and then I just
started watching live right and you saw
me in the chats and uh and now I look
forward to this this podcast is my
weekend it is so good you're you're like
the event of the weekend for me I I love
your energy the camaraderie you you
compliment each other so well and you
you miss it when you're not there you
can see what happens to the podcast it
goes down it's so much better when you
when you have all four of you uh the the
the the way that you do things is so
great and you know I don't know people
realize how much work goes into making
the content that you do making the
podcast you do you know all the things
that King comes up with that's not like
happenstance that's thought out you have
to do that work right all the stuff that
Cog does and you know introductions all
that that's that's work you have to go
figure it out you know there's a lot of
things that go into to making this
happen uh understanding the games and
understanding the industry right and
you're just intrinsic knowledge because
you've lived through most of the the
start of Gaming all the way to now right
it's just so great to have all that in
right and and that's what makes it so
fun it's conversational and for people
at our age it's just all the memories we
have of what this was what this is right
and and that's why it's just so much fun
to keep hearing like oh yeah I remember
that I remember when that happened and
when that came out and it's just so
great to have that uh but you're you're
you're like like a WWE event like it's
so awesome right that every I'm serious
I love like my Sundays it's it's the the
Lord's day to watch you guys I hate it
when I have some family thing to have to
do
I love watching like this podcast
especially I I like a lot of podcasts I
mean a lot of podcasts I watch them I'm
actually part of many podcasts but this
podcast is just so out of this world
awesome I love how you bring in guests
of All Sorts you have awesome
conversations with them I've learned so
many things from your interviews uh you
know bringing in Industry people
bringing in other uh panel you know
other community members you know it's
just it's been so good and your
interview style is so great like going
through everything in a long form is is
so cool uh so I really love your podcast
a lot and you know the the criminal
thing is you have like 14 14
000 it should be Millions you should
have so many subscribers people need to
listen to this people need to engage
with this uh you guys have such an
awesome format uh no um you know a
hatred or anything like that it's all
about the beauty of gaming and how we
want to make that you know a part of our
community and you're you're a very good
part of what this community has to offer
offer I really love this uh this format
the podcast and all four of you make it
that much better uh so yes that was
basically what I wanted to say I I love
the IOP podcast it's so good all right
brother I appreciate you man it's really
cool to see again you know like we said
earlier so like you see names in the
chat you remember them you know and you
see I remember I'm like yo Hardy I gotta
tell you this on air my wife said he's
my favorite guy because he's real he
said she said the blue shirt long beard
guy yep she's watching right now right
and um
she she knows you real because I talk
about you know how real you are and how
much of a good person you are and
um
you know uh how you you give out to the
community I mean your heart is so big
right and I just want to say thank you
thank you for being part of this
community thank you uh for even meeting
us today taking the time out for us
um you know PAX East is so much fun
knowing that we're going to get a chance
to see hoggy be honest with you
um to have you at a live show
um it's just this community is so great
you know and I do appreciate you so
thank you so much for showing up yeah
thank you thank you again Legend at last
but certainly not least
we got South frogs finest in the
building this is another person who
let's be honest you know you know Bari
been doing it for a long time yep you
know um Bari his his passion for
PlayStation I think he's one of the only
people that in this panel that's been
doing this longer than me like the same
amount I mean me kids smooth and bar
you're Barry Camp after me and kids
smooth a little bit
not for you know I respect about Barbie
like again we talk about behaviors of
certain content creators in Hollywood
and you know when dudes is dudes is up
right and we the little you know we the
onions coming in the game and he's got
so much going on and he's like yeah I'll
do your show you know absolutely and I
was actually shocked you know what
addict told me like no I'm already
sitting down I'm like what you know in
early IOP early you know what I'm saying
like 5 10 15 people in the chat came
through and we had such a good time and
me personally some of the best back and
forth with King with bets and play like
he it is so much fun you know what I'm
saying and one thing about bart yeah he
loved PlayStation but it's never
personal like he's having fun you know
what I'm saying that's one thing I
respect about Jay Park of course he's
from the town so I'm biased as well you
know what I'm saying but look Bari I'm
so glad you was able to make it bro like
you mean a lot to to where where our
starter is and getting us there and
still supporting man and it's good to
see you so IOP 300 man wherever you want
to go hey man uh can you guys hear me
louder
yo this this podcast ain't what about me
but you still giving me an intro
yo the Iron Horse podcast they got the
best intro so it don't matter look
everybody that came up ahead to show
appreciation to you guys you guys gave
them a proper intro you know what I mean
uh so yeah this is all appreciation to
you guys man I've been rocking out with
you guys for a very very long time and I
just love the fact that you guys always
stayed very authentic uh to who you are
regardless if we disagree and our game
intakes or whatnot that's the most that
I respect about you guys because I
remember you guys was just like that
Destiny podcast
where where is it like yo y'all was in
that Destiny y'all was role-playing
for us
no no no no but but but but if you guys
look at it the overall scheme of thing
it whatever you did in the beginning
you're still doing here look at your
overlay look at everything you do within
your channel the the the the members
that come in the super chats are coming
it's very up that same kind of aesthetic
you might change this few things up a
little bit here and there but you still
have that very same raw aesthetic that
you had from where you started up it's
just now people are recognizing your
talents more and more and more and more
as people you know come in and and Vibe
with y'all man so the the fact that you
have all these people come up in here
that's that's let you know that you guys
are valid yeah that's a New York word
I'm sorry
you know what I mean and uh yeah I
appreciate you guys like I said uh you
know we can disagree all day we can go
back and forth you know King can come
for me all day
Jay
okay it's very early on I'm like who's
this
who's this like like like on Twitter
like you know not not what it was it was
you know it was the four horsemen it was
you uh Porter Rock Johnson
and one other mm-hmm and one by one I
went knocking y'all off oh my God
I don't care who he was he was war right
Jay Bari was standing there Toe to Toe
all day blow the blow pause we gonna get
this over with you ain't gonna run
through me like that pause and I'm
telling you
it was so dope that he was like oh you
picking up your PlayStation over here
what you may call it I'll be over there
oh we need the link facts and I said
that's real dude that's real that's real
dude you know I mean from my town I mean
I mean at the end of the at the end of
the day uh like I said people are going
to have different opinions when it come
to gaming but I I always respect to you
guys you know many people come to me
like yo our Lord learn life is always a
show respect because even when I was
doing stuff I never asked you guys for
nothing but I remember Cog was like hey
yo we gonna put the the online arcade in
our in our Discord
I love that dude to death man uh dizzy
was that dude where
he was always that bridge like it
doesn't matter like yo did you watch the
episode this week I was like ah you know
what let me
you know what I mean if you talk about
uh what's that art game
oh you should play that on Playstation
you in that video
I I never got a chance to tell you on it
you did the video and you got the most
respect from me
you didn't walk away from the knees
man of your world
yeah I'm watching your new podcast now
and um
yes I'm I'm liking this Statics I'm
liking everything about it you guys are
doing your thing I just wanted to tell
you respect and I'm so happy that you
know you you definitely tuned up today
and showed up today yeah yo Loki I'm
gonna give each of you guys your
individual respects as well you know I
mean Sav it's always the the the Silent
Assassin you know everybody did that
song is nice and all that stuff we
listen listen on YouTube you can scroll
all the way back to the early episodes
of when it's time you know like yeah he
knows this stuff I always appreciate him
where you know he's always a calm dude
but you know he definitely about his
gaming and what he does you know what I
mean shout out to my man addict addict
you know me addict you know we disagree
many times Well addict me and Addie
always had a cool relationship where uh
you know I have to give up more suspect
to at it too man you know when he gets
me on here to be a guest and sometimes
I'd be like I ain't trying to come and
be against the ruin your your Vibe and
what you're doing it's like nope nope
just like that I'm not gonna bother you
not going over I'm like yo it's all
right it's okay I I listen to the chat
it's cool man but not at it but not come
on through man you gotta come on through
and give your opinions out here man uh
my man already know the Vibes you know I
mean this is my guy right here uh
everything that people say about Cog is
is the utmost truth you know I mean it's
very genuine dude uh you know he'll hit
you up whenever it is you know what I
mean uh it's just it's just a cool guy
overall man you know I mean Cog is one
of those dudes that I'm pretty sure he
never got in a fight in high school
enough
oh oh you know
what I mean
guys you know my man king you know King
uh when it comes to you know back and
forth you know me and King we we we do
our thing but like I said I have almost
respect for him and King is always
always one of those guys that always
bothering me it's like you better get on
camera
you know
he been a girl I'm like okay man you
know when I get on camera I don't want
to be on the cell phone
camera you know I wanna make sure that
Journey's on point I always do it you
you on point okay why can't be on point
though
you know what I mean but yo shout out to
my man kicking man always a outstanding
dude
um like I said game and take sometimes
we disagree and that's cool that's cool
to go back and forth as long as you keep
respectful yeah I'm all for it man but
yo big shout out to everybody here
um everybody that came through and
showed love you know for the four hours
so that's one thing about y'all too man
this is why this is why I love you guys
man because you guys keep it to what you
guys know and who you guys are because
only only this podcast I know that can
go six hours seven hours and you still
have all these people here
y'all ain't even trying to rush it
either y'all let people talk y'all let
me do intros and all that stuff
big shout out to you guys man but Imma
shut up you know I'm pretty sure I'm
pretty tired of hearing this list but uh
brother all love thank you brother for
pulling up it's good to see you good to
see you here we got last
an apology I got him in trouble with his
family the man was here already thank
you addict for telling me to put it on
gallery view because I didn't even see
the brother was there that long and I'm
like him him and finds all an apology
because they was in here for the grind
when they when they were supposed to it
Cog hosted messed up so listen Texas is
on
independent Outlet
Level One gaming one of the coolest
organizations great writers great team
y'all got a support man y'all talking
about support I gotta support Level One
gaming Fame entertainment use we used to
be on the same team together
Carlisle tech gaming we came up together
you know what I'm saying to see his
journey I'm so happy you took the time
out for iop300 I apologize that you're
waiting but it's good that you came back
so you get your balls listen let's go
face listen I told you I told you last
Monday my wife is is Puerto Rican and
she's from Philly she got hands you got
me two-piece stuff
I got what I have to get done like I put
some makeup on to cover the black guys
I got it done but listen I I I I want to
make sure I made a perfect message I
said hey man if I gotta make a video I
make a video because I want to make sure
I come through and show love to you boy
was right because y'all y'all been
nothing nothing but the most cool people
in this community right and and it
really goes back like you said back in
the tick days uh and and like a lot of
people said that bridge really was
Disney a lot of people don't know dizzy
yeah uh co-host the double XP podcast
with me he was he was my co-host it was
me and him rocking and that's how I
found out about you guys and with all
the tick and like my biggest regret is I
didn't get to know you guys we was in
the same building in different offices
you know what I'm saying like the
biggest regret I never really got to
rock with you guys like that man and to
see you guys grow and see what you guys
are doing is super inspirational from
from from the no cursing which I've been
I implemented on my show now like
everybody
see them over there doing their thing so
we got the custom out over there man and
what y'all doing is like super
inspirational man and um I I want to
show some some extra love to solve
because I was the one person on the crew
I feel like I never really got to meet
uh and talk to man so uh from the bottom
of my heart man you left with somebody I
want to get to know a whole lot more on
a personal level addict has always been
that dude even if we don't disagree we
didn't have stupid you know arguments
over stuff but attic has always been a
stand-up guy uh King
I'll be honest with you bro a couple
years ago packs East I had I had a
situation I couldn't make it out there
right right so my homeboy Baron who
co-owns level one was out there by
itself right and he said you are the
reason he got so much work done he said
come on tomorrow hey what you doing get
this up get this out get this where's
your camera now why your camera now
right and he was just talking about how
much those words meant to him and it
pushed to motivate him and and it pretty
much you were the you were that that
person to to help get level one work
done because I couldn't make it bro so I
definitely appreciate you for that man
that's that that's a you got to be a
real one to see someone out there in in
the same field as yourself and not look
at us oh it's competition you understand
we all could eat and you want to see
others win bro not a lot of people will
do that not a lot of people are about
that they don't they don't really
courtesy of others win but one thing
that the our Lords do you guys make sure
others win as well and that's and that's
and that's love man
I I don't know what to say I try not to
go too long because I want to hold on no
but I mean I got to give you your
flowers as well you know at the same
time because we come from each one to
each one right I come from that school
of you only as strong as the next person
next to you so I see my brother there
and he is my brother you know uh level
one game and Nate I don't care if we was
in the same building in different
offices we were still you know team
regardless to what you know and that's
exactly how I looked at it regardless
um but I see him out there and I'm just
giving him some pointers okay he said
I'm I'm by myself or whatever okay so
this is what you want to do and this is
how I'm doing it and I can give you a
format on how to get this done all right
you got to go down get as much as you
can get come up load up as much as you
can and go right back down you want to
flood as much uh content as you possibly
can get because there's people counting
on you all right there's that one person
that's probably at dialysis or whatever
who can't make it out here to these
places and he's looking for your opinion
he rocks with you or she rocks with you
right so I'm just trying to pass on a
little something that I know and I know
that I had big homies do that to me so
I'm never gonna see somebody sitting
someplace I don't care what color you
are regardless to what if you're having
a struggle you're struggling a little
bit and I'm there to help I'm going to
help
um I didn't interject then in true but
also no Baron right and and I know you
guys and I see the work that you're
doing I see y'all on Tick Tock I see
y'all on Twitch I see y'all every place
you know
um from each and every last one you do
so I respect y'all and I was just
showing that same courtesy in that
respect because if my brother's in a
foreign land and somebody else is out
there I want that person to look out for
my brother too so that's all I did
see and that's that's that's love that
that's the beauty of of you and you guys
ilps that you you guys care about other
people and that's that's rare believe it
or not man that's that's right you want
to think that everyone's a good person
right but you guys you guys genuinely
put that love and that respect I thought
man and that's something that that they
can't be replicated they got to come
naturally you know you see how people
are trying to fake it till they make it
but it's genuin with you guys right it's
hella genuine and and Cog man we like so
we spoke you know pre-show and post show
or 15 minutes of fame man and just
seeing that where we are intellectually
on the same level and I I can talk to
you like like I didn't know you as long
as you've been knowing King I thought I
mean that's that's that that's amazing
man and what you guys are doing right
you guys are the only podcast that can
get me beat up on a Sunday
shout out to your wife shout out to my
wife let you go through I I messed up so
tell her tell her tell them about
apologies I have my man sitting in there
didn't put it in gallery mode didn't
know he was even in there until addict
show I'm like oh no so yo bro it is so
good to see you the ties the history we
came up together we came up together
right yeah and listen bro this right
here I can't I can't do nothing bro
this is mandatory now bro
you're really comfortable yes are you
really comfortable are you really
comfortable fast
let me ask you a question after gaming
with it right
how how do you try to game without it
like your hands how you rest your hands
you can right you can't I'm sitting like
what the heck what do I do
we need to ever have a conversion with
flames
bro so when this came that box I
remember when Alex sent me the email and
he's like oh yeah y'all receive me a box
of bees about to get pumped
and when it came I was like yo like this
this is mad comfortable like I'm sitting
on podcast I'm just arms folded like
just super comfortable bro but that that
just gonna show man you guys man
um and the fact that my favorite episode
right it's kind of like this one it was
almost like the Multiverse Saga people's
coming in through like doctor strange
and y'all just calling folks in from the
Multiverse I mean it was it was super
dope man and uh I appreciate you calling
for for letting me come back in because
I I definitely want to show you guys
some love however I can show it man uh
because you guys are definitely some
real ones uh I love seeing people like
me succeed
um and don't get a twisted addict inside
of this light skin
[Laughter]
so it's love to see you here oh man so
much words to say and we have another
gentleman that just pulled up new
Challenger and I am so happy to see you
I am so happy this is my flannel
Brethren my beautiful dude
my defining Duke bro listen man
get it listen I remember having the
comments ran was here early and I
remember having a conversation shout out
to ACG who was also who left something
for us earlier but I remember when ACG
left and I was just like everybody was
like yo you know I wonder what they're
gonna do with the filing dude I was like
yeah I wonder what they're gonna do you
don't say like real talk like I wasn't
even thinking about anything like that
and and I remember Rand saying like nah
bro I'm like stop me I don't I don't
have the subscribers and the typical
thing that you would think where people
look for just metrics and I never forget
coming home and seeing my phone and
seeing a DM
please
I was like wait a minute is this what I
think it is am I getting it's like I got
drafted you know like the NBA NFL like
you like hold on and you get the car
they ride their whole family yeah so I
hit I hit the I hit the Lords up
I think Daddy just yo yeah it's
everybody kicks it man if you don't he
said if you don't Trump is asking me
permission he was like he was like yo
but they was disgusting with me buddy
he's like how dare you ask for
permission to do the final they was like
you shot it makes us better you Obama
brothers so my brothers gave me the okay
attic I said it's okay cool it's like
but hell yeah
I'm gonna respond to this DM for Mr
mattyblies
and since then man the Friendship the
chemistry like the jokes we could just
talk about anything and and I just love
the fact as a host being not able not
not having to be a host whatever with
you and I could just talk and be myself
and bro I'm so happy you made it I know
you had personal things going on today
for the for the record I like I I didn't
expect you because I know you told me
like you can see the fan right back yeah
the man ain't got no AC is a lot serious
I'm serious right now is Nintendo
sweating yeah
brother I'm Gonna Keep it quick but I
had to get my flowers thank you so much
for showing up the defining Duke man
himself IOP 300 great to have you
anywhere in Chicago
I'd be yeah I thought I was the one here
coming to gas you up you spent how long
can I talk me up man I thought that's
why I was here for to you know share
some words share the gospel of ILP but
you know I appreciate it and uh yeah
it's funny because you talk about like
me hosting and you just get to show up
but you make my job easy because I'm
just like all right bro here's the topic
you just run with it you just run with
it I'm like all right I can take a drink
um I mean I I don't know where to start
because I was I'm kind of coming into
this like because I wasn't sure if I was
gonna make it or not but I mean talking
about you guys in a positive way really
isn't too difficult right it's uh it's
easy to find the words because you know
when I was thinking about it you know
it's like what does iot mean to Mr
Maddie you know I think it was
um you invited me on for an episode and
uh watching what you guys do is a
reminder to me that
you know it's I take things seriously so
what's up with that so for me it's a
good reminder to have fun with it and I
feel like no one on the internet truly
has that balance like you guys do of
having fun
while also uh having those deep Dives
and it's really tough to balance that
man like you're either really one or the
other but you guys just walk that line I
think it's because you literally have
the perfect set of hosts and you got
that guest involvement like no one says
anything bad about IOP I'm sure you
already know that but I'm just saying in
general as someone who's been around
guessed it on some shows here's the talk
no one's ever said anything bad but you
know what I appreciate more than
anything guys is
um you know when I brought Cog in uh you
know that's that's one thing right but
the way all of you embraced me and kind
of made me feel part of that family
um not to claim ILP ownership by Amy
just I feel that way like I feel a
connection with you guys when I saw King
like King we've only met in person once
but like when when Cog tells stories I
feel like I know you way better and I
really do probably
um SOB when I see you bro it's easy
deaths like just what's up bro hugs like
a joke around attic same thing it's you
know me and act are always talking the
review game so I don't know you guys I
consider you close friends even though
the interactions are few and far between
and I think that just speaks to your
character I think that speaks to the fun
you have the welcome environment you
have like when I run into you guys at
PAX East it's it's it's like a it's like
a bunch of kids but I say that in a nice
way you're having so much fun taking
pictures copper and everything it's it's
so much fun to watch you guys work and
it's a good reminder to I think everyone
in the industry to take a minute pause
and remember why we do this um
there's a lot of ways we got to improve
there's a lot of ways we gotta
um take things seriously of course but
games are fun and games bring us
together as cornies that sounds and I
think you guys in the especially the
podcast face are like the the leaders of
what that means truly and that's the
thing that always comes to mind is I I
like Cog I host a show with you and I
sometimes look at Duke and I'll hear
what you talk about IOP I'm like I gotta
loosen up I was like I got it I gotta
loosen up but I you know it's it's just
uh just watching you guys is such a joy
you know for for everything I do I'm
always working and everything and and
this is the show that when I'm like I
want a podcast like this is the one I
hear from Cog multiple times a week I'm
still like nah I gotta hear it I got
fired up I gotta hear what y'all are
talking about what's the debate this
week what's the king hot take like you
know because him and I are eye to eye on
that stuff and uh yeah it's just always
a pleasure it's always a pleasure to be
around to be involved in any way shape
or form and uh uh just to call you guys
friends man uh it's it's incredible so
you know thank you for what you do
because it's inspiring to me thank you
brother much appreciated
um
anytime it comes to LSM solve a tougher
day so happy your boss be crazy today
ain't no
let me talk cause I never talk oh
I mean no no no I mean you this is you
this is you today
continue
I did not know Maddie was so tall yes
I'm sorry I don't care when I saw Maddie
I was like yo that's Maddie yo it was
tall people this is how tall people
greet tall people
right here and then we went over to the
wrestling stuff
um and like you said it just feels like
I don't know for some weird reason to
feel like I know him more than I'm
supposed to know him right I feel the
same way about you like anytime Cog
talks about your holidays I'm like yeah
it sounds like King I can only talk to
him a handful of times
put around him a ton
um if anybody's wondering yeah the smile
is insane in person as it is on camera
um
yo we we got there and I just want to
say thank you for uh welcoming my
brother on
um being Who You Are uh to make them
feel comfortable and welcome uh with you
on in doing it because you know to step
into ACG shoes
that's huge it must have been daunting
going in but not one time did he say
that he felt uncomfortable I'm not
saying that my guy is not capable of
doing such great feats I'm just saying
that you had a welcoming environment for
him
um just the whole LSM uh team has been
welcoming and inviting for him and you
got showed out today I do appreciate you
guys turning up and showing up uh so and
you ain't got no AC on so I'm not gonna
keep you on longer no guys look I'm not
in a rush I kept the window open I fan
this room down so we got we got time we
got time to really show some love here
at daycare but the temperature will go
up over time but don't worry do not feel
pressed at all
um you know it's my pleasure you know
for what it's worth you know I didn't
have any doubts in COG you know at all I
obviously I didn't if I was to invite
him on but
um yeah it's my pleasure to to make that
kind of environment but it's really a
testament to the community like more
than anything I can do what I can
because I just want to make this job
easy but you know the community at LSM
really makes it worthwhile for all of us
and and they're their their vocal
supporter Cog like I I don't say in this
Envy as well though I I I only say that
because I think it can come off that way
but I always say like cog's the favorite
of the show and that's totally fine
because like I want that because like
like to me like this dude's just a
Hidden Gem on the web that needs that
exposure and so to to kind of bring him
to the masses and see people go like
yeah he is
I remember who I am now yeah this dude
does Rock
um you know it was it's awesome to see
for me it's rewarding because I you know
for me like there's that nerve of like
am I gonna pick the right guy when life
happens and we gotta find a new host
like pick that right guy and and with
Cog it was it's funny we I hopped on ILP
once Cog guested on the show with
Carrick and I yes for our predictions
and it was then I was like I had the
idea of like well I want all three of us
together like that is a show
um so to me I just had no doubts it was
just when Cog say yes or no but you know
it's of course my pleasure to to try to
help to make that environment in a place
where he can Thrive and succeed but it's
really all to that community that that
welcomes it both in with uh with open
arms even when my takes are pretty
egregious
speaking of egregious takes that you can
solve you have anything you want to say
I appreciate that
Cog will on Bounce like I'll have this
reasonable take on death Loop or
something like I'll go throw something
out there and that's where the
favoritism will get me topsy-turvy
because it's not a boy death Loop is
pretty good I'm like no come on man you
can't do it yeah
cocktails the line very well
but I will say I remember when he first
went on and I noticed you know I always
listen to I'm like I told I put them to
the side I'm like [__] you guys are
going the back and forth is it it feels
it's feeling like very sort of planned
kind of like oh what do you think about
this and what do you think about it I
was like you know you guys don't speak
to each other that way let's let's get
let's you know be yourself just be
yourself be yourself I knew he was just
nervous because again like King said
he's stepping into carrick's shoes and
although you shouldn't have any
comparisons it's gonna be made because
you know the community is going to make
comparisons yeah and I just remember
after I said that to him like the
following show it was just a lot
smoother I was like yes you guys have
been yourselves back and forth and then
from then on it was just like you could
already see the chemistry so again for
me
when he came and he was like I think
they're going to ask me to be undefined
Duke I'm like why are you asking me bro
yeah permission are you nuts you're
talking about respect yeah but um uh
yeah man I I just love the chemistry
with you guys it was fantastic being on
that show with you guys and again uh
thank you for coming through Maddie
because again it is one of those things
like again when any of these guys
vouchers for somebody that's fam to me
and I and I've always felt that vibe
from you so I appreciate that man of
course of course any any bars for Mr
Maddie plagues yeah I just have to
apologize to everyone I am eating
currently we're 5 30 in so you're gonna
have to deal with it we haven't finished
intros yet attic what are you talking
about
so first off I want to appreciate Matt
for coming on you know what's funny is
me and you agree on just about anything
I'd definitely do yeah but definitely
yeah that's the only thing because we
have similar tasting games and every
time you say well definitely wasn't a
good game like oh I wish I was on this
show right now
you had thousands of others
death is just misunderstood
this is wow what an amazing episode have
Maddie come through towards the end even
if it you know it means a lot just the
community everybody you know just still
here rocking which I'm surprised is
awesome this is I thought just forgot
his camera
I ain't got my camera on because I got
some kind of weird skin outbreak and I
don't want to freak everyone out
you look like a zombie right now nah you
good brother you good but I appreciate
you taking the time out but um yeah man
this is this is special I know this is a
typical a usually long episode of IOP
how we always do kind of crazy today but
not listen it's just the love you gotta
you know you have to receive you have to
receive sometimes it just just just hear
people sometimes we don't celebrate but
wins enough I think you know and it it's
cool man that that that people came up
and people respect our peers that just
means a lot buddy thank you brother
Jesse of course yeah of course I saw the
uh the picture on LSM they uh they put
in the defining Duke Discord it was a
screenshot it you guys had like a room
of like 20 people or something and there
were all these faces big names in the
industry I'm like that's love right
there if you all didn't know what how
your viewing the industry like that
picture you just gotta look at and
that's your reminder so yeah absolutely
I want to have a
a
a democracy where we get rid of ff16
it's the only Cloud it uh initiative we
could just talk about redfall and get up
out of here we got the back doors right
there
we got to do this super chat
but oh yeah guys anybody I don't know if
Chris Hart's still in the chat but he
wanted to come in for a second I think
okay
the doors are locked we had two people
to help me eat and then there was doors
will lock after those two if they were
able to make it so yeah okay yeah so he
sent it out yeah okay yeah I sent it out
to eat we said I mean you know what you
call it dude anybody said that let me
see because yeah oh you did send no I
did not oh okay you did okay okay I'll
take care of it I'll take care of it so
we do that because I know um he is
coming and he's an OG he's been there
from the beginning we got to get his his
bars in there
no no not that either
but you know oh
yeah there we go okay see oh man I got a
new guy all my clothes eight pounds uh
ounces congratulations santel to you and
yeah yeah yeah your significant number
wow we got a baby
that's crazy
it's a big baby
now this one means a lot to me that e is
here because um
he he's different he's built different
like he is did he carry his whole setup
with him yes
he took a whole flight got over there
he's back he's back okay but he listen
we we did something special in the
beginning with um addict me stood up all
night because we like yo if we're going
to do the the whole 300 we got to start
from the essence I lost podcast was a
destiny focused podcast first right and
outside of that before we branched out
to open games and and made it
multi-platform you know he was the one
of our very first guests and you saw the
little icon in there like IOP number 10
or whatever that episode was adding
weird and I seen it I think it was 14.
yeah I was like yo Eva
and obviously I met this brother for the
last word y'all know the story you know
in Florida Tampa Bay Fairgrounds you
know hot sun because we love this damn
game so so much you know what I mean so
much sweat and I see this guy and I'm
like yo we're sitting there I forgot I
think it was the Guardians the who's
those guys the Guardians both um
we've got the the podcast
Guardian radio Guardian radio Garden
we're all fans of Guardian radio and I
see him there and we start talking and
I'm like man this kid knows this that's
the he knows games and we started that
thing man at the world
seriously curse of Osiris because like
bottom point of Destiny 2 which was
already a bad lunch we're like cool
let's start a destiny podcast that was a
great idea exchange business cards and
the rest is history the last word is
going on to be something special we've
been you know he he's heard my
frustrations he's probably one of the
few places get it right it was called
Flashpoint yeah right I changed names I
got so much respect for you because as
big as he were at the bigger than us at
the time wanted to do a pocket with me
but at the same time he's one of the few
people I would tell my frustrations like
damn man I just wish we could be a
little bit bigger I wish you know people
get so he's seeing the journey and
things unfold and I'm so proud of him
and I'm so proud to call him a friend
you know I met this man multiple times
his beautiful wife and listen man I had
to have you I had to have you here man
so e any word you literally made the
podcast long enough for my flight yeah
tradition is compelled IOP long show but
any word yeah no seriously now we know
what happened Cog did this intentionally
yes are you just showing us your butt
right now
that's the love I get from Atticus no uh
no seriously like yeah when you guys are
hitting 300 that's huge and I mean it's
an honor to even be a part of any
podcast ever just ask to be invited on
any podcast ever always feels like an
honor it doesn't matter how big you are
typically it's always just a good time
to chat with people and you come on here
and there's no way you're not gonna have
a good have a good time whether knees
are at risk
sometimes that happens uh whether it's
like amazing figurines you know you got
like crazy skill when addict and I are
going back and forth on who's going to
beat the first I think he beat me on the
final guy because he kicked my butt for
a while
um and then Lord saw solo player that is
literally like my entire channel so I
mean like we get along pretty well
across the board with all of us and I
haven't actually haven't haven't had a
chance to speak to Maddie yet but it's
actually cool to see you in here because
I've been watching you guys literally
since uh Cog jumped on there and for
Xbox Xbox podcast that I listen to It's
like I've told Cog previously
um do you guys Cog is like the the
in-between of both of them but like the
dichotomy of ILP and
um defining Duke it's it's a really good
balance of both to get like the fun kind
of Rowdy like shooting it up just having
a good time with each other and then
Maddie coming in with the professional
show but you guys have some of the most
ridiculous write-in questions that I
have ever heard of in my entire life
the macaroni and cheese debate in my
house is very easy that wasn't a problem
it is definitely Fork no question about
it
oh no my wife and I are married on
account of us both looking like like
craft spirals with a fork like that is
one of our like Comfort Foods I was
gonna invite you as ddu guest but I
can't oh
you're messed up
I just ruined it right it's a spoon and
we'll talk
I'll spoon you how's that well
let me
hey if nothing if Travis isn't here
somebody's got to make the show Travis
is definitely I'm used to that's always
amazing somebody's going to make the
show like possibly demonetize that no
between you guys talking about like
Oreos and other stuff and then just uh
there are times when I will turn on ILP
and King is in the middle of like a rant
it's either the Phil Dominus rant or how
ridiculous the PlayStation crowd is it's
hilarious on both sides and I know it so
um no like honestly like you guys are a
fantastic show always need to have like
10 times your numbers if not way way
more uh and then the guests are proven
it and that's the one I've seen in the
past couple of years especially is the
the guests in the caliber of people you
guys have the time you keep them around
most guests that you guys would see for
any larger company or anybody who comes
in to talk to you they might be like hey
we got 30 minutes I got Max you guys
keep these guests forever I don't know
how you do it
so it's it's always impressive the yeah
the respect you guys have for the guests
but the amount of like
just the little like strings that you
can pull out of them once they just
start really get comfortable shooting it
up with you guys
um
so it's that type of stuff like how you
guys do some of those things always is
impressed and how you guys run a show
for as long as you do week by week that
is the dedication right there so no much
love for you guys I mean I'm lucky to
call Cognito a podcast co-hosts and then
just to have been on here like you know
one two times before I think
um yeah no much love and then yeah
Maddie someday maybe I'll uh I'll Grace
that one but we'll have to talk about it
think about your Castle sir that's all
think about your life choice
we'll figure it out we'll figure it okay
we'll make you a cheesecake and I'll
make it all better it's fine how to cook
the chef chef look e-man delicious thank
you so much brother to have both of you
is like this is my week my podcasting
week
you know everyone here yeah it just
means a lot man thank you so much for
showing up wouldn't be completed without
you Travis Maddie the Lords it's meant
to be brother thank you IOP 300 First
topic done thank you for everyone
thank you that's your episode save the
topics for next week it's gonna be hard
let's see but I appreciate y'all showing
up oh so let me know how you want to
handle I could do paid shot stuff
you wanted you want to go through all
these stupid tests now and then get into
redfall or I don't know how you want to
do it um I do have two patriarch
questions in the poll and then we just
like red four as the thing so if I want
to do that no performance mode
oh come on I mean everybody has their
flubs I mean I would say yeah we go
through that and leave super chats for
the End come to get Maddie here we go
here so let's talk about let's talk
redfall yeah
rest
if I invited to hang around for redfall
was that oh yeah
you you
[Laughter]
what two games would you combine to make
the perfect game this is from Brian what
does that perfect game look like and why
so anybody can answer that from the
realm if you could combine to two games
to make the perfect game
yes please add it all right I'm gonna
throw two actually okay one is gonna be
Final Fantasy and Persona
because I feel like that would be
remedying the the issues I see Final
Fantasy having and the next one would be
x-coming midnight size
to actually video on some x-cons okay
okay okay okay get rid of the cards I
got you any uh games for something get
rid of everything but the concept of the
characters so okay
um mine would be uh breath of the wild
and Elden ring
okay okay
um the the reasons why uh I like the the
movement in breath of the wild uh you
know the climbing and stuff like that
and then the open worldness of
everything they they pretty much the
same as just I think Zelda is missing
what Eldon ring has and I think as Elder
ring is missing what Zelda has and if
you can put those two together you have
the perfect game
um so if if I was ever able to do that
that's exactly what I would do you could
solve any two games that you liked that
you would maybe combine
I would say red dead and Deus Ex
oh okay that's crazy right there just
did rock star games
don't throw it out don't spit it out
though
whoa hold it hold that hold it hold it
hold it
anything involved in Tekken but the
fighting game match but I want it I
think second attempted to try where it's
like a quest game I think you remember
that one I think that was checking two
right yeah no it was what was it called
Tekken Force Mode Force mode so I want a
Final Fantasy 7 ish like world and
engine like a hub where you actually do
stuff and it's a cinematic historian and
it's going on and then the battles be
the fighting you know say like a true
RPG fighter kind of thing and I see it I
know Final Fantasy 16 is atomic like ca
Final Fantasy it had be like crazy
inspired so it looked good yeah it
looked really good so that was those
were my two um on the pole we will last
week's results were in as far as to the
question with the news and rumors of new
handhelds emerging which of these has
your most excited the winner of the poll
37 was the new Switch Pro Group at 37
close 30 percent was uh Microsoft I
don't care you need to make a native x
boy handheld that was 30 19 was the
newcomer Asus Rog Ally the Steve Decker
killer and last place 13
Q light handheld so it looks like attic
do people agree with you switch gang
switch game switch gang they good with
that obviously because people go where
the games are and until these companies
are realize that they're just going to
keep playing games they can already play
in their steam or their laptop like fair
enough and now so we're going to get
into the topic because we're gonna do
the super chances all last right there
and that's how we know yeah yeah because
we don't want to mess up the flow so um
this is it solved this is your topic uh
controversy huh
red fall it's uh announcer should you
set it up oh you got it you got it I got
it you got it why is soft setting up go
back to speaker mode okay yes thank you
okay good good hosting good hosting
yeah so uh on Wednesday of this week uh
Bethesda confirmed that red fall would
be launching on serious consoles at 30
FPS with a 60fps performance mode to be
added later via game update although
they did not give a time frame for said
update and
the internet went crazy
as the internet does as the internet
does the internet went crazy
um
I want to know what you guys think
because for me
in an adjustable and in a just world
this should not be a big deal
but it is
and I'm usually the one that
doesn't really go with the whole sort of
hey the game's done because of this but
I will say this
30 FPS at launch no 60fps performance
mode is an l
is an l and it's an L that maybe maybe
that narrative shouldn't exist but the
fact of the matter is that it does
and I firmly believe in
a game having its moment and being able
to shine in its brightest light
when it launches because after that I
always talk about the Zeitgeist moment
and the Zeitgeist moment it's very hard
to recapture that for a game that's not
built to be a service based game with
the inherent sort of Hills and Valleys
that go along with that where it gets a
second moment to sort of shine so this
for some may not be a big deal
for many that are in the know that if
you're if you're a core gamer on the
Xbox series X or s 60 FPS is something
that you've come to
expect in some way shape or form I think
um 30 FPS
for any other reason other that we just
can't make it on time
um
feels like they're not reading the room
properly and I don't know what it is
right it could be an optimization thing
right that it's just not they're not
able to finish it on time or it could be
an issue where it isn't as much of a
priority as we would like it to be
um but I want to know the second one I
want to know where you guys land because
there I've I've long thought that the
idea of 60fps on consoles why haven't it
why hasn't this been the norm
for a long time now right and it's
always been CPU bottleneck CPU
bottleneck has has kept us from being
able to to sort of hit that but why is
there that CPU bottleneck obviously
prices and stuff like that when you talk
about consoles consoles is always a
compromise right you have a system on a
chip it's a compromise that you're
making and when you think about consoles
and how intrinsically they they're
linked to new televisions and and things
of that nature
oftentimes
they're going to have resolution and the
look of the game supersede the
performance especially on the console
side so my thinking is is there a
possibility that that not reading the
room in the way that us hardcore would
like them to read the room and generally
they're not seeing the 60 FPS as much uh
of a necessity as we think it is and 30
FPS is fine with them and so much so
that
I don't know that they'd see that it's
going to harm the game at its launch in
the way that some of us feel that that
it's going to so for me I just don't it
just feels like
when we talk about the console space
when we jump into a brand new console
generation like all the bells and
whistles 60fps we're going to get all
this hot stuff Ray tracing all that
stuff as it's panned out a lot of that
stuff has been difficult to come by in a
in a regular fashion because for
whatever reason optimization stuff like
that it just hasn't been there yet the
problem with that is that that scale in
the console space const that goal post
constantly moves so when we think we're
over one hurdle there's another hurdle
already there that's keeping us away
from that 60 FPS sweet spot that we
think should be the norm right so right
now we're talking about oh people trying
to implement Ray tracing and Kai was
talking to me about this the other day
hey Ray tracing they too much
implementation of Ray tracing is keeping
is keeping these games from being able
to hit that 60 FPS optimized uh
optimization that's one thing the 4K
aspect of the true 4K and and trying to
figure out ways around that because true
4K takes a lot of juice and all of a
sudden now you can't hit that 60 FPS so
I just think in the console space
it's almost like they they don't care
about it as much and that sucks because
to me and as we as we look to the Future
and the possibilities of mid-gen
refreshes we may be looking at mid-gen
refreshes that are going to focus on you
know
8K as opposed to 60 FPS right if we if
we look at what happened with the uh the
PS4 Pro and even the 1X
those Jaguar cores didn't improve right
they got a little a little bit more
juice in them but that was it for the
most part this is a graphical upgrade
and my fear is that that's what we start
seeing because their thinking is
consoles means TV means resolution
performance doesn't matter as much and I
just I I kind of think it sucks I think
the game's gonna suffer for it I don't
know that if it matters across the board
as much as us hardcore in this bubble so
you kind of see it and it's it sucks do
you think there's a possibility that you
think that the data and the metrics may
prove otherwise based on 30 frames per
second and what you know they may
realize that Gamers maybe it's a subset
of Hardcore Gamers that value overvalue
that as opposed to the Casual Gamer well
you got to remember yeah that in the
console space 60fps is a norm
has even not even this generation it's
kind of been the thing you you you're
sort of getting performance modes but
I've seen plenty of people that have
that performance mode and they're like
I'd rather run at a 4K 30 with whatever
a little bit of Ray tracing they're able
to pull off or whatever the case may be
um so there's still a lot of that people
like I wanna I wanna get the most out of
my television right and when they say
the most out of the television to be
resolution they don't mean performance
they don't necessarily mean 120 FPS mode
because 120 fpf mode depending on the
game makes the game look a lot more
Vaseline than it it's not as crisp so to
me maybe it is a metric thing where
they're just looking at that it's like
it's not nearly as important we'll give
it to the guys that want it later on but
we're willing to risk that sort of
zeitgeist moments up front
for the possibility that it's not going
to matter in the long term or the people
that care about it aren't you know are
very small percentage of that hardcore
um and the hope that that that narrative
doesn't paint the entire narrative for
the game at launch and to me it's sad
because I think redfall is one of those
games that it has to come out of the
gate strong in every way possible it can
because it's not it's not a game that's
really built to have that second sort of
coming that you know that that second go
around it is kind of it isn't a service
based game in that way so it's just I
don't know again we could be over
exaggerated I could be over exaggerating
it but I just think in this day and age
just should not be that way I just don't
think it just feels like they're not
reading the room in the right way and
maybe maybe I'm off in that thinking I
don't know let's get our guests uh Mr
batty please define the book in the
building still so now that you have a
little bit more time to resonate on this
we've had this discussion you know what
are your thoughts about what Sam is
saying about the 30 frames per second
read for announcement yeah I agree it's
definitely an L in my book like I think
saw pretty much echoed everything I said
undefining Duke so to carry my thoughts
one step forward from that
what I'd say is this is probably in the
first party realm so far the biggest
test Game Pass is gonna face in my eyes
like this is gonna be the real moment we
all learn the virality of it does 30
matter does the negative Twitter yapping
does that matter does any of this matter
or are we kind of in our own bubble here
and I think it's a good one to pay
attention to because I think Xbox is
going to rock with it I don't think
they're gonna delay the game I don't say
all that because I think they're they're
looking at this scene all right we're
gonna see what this hat if this works
out really well and we have the highest
player count ever for an Arcane game you
know that's what Phil's always talked
about with bethesda's game studios we
want Starfield to be the most played
Bethesda game he never says highest
selling so that turns out to be by their
metric a success for redfall then
they're gonna feel really cool calm
collected going into starfield's launch
and as long as they're gaining Game Pass
Subs maybe they don't care
um I completely agree though that you
want to put your best foot forward to me
as an Xbox fan it feels a little icky
that when a game goes exclusive and no
longer multiplat we're still getting 30
frames I feel like when you cut those
skus down and you're able to focus on
that one platform the expectation from
the consumer no matter the technical
complications which are beyond the
average consumer's knowledge set the
expectation coming in is I'm getting the
because you are giving to this me to me
exclusively on this platform I'm getting
the best possible version that was only
made through this collaboration of
Microsoft and Bethesda and especially
you know the problem HiFi Rush puts like
a little asterisk next to this but still
but this is the first fully marketed
we've known about it for a while there's
been a build up to it Bethesda first
party game coming out that's a Microsoft
or XBox exclusive it does feel really
weird that it's sort of coming out 30
frames it kind of feels like a whatever
game to some now uh but again that's
where it just circles back around to me
to game it's like they get millions of
downloads and new Subs I mean
this might not matter to them
um but I I talked about Xbox in some
realm sometimes appearing to me as
complacent
um I think that's set in when we saw the
major delay last year it felt like a
reset for fans when they said all right
right before the Big Summer showcase
Starfield revfall delayed it felt like
that was everyone just Gathering
themselves one last time to wait because
we all agreed you know what if XBox
wants to hit that PlayStation level
which we always thought about we want to
hit the PlayStation premium quality
we're gonna have to wait and when you
wait all that time and you think about
all the times we saw redfall between now
and then for it to just be announced now
I imagine it was a feature plan that got
cut it's a very bad look and it reminds
me of again what I said on on Duke which
is that kind of I call it the silver
metal specialist like
it's just kind of they're just loving
second place and they just they don't
mind they're like yeah we're doing well
enough for our own standards so who
cares about running the whole show and
if that's the energy they want to tackle
with then
okay that's fine just be prepared for
the lashing from fans online be prepared
for these Reactions where uh just one
last thing I'll Echo from Saab is yeah
man when this is PlayStation with think
of it this way when The Last of Us rolls
around on PC it's a joke of a port no
doubt about it really funny glitches
um and in some ways for people they're
calling it Fallout 76 level which
pretty intense but point being it's
really buggy but when you look at that
does that shake your faith in
PlayStation the answer will vary but for
me no I don't look at that and go well
what's happening with Spider-Man 2 I'm
worried now but with Xbox fans that's
the cascading effect that happens every
time we looked at redfall what was the
first topic Cog that we got into
Starfield what's that what about Hellboy
hellblade's ue5 that's graphically
intense it just immediately domino
effect right so that's the problem they
face is they can't just have isolated
issues they have
chain reactions because of years of just
not delivering to fans in your eyes but
at the same time you got to take your
wins where you can they may not have the
exclusives to some but Game Pass is
working xcloud is has only grown more
and more the user base has grown more
and more so it's as I've got further
from the topic I still find it extremely
frustrating but I definitely expect Xbox
to ride this one out because I think if
it plays out in their favor uh they're
going to be happy they did and there's
going to be a lot of I Told You So
energy especially coming our way God
but uh yeah that's where I stand on it
no doubt Lord addict the news hit Arcane
put out the Tweet they were like reforms
launching on consoles with quality mode
only series X 4K 30 series s 1440p 30 60
frames will be added via game update at
a later date
I think this might be one of the biggest
else Microsoft's had in a while I think
I think the biggest issue with this is
the messaging in the past you know
yeah you love Aaron Greenberg to death
but you go on Twitter and you say yo the
new standard 60. and you know not only
are we doing 60 but we're going above
that and doing 120. people are going to
assume that people are going to take you
literal on that and the part that
frustrates me the most is like you
really sit down you think and I want you
all to sit down and think when's the
last time we played a 30 frame game that
wasn't on the switch
um plate tail Plateau yeah plague tail
and besides that you can't really name
many since the Xbox series X came out
even the series s the majority of the
games have been 60 frames right and to
me
you expect me to go back to that
like I I just
I find it I find it hilarious
that someone thought this was going to
be a good idea right it's just like to
me I hope it's not Maddie what Maddie
said and maybe it wasn't a priority I
hope it's one of those things where
something happened at the last minute
and even though they didn't want to do
it they couldn't get it at day one
because if it's something that wasn't a
priority
that's an issue because at the end of
the day with the reason that PlayStation
doesn't get attacked for this is
multiple reasons one because they
deliver solid content throughout the
year sure so many for you some are for
you and two they don't go out there
screaming 60 frames from the top of the
uh of the rooftops they don't got their
screaming that their console is the
strongest on the market for the what
monsters eat monsters like it's just
like look like
this is one of those things where Xbox
is marketing and it was genius marketing
at the time but now it's coming back and
it's hitting them full force and it's
just like look you know maybe this
particular thing it's an isolated
incident maybe we won't see it again but
the problem is
is you're making me look at this redfall
which is something that you've been
highly marketing and I'm like if you
didn't take the time or delay this game
to make sure this game was at 16 and ran
the best it possibly could what makes
you what what makes you think that you
could convince me that Starfield isn't
on this list too what makes you convince
me that Fable isn't on this list too
because redfall is a very
highly anticipate again that they've
been marketing and pushing since the
thing got announced and to me it's like
look you guys got to do better we don't
need to be playing these games like we
played them in the 360. like and what's
funny is you're pushing me to play this
game on PC which I don't want to do and
it's like well it's what Clover said on
Twitter
you are pushing me off of your own
platform
on the PC that you're gonna be playing
it on other than next month
no but it's that's not the point though
the point is they sell a console that I
feel like is never the highlight of
anything they do anymore the whole time
they've been marketing this Activision
thing it's been about mobile about Cloud
streaming rarely about the console
itself when they bought Bethesda that
was a little bit more equal
but we know why they bought Bethesda
they want game passing Game Pass does
help out the platform in general but
it's just like you make us pay for on
for gold you don't make the PC pay for
goal when is it gonna start to be where
okay this is enough
because to me
with something like this and I know for
a fact that that PC version going to be
60 frames hopefully it'll run okay I
don't know that still remain to be seen
but to me you're screaming from the top
of the rooftops look we just sold you a
500 console 200 uh two years ago but
guess what we want you to play that on
PC yeah and it's just it's not a good
look man you know I hope they do better
and part of me is is happy this happened
because
the amount of backlash that they did get
because I saw people that you know how I
know when it's not Fanboy stuff when I
when I click on someone talking about it
they ain't following no one I know so
I'm like okay you are definitely not in
this community you are genuine and you
are upset that this game is 30 frames
and I'm like maybe they'll see this out
loud this backlash and they're like okay
someone go over there and tell Bethesda
we need that Starfield at 60 frames we
can't deal with this anymore they're
like like so you think this sets it off
so this could protect star field no it's
like this is red fault okay they are
going above and beyond over red phone
what do you think they're gonna do about
Starship
it's like I'm hoping that some way
there's some positivity in this you know
some way that Microsoft sees the the bad
publicity they're like we don't want
that smoke again
right though I didn't mean to interrupt
no no you think Halo would be that like
that that's the thing I thought that was
the line draw like wow we should have
held on to that
Halo exactly but the attic talks about
you know again read in the room and like
understanding the backlash and
responding to it didn't they announce
that that red Falls gonna have de Nuvo
on PC
fire Tokyo oh and that's another thing I
think it's a great fall as well okay
that's another the thing you look at
ghost uh ghostwire apparently according
to people that were told me on digital
Foundry it's
play that on Playstation their own home
platform
so you mean to tell me that ghostwire
came out a year later that it's better
to play it on a platform they had time
exclusive a year before we give it to
kick I just want to ask you a question
um
does
are you holding as this is a question
consensus you guys can however you want
to attack it are we holding the
developer more accountable are we
holding Microsoft more accountable S2
how why the situation
I think it's Xbox and Microsoft because
I think if you went to Arcade and said
yo we'll give you more time they will
take that time there's no incentive why
they wouldn't take that time and then
you got to look at it from logistic
Point even though we I don't condone it
I mean I don't co-sign it where if they
don't launch this month when's it gonna
launch I mean at the beginning of next
month are they going are they going to
compete with Zelda in two weeks if they
had delayed two weeks they're going to
delayed a month to compete with Final
Fantasy wants three months that you can
compete with Starfield there's really is
stickly no other place this game could
come out so I guess that's probably I
bet you if you if you wouldn't talk to
like a fly in the wall that's a lot of
the energy being going on look we want
this game to come out the best it can
this game needs a little bit more time
now I have a lot Pro probably just a
little bit more time but are we really
going to try to compete with Zelda we
can't sit here come out there and be
like yo hold up you can't uh Horizon you
are stupid for taking on Zelda yo right
Paul go up there go ahead and do it I
mean I mean vampire themed I delayed to
October
um delayed to October no that's four but
they want to Forza yeah exactly we don't
know where
videos
I think that something happened towards
the end of the development redfall
because kids people kids been put on
Twitter he's like I'm pretty sure I saw
this thing say 60 frames in the
description of this game and they delete
they removed it and then kids smooth
posted on Twitter people went back and
used that website to backtrack and and
was posting pictures no it definitely
says 60 frames kid it definitely said
yeah they deleted it off of the off of
the description so I think what happened
is towards the end of the dinner uh
towards the end of the development cycle
something happened they couldn't
realistically delay it you know
obviously I would have liked the delay
but once again me coming from a consumer
side if you launch that around uh Zelda
I'm not playing it you launched it
around Final Fantasy I'm probably not
playing it star foot I'm probably not
playing it like there is literally
there's literally big games he's like oh
well there's literally big games two to
four weeks every week after this game
comes out yes itself wouldn't it skip
King man he's been paid and I'm very
curious where this going girl
the king you know read for the
announcement about Arcane that uh it's
going to launched with a performance
mode it will have quality mode and
performance will be patched in later
disclaimer
whatever King says doesn't reflect upon
oh this is the IOP Brethren that are
here or our defining Duke they're like
we're all in one section are you about
to co-sign this I really want to see
when it's going where is this feels very
weird it is very strange I had I had
friends on that was showering us with
flowers earlier that are associated with
Microsoft this does not reflect upon you
guys okay
you ever heard that stuff when your
mother says this is gonna hurt me more
than it hurts you
do it this is
this is to show you that I rock with
y'all I rock with y'all so they call
this an Xbox podcast because of me
oh he put the Xbox
we're about to pull out a PlayStation
one from the other side
are we melting the chain
you guys are like a boxer with scar
tissue
you punch you right in the face you
split up that old wound again start
leaking from that same cut again
we want y'all to get into a fight and
don't get hit like me and Cog got boxes
that we know he real good if he don't
get punched in the face
just don't touch that [__] just just
yeah just just watch out for the scar
tissue big cloud says signed the
contract and and and and Maddie Maddie
alluded to that it's the cascading
effect
right what is this going to affect down
the line it's never a one-off with you
guys never it's never you've marketed
this game at 60 frames per second I can
go back to every video it's been 60
frames I've said yo look at his 60
frames I'm amped every time you showed
it you showed it in the best like 60
frames everybody's getting amped for a
game that we really didn't care that
much about care about Starfield you care
about uh uh uh uh what you call a
hellblade care about Forza you made us
care about this game about how you
presented it 60 frames
now the game is getting ready to come
out you say hold up baby
voice
oh that's gonna be 34k 30.
no that's not what I don't know
listen here Playboy
you ain't been talking like that uh-huh
what you mean you've been talking that
4K 60 talk all right let's not do 4K
let's not shoot you in the foot let's
stop bottling you up and putting you in
4k God of War if I was right around came
out and it had a 60 frame per second
mode right yeah yeah I don't care about
that 120. we talked about 60 here it had
the 32 right you could do the 30 with
with the 2K checkerboard license
whatever the hell they was doing they
did the 30 they did the 16
and they gave you the Vaseline 720 120
hertz version
see when Maddie says we with PlayStation
that joint is a one-off because they're
gonna they they care about units being
sold when you change the metrics
see Sony knows they want to sell you
this copy
you ain't getting this in a service
so it's game pass the issue oh we throw
it inside Game Pass y'all getting it for
free anyway we worrying about the
engagement and we'll hit y'all with that
later you'll be around
stop taking my bucks for granted b
um so I'm taking my viewership for
granted don't present something one way
you catfish me God
you can't fish me guys now I'm sitting
inside the showers The Crying Game she
showed up in something else
you showed up not how you said you was
gonna be
yo why is total change like I'm missing
30 frames mate I'm I
was 60.
and then you showed up
you're back not right shoulders are
slumping you're not looking like you
look in your pictures
he thought he was about to match with a
10 but he's actually about to have a day
before it was someone that looks like
gold
oh man I flew you out I paid for the
flight
the hotel when you got there you wasn't
like your IG pictures me
yo okay if I keep talking from us
let's go
let's go for
oh it's called red four you're gonna
tell me
two weeks for it about to come out now
[Laughter]
where where we selling for this at
um
you could have did 1440p 60 frames per
second I would have did with 1080. you
could have did 1080p on the series s
word like 60 frames per second do you
think they're pushing 4K is the biggest
issue there's no excuse for 4K ain't on
60. all right
this is absolutely no excuse for this BS
we always got to take it we always got
to take it and we always got to say yeah
but it's in Game Pass though
yeah but yeah but it's in Game Pass
though yeah but you ain't paying for you
paid 15 bucks you should be happy
[Music]
what about all those months when my my
15 bucks accumulated when you didn't put
anything out for the year
who delayed this
from last year to this year to come up
in this state what was it
look so if you getting 30 now what was
you doing 15 then
I'm so sick and tired of you dudes doing
this to yourself you making it hard to
rock the chain in history
coming for me and you don't care you
don't care how to protect you from the
PlayStation fan base no the PlayStation
dudes is on my neck God of War got 60
frames what's up with your man okay
we are trying to hear that
smoke is for them so let's just stay
theoretically like what you say I I hear
you I hear you there's about to be a
crazy theoretical no I'm just saying
like my question is I mean we we do for
what we see you know uh post acquisition
you know that
they've operated I would say uh zetabax
has operated kind of still independently
right you know it's been the Xbox and
Bethesda showcase kind of thing you know
if um for the most part you know the
transition period is still new as far as
them into the fold do you would you be
apt to listen to the fact that you know
well maybe
zenimax still has their own way of doing
things right and the the ultimate
message of Xbox is world's most powerful
console 60 frames per second that is
their message trying to say that's not
their message their message is
mediocrity well well well I said I'm not
saying known to not release games in the
best state when they launch and all I
will say is that you know Microsoft's
own messaging also has been we allow the
developers to do them we don't want to
be hindrance I feel like that's mainly
being aimed towards the people not
making their games so so if if just
theoretically if arcane
was comfortable
with where it was at right and then now
that information comes out now to your
point the question is where the
information comes out and when there's
the knowledge from Microsoft okay that
this is going to be at this frame rate
right right because clearly I would
assume that they do care about it the
fact that the Tweet went out and said
hey 60 frames is going to come so
there's clearly someone internally
okay can I ask a question okay please
yeah please go go go hey Maddie what
what frame rates are definitely
Fair
no I got an answer I'm gonna let you
answer but I do have to ask so is who we
just can't even arrested me who's the
studio who's the studio for both arcade
for both right yeah you're saying
because arcade set the standard with 60
there right that automatically as you
say there should be the business I'm
just gonna try to get the gist of what
you're saying they went in the backwards
compatibility and when they made the the
uh the Ultimate Edition for Dishonored
one for the Xbox didn't they make that
60 frames too
I think everything Arcane was the
biggest issue they had was when the
Dishonored 2 launched on PC I think it
funny enough had to do with de novo I
wanted yeah
yeah it was it was it frustrated me to
know when because I thought Dishonored 2
is I still think it's like one of the
best stealth games ever made
I'm sorry I can't finish I was just
gonna say just I know the PC port for
that was was busted so and it wasn't
running in a proper frame right but but
I do want to be clear like isn't it
Arcane Lyon and this is Arcane Austin
I don't know I'm asking what is Arcane
Austin's last game okay this is the
outside I think okay so did it wasn't
anything recent that was 60 frames per
second that we could pull from all right
now Mr Clarity okay
Mr Clarity why show the game at 60.
and I actually have a different one you
know when you guys went to play the game
it didn't feel like it wasn't third it
didn't feel like it was 30. the gameplay
and I'm like I don't see a console
anywhere man to me I saw a kid's smooth
post on there said why didn't no one say
that because no one knew like they
didn't know they did know
influencers in media that went out there
no one knew now I'm kind of curious did
no one asked well the question is
we're not be able to talk about that at
that it's time exactly right but they
they but after the Embargo lifted
theoretically that would have came out
but nobody asked was able to ask those
questions
I feel like no one asked because they
played a 60 frames game and they just
this is because it's been marketed this
way he's been bamboozled we've been
catfished
we let us straight it was a type of
event where like we we wanted to know
about the game we wanted like it was I
think I don't know for me again it's a
thought that I had that I ever realized
the Cog I verbalized to Maddie I didn't
know that I felt like it was the right
time to verbalize it to like Harvey
Smith hey Harvey like what what's going
on
you feel that you was happy to be there
so you didn't want to act like that let
me jump in because I'm ready I'm gonna
go at this because no I'm upset I
respect that I've been a respect that
completely I've been upset
since the moment I heard this I've been
this has made me Furious you're not
making me pick up no no no PC controller
you ain't making me do it
yeah yeah but you ain't making me play
on this rig I purchased I pay 500. yeah
five you lied to me B you lie no how I
feel is that come on man
it showed all the marketing all the
marketing was 4K 60. okay I don't care I
don't care about the 4K part let me give
a little bit more balance yes but
because heart gets you needs five
dollars I'm gonna I'm gonna jump he said
just FYI Arcane has been using void
slash up until now red fall is their
first unreal game that's what I heard RK
lion
so to just to clarify and I'm just just
putting I'm picking up what you're
putting down Hardy they could they could
make a performance mode when everyone
else that uses the unreal makes a
performance I just
it's hard to believe I I
this is a strictly I think this is
strictly something happened at the end
of development there was nothing they
could do to get it out on time should it
have been delayed yes but I don't think
realistically that is an option that
they're willing to entertain I think
there's a very real legitimate reason
why whatever we're not getting 60 at
large I just think they're not putting
in a given of credence to how optically
that makes them look and it and and I
just feel like we maybe again we're
reacting to it a certain way and I agree
with King completely I just to me this
should be the Baseline now and that is
it
I've just always have
it's cool now look you know look this is
this is disappointing you know for me it
was disappointing because obviously you
know me soft batty we went to the event
you know and we played clearly the PC
version of this game right and for all
intents and purposes that was 60 frames
what I played what I touched felt smooth
so for me it was no question that it was
going to be this for console and maybe
I'll take the L you know for not doing
extremely due diligence and I don't
think there's no l to be tough I could
have asked I could have asked here's the
thing though is you realistically played
60 frames game when you're playing even
though you're playing PC you're assuming
that they're trying to in some way uh
you know project what you would play on
calling so and I think that's a fair
assumption right I just I just assumed
that it was and again you know I look at
the art style of the game I look at
certain aspects of it I'm like okay you
know this should hit that now I will say
here's the problem the problem is
there's been so much negative real quick
this last Super Chat is the best thing
I've seen
it what's funny my Bars were about to go
there that's what's so funny yeah he
said that shout out to the rambling game
because that's where I was going so look
the the negative press coming in
has been it's been rough on raffle you
know what I'm saying the the persistent
online talk didn't really do it any you
know justice as far as from The Gaming
Community the you know let's be honest
you know Jim we had them on but you know
the gameplay representation that they
had did not do a lot of positive you
know alphasize
for the Gaming Community you know what
I'm saying as far as their feeling on it
right and now we get the the you know to
try to use the teleporter like a grenade
continue the 60 frames for snipers in
the house I feel that you know but the
60 frames per second announcement now
don't judge
he was like What's It Gonna explode now
components it you know now the thing for
me is solve you were there we were
fortunate we're blessed to get the
interview with Harvey Smith you know one
of the things that he mentioned about
was challenges of development how hard
it was to get the game out but the key
thing I thought was interesting was that
I asked him remember so I said look you
know what I think is really impressive
right from a technical standpoint is
that you guys are doing four player
co-op untethered I come from State of
Decay to one of my favorite games which
is and shout out to Undead Labs we've
had them in the realm I was like damn
buddy I got that tether though like why
can't I move outside this small one
block radius and everybody got to be
next to each other and Harvey told me
the developers looked at him like bro
like what you're asking for redfish
impossible from a CPU standpoint like
we'll see we'll see about that like I
don't know and he pushed me pushed he
said now listen [__] you know the whole
game yeah it's four players he said
there's gonna be points story-wise and
progression wise when you advance the
game and then we bring you together like
kind of that was the determination
almost broke into it right yeah don't
you so you know what I'm saying but he
said you could operate you could go all
the way now that person's gonna have to
deal with the smoke that they gonna deal
with based on the scaling of the game if
they go far from the group but I can I
can vouch from a CPU intensive feature
that requires there's no doubt I'm not
no developer I'm just saying that is
still not easy because I know a lot of
people are looking at the graphical
Fidelity game and say yo that should be
easily 60 frames and I get it from the
Optics I get that but if you look at the
way game development works and the way
how intensive that is that's a thing now
the question becomes which is where I do
side with King
is that the problem is this the Xbox
marketing themself you are marketed
yourself as the most powerful console
you as marketed yourself at 60 frames
per second being a standard in gaming
right so this is this energy is not
going to sit well because it does feel
like hey we can launch it in this
amazing service we have and then we
could deal with it later the problem is
what Maddie said which is like the
Zeitgeist for redfall like I'm worried
about this game not being at its best
like Saul was saying and then not
getting its just do if it is a great
game the key for me with all of this is
going to be we're going to learn a lot
with this launch I said this on Duke
with you Maddie which is
how important is 30 frames
in reality because here's the thing King
and I know where you're going
but if they sit it reminds me of when
the series X launched and they had no
Dolby Digital port
I was like what the hell are y'all doing
I was like bro what's my 5.1 gonna do
yeah like you bucket I'm like you who
launches a console without Dolby Digital
I was Furious right when they took out
the um
right and I was like this is a mistake
this is critical now again this is not a
game I know it's not Apples to Apples or
I know but what all the point I'm trying
to make is
there is data there is telemetry there's
analytics in his metrics we're going to
learn does the vocal minority on Twitter
represent what everyone truly feel
because if the game come out and it's
popping and people are having a good
time and the engagement seven we know
seven million zombies had vampires heads
crushed you know what I'm saying hey
whatever not to Magic but we got to see
how that lasts throughout the engagement
you know what I'm saying but I'm very
interested to see
how much this truly matters to people
not picking up the game engaging with
the game playing with the game and I
just think overall it is disappointing
it is disappointing I I'm not going to
make excuses for it I'm just curious
what happens and then the last point I
will say this is the thing I kind of so
Duke a little bit is that I'm always
team delay I've always team delay delay
delay delay I want the best version of
the game always I do not care that's
just how I'm always going to feel give
it the best chance to win I am curious
because this is the same Community right
Halo infinite gotta come out y'all being
selfish for talking team delay remember
that talk y'all be the gay I don't care
if you don't got Co-op I don't care if
you don't got Ray tracing I don't care
if they don't got forged you as a gamer
being selfish to demand that this game
get held up for your your your whole
package business right I mean we would
think hindsight is 20 20 right so again
you know what I'm saying for the same
people said Microsoft needs to crack the
whip that's what they were saying what
is going on they need to crack the whip
this this that and third so my issue
with the community sometimes is you
can't have it both ways because at the
same time when they say that and now
they like yo it's coming out it's coming
out whether it's coming out you gonna
get 60 when you get it whatever whatever
then it's gonna be oh what's going on
over there
if it was delay talk instead of this
talk
we have to admit the conversation would
be yo what is going on over there
Microsoft the mismanagement these games
are taking eons to come out
I've just gotten to the point where it's
just like look you know I know I'm the
minority when it comes to I want games
at 60. I know there's plenty of people a
vast majority of the fan base that don't
even they don't even know the difference
they but it's just like I don't care
about they need I care about mine
absolutely uh so it's just like in in a
way I know people think oh you be
negative towards Russell no I want it to
be the best it possibly could be because
I wanted to do the best it can be
because I love this studio and I wanted
dishonor 3 in the future I want a
healthy franchise for them to work on
and to me if they go in there with half
their weapons and get knocked out then
for all you know the repercussions
that's okay we were gonna let you make a
dishonor three now your support studio
for this studio so it's just like I
don't
I don't think the opportunity
the only thing I was saying for the
people who were saying crack the web
let's just say this is an example of
Microsoft crafting the web you better
come out I don't care about what's going
on with whatever whatever you got to
come out and guess why you got to come
out because June
um Here Comes Diablo
um also we just heard about Final
Fantasy you know that's coming out oh by
the way we had a specific roll out for
Forza oh by the way you can't come out
September because that's where
starfield's at oh you think coming out
on November no week you know maybe uh
Call of Duty so what if this is the
cracking of the whip like King always
wanted right he was like yo I don't care
Starfield what if this is the Kraken of
the whip King
I'm I'm blaming Todd and the team
I'm just gonna keep it a buck okay I'm
keeping it above because I ain't even
working on this game
no I'm talking about they over there and
since they want to be
Microsoft on this side shout out to
Aaron greenberger y'all most powerful
console 60 frames yeah yeah and xenomax
is over there
hey for the record King taught God how
it has been on record to say I like to
pick up the cups and and look at
everything yes that's cool
and Microsoft came out after they said
the 30 crap
Maximus really has said 60s coming later
right so what what is this what you said
what if Microsoft cracked the weapon
said no no we go you gonna get some help
to do this I'm gonna say this yeah
and this is this is the blessing and the
curse of Game Pass
this this is it this this is the knife
guys you this is where you got the good
part of the blade and it's the bad part
of the blade and we got hit with the bad
part
um
the game is inside game passes coming
out Game Pass is the platform right Game
Pass will always be new to somebody else
the next day that they jump in
Sony don't care about how stuff looks on
PlayStation Plus because their games
don't release on PlayStation Plus
they're worrying about absolute sales so
they're going to try to give you the
best product in the beginning that you
can get for the sales aspect right I'm
looking at God of War now I know you're
gonna say well God of War and redfall
ain't the same thing right I'm just
talking about sales aspect of a company
looking to sell you something so when
you saw a God of War you saw the list in
the back and it said 4K or whatever it
said you know 60 frames 30 frames 120
frames they had all these little
listings that you saw you were good
about it and you gave them your 70 bucks
this joint said it's coming in Game Pass
in two weeks 4K 30. haha
and you like what yeah it's inside Game
Pass if you don't want to spend the 70
you can buy this service that we have
and you can get in yeah or you can play
right yeah or go over there to the PCS
so let me let me that's all for you it's
called a PC let me ask you guys a
question real quick we'll go around real
quick
they they come to you said yo we can get
this out at 60 frames but we're
untethering everyone
what do you do that was going to be my
question for caucus what was the
question would you no would you accept
untethering people for 60 frames
Catherine you mean tethering people
we do know that's not the case because
we know that they can do 60 that's the
delay yeah we know they can't do it go
to you now and say yo tethering is the
issue we're still working around it yeah
but we could tell oh they say that
that's the blaze okay you say that the
reason why would you do it would you be
okay with that it's honestly probably a
contributor would I be okay
or would you be what what's the question
I'm okay would I be okay what
specifically it comes out at launch with
60 frames but everyone's tethered oh no
we ain't doing it tell them we're not
doing the telegram tethering that's your
whole that's your whole seller point
because I don't know until I'm okay I'm
okay we'll tell you know why because
when I look at the game that we played
and how that game plays and how those
powers are supposed to work in a
synergistic fashion right I don't know
the benefit of being untethered
again I haven't experienced it I don't
know the benefits
you necessarily see the benefit of being
untethered running off and doing my own
thing yeah when you guys did talk to
them and he said look if you separate
you're gonna be jumped so it's like you
should they're encouraging yeah leaving
each other anyway so if it's stopping my
60. yeah you could keep me on a chain
we do know that 60 frames per second is
coming here we do know this so they say
that they they according to what they
States didn't show up 60 friends is
coming so to me that I have to infer
that this is a technical challenge that
they need more time to get there but it
is possible no what's good with all them
buzzwords what's up with velocity
velocity architecture
so whatever these words they're supposed
to get us to 60.
let's give it a time frame yeah you wait
three months okay you have to wait three
months you get your 60 untethered would
you do that delay the game no I don't
well but I that's where my is delay the
game but I'm always happening yeah so
it's just like
if it's more than a week tether them
well I don't care
for a week because here's the thing we
know how gaming is we know how gaming is
if it takes them a month to fix that two
months three months that no one's going
back
I've been holding this in yes please
please please
advocated on Duke for so long the
untethered experience I gotta know the
co-op experiences we're going through
here actually really it's more so a call
for Education let's go anytime I'm in a
co-op game with the homies I am not
further than one room from them because
it's Co-op right so if it were at the
cost of 60 frames when and that's why I
was like silent on it because in all
actuality I want to play the game and
and review it and experience it and be
like oh that's why my friend would be on
that other side of the map there might
be technical reasons why you'd want to
be separated like that yeah like I feel
like uh stated to K2 it would make more
sense why you'd want to be untetheaded
there because it's a it's you're
Gathering resources it makes more sense
to separate in that type of game but
what I've seen it did not make sense to
be on to be untethered in this game I
haven't played it before but I played
there's because like when you complete
stuff you get resources like I guess
it's kind of like sand decay in that
regard like everything you collect just
turns into this resources currency that
you go back to the base you can like buy
weapons with and stuff but nothing about
the design of the game at least in that
two-hour window screen to me like oh you
know you're gonna want your buddy on the
north side of the map when you play
games like dying light that that do
stuff like this like I can't name the
last time that I saw look look what
happens when we play something as simple
as what was that game we played naraka
look we can't even uh you can't even win
a little bit farther from us
we got them dudes like King like
Sinister that's gonna do their own thing
you always got that dude in the crew
we're skipping the story and he won't go
away
arcade is offering us that ability I
like that untethered at a compromise
though and I I think and that's the
issue and but this is the thing though
okay and this is it is not because I
love it this is your makeup
but this is not because I recently just
converted to master race it's not that
oh this guy but I just think on the
console if you go if you guys want to
sit here and have these arguments about
compromises you have to understand that
buying a console is a compromise
it's just the truth think about it are
you getting I don't want to treat the
wrong experiences are you getting the
optimal appearance on a console I gotta
tweak that of course not PC is always
going to be I don't want to sit there
with the levels how many levels I gotta
mess with to get there I understand see
you you trying to make it more difficult
than it is it's not difficult at all you
just don't want to mess with it and I
get that I understand but I'm just gonna
update the drivers my worries my worries
are that this is the camera conversation
that continues to mind you I this
conversation is going to come up again
and it's not just going to be readful
and again and again and again Xbox right
see I I'm trying to be the lead voice
this big of an issue I am trying to be a
voice where it doesn't happen anymore
well I'm trying to to raise an army
online this is these people gonna be
upstairs
to your point addict that is the
positive out of this right the positive
whoever whoever whether it be Arcane
whether it be about whoever thought that
you know launching at this at this you
know frame rate and performance you know
would be
accepted right they are learning through
the community and through the ratio of
the tweets
that this is not something majority
accepted by the community right so to
addicts point
hopefully it is a teaching moment with
this relationship I know it's gonna be
30 frames per second hopefully that's
all I'm Starfield is 30 Francis
like his thing the way I look at it is
if I were to guess I'm just guessing if
I were to wager why red Falls going 30
right it's probably the multiplayer the
untensive experience and probably the
visual effects like not the actual
Fidelity of the game but how many uh
explosions are happening right yeah
because there was a ton of that that
would be my guess whereas Starfield I
think for the average gamer looks like
the more acceptable 30 because it's
pushing the boundaries in so many ways
but now
because that is the reality I think
that's going to come to pass that it's
going to be this back-to-back black guy
for Xbox and I know I don't think it's
going to be the teaching moment I'll
even go as far as to say as much as I
don't want to be putting it in there I
do want to pull hellblade 2 into the
conversation yes 30. we questioned it
everything now not everything like I'm
not but I really think with what I'm
seeing on the detail of that game I'm
starting to learn there's a cost for
this
yeah hold on hold up I feel you on that
Maddie yeah but it doesn't seem like
Sony's having that issue with their
graphical games like all games at
performance modes like like to me
they're not like obviously you can't
compare Them Apples to Apples oranges
oranges like they're different forms of
games but God of War looks phenomenal
God of War Ragnarok it's very eye candy
game Horizon is one of the best games
that you can actually visually look at
and they both have their performance
modes and to me I just find it hard to
believe that that can't be met
because like I think when I look at the
detail and the face that we're seeing
now for Santa while I'm like okay that's
pretty next little stuff when I look at
Starfield it's like okay you're not just
on the ground horizontal exploration
like it's always been Bethesda you're
gonna apparently be able to fly your
ship around the in the atmosphere of the
planet in space you're gonna be able to
it's kind of the do everything game
where I feel people are gonna be ready
to be more forgiving of it like I've
already said or I recorded a video where
I said like I do think it's gonna be
more 50 50 in redfall where I just think
when you look at redfall because of its
art style there is that confusion of
like bam why is that dirty not because
it looks bad but it doesn't look as
demanding compared to Starfield but if
we're having a limitation issue with
something like that is it optimization
is that an issue here or are we setting
ourselves up for at least two other 30
FPS experiences you know what we setting
ourselves up play these games on PCs
viewing redfall on PC like 100 yeah
that's the thing Bethesda if they're
smart which I imagine they are since
they've got this far of marketing right
uh if they don't send us review codes
for PC I mean they're wild they're
they're well Xboxes are both should
count for both shouldn't they yeah
that's the Hope right that Xbox One just
lets you play on Game Pass PC yeah well
we gotta see this is I just want the
game to do good man I just that's all I
want everybody wanted to gain the good
do good I mean stop stop stop that they
shouldn't a lie
you you lying you showing 60 and then
two weeks before you bout to show out
hey by the way um everything that you
saw over there just half that and that's
you that's you yeah
for everything that you said it's like
you talk to them it's like you talk to
them like why did you not tell me this
was 30 frames oh it's 60 somewhere else
I gotta show with this promotion over
here you don't remember you don't
remember I yo I even came on the show
that day and was like that's 4K 60s
looking crazy you had oh that's nice I
just don't remember the the broadcast
get a phrase for console but again if
you guys have the information
I'm completely upset yeah if you would
have showed it and it was I
it's been more transparent I feel like
they wouldn't have got nearly as well
but two weeks before oh man you don't do
that two weeks before I'm about to fly
out I tell somebody yo don't forget I
got a wooden Lake
yo mama I got a club
but you got to think about it she
thinking you showing up with two good
legs
this is the problem this is the problem
not what you advertise advertise 60. you
would never get to you don't get this
from me if you came out like you said
they told you they lied one more week or
whatever it is
coming it's covered they say yeah it's
coming in two weeks but not like how we
said
not just like that's like when you go to
Burger King and you see that burger and
you're looking at it
and yeah the stock photo yeah you get
your burger and you open it up and it's
that 30 frames it's a stock photo the
stock photo isn't even it is it even a
burger
your burger and you look up at it and
you like that's 60 and this is 30. all I
can hope is I hopefully the delay isn't
that long you know I I worry about
design guys I want redfall to succeed
and I am concerned I'm concerned but
look we just got to see what's going to
happen
metrics and analytics are when it does
drop if Rook Gamers stand on a square
with the situation real quick I don't
know if I don't know I don't know if
this has been photoshopped obviously
it says it down here the 60 frames right
here playable it says Xbox cross
platform 60 frames optimized for the
series snx console like unless this is
Photoshop like stand up fair enough if
that was out there then that's the smoke
that has to be received it is what it is
but look let's move on there's a long
one and um yeah I mean look at the end
of the day I can talk about final
Fantastic look great
it looks good it looks great
this is the game that got me excited now
summons Sid because oh the whole thing
looks phenomenal oh my God it ain't
showing up it looks phenomenal that's
what I would that's the game that got
beat I skipped the skater play because I
was just like I'm sold all right yeah
like don't watch it obviously not at
this point but they just revealed so
much much I think they did yeah I think
they showed so much I'm like man because
they because you obviously they've been
promoting the summit bottom like you
showed us them all yeah they did show
out they super confident I didn't watch
any of that stuff okay watching the
Showcase with attic on our Channel
watching the Showcase with attic made me
want the game now yeah before I did not
was thinking about it didn't really care
about it it would have showed up it
would have left but now something that
Cog and I always begged for was to be
able to control the summonses more than
just a cut scene now you fighting with
this using them so yeah I actually did
something that I asked for so you've
earned my money
um it looked great I don't care what
platform it is you know a lot of dudes
is like oh you're Xbox gamer dummy so
I'm definitely going to play the game
but now they did something that I wanted
and I'm glad they did the um the state
of play just for that it was for me
basically no doubt anybody else had any
things on Final Fantasy 16 consensus I'm
good no I didn't I didn't watch I didn't
watch the Zelda trailer either you
already know I stayed away from it all
right all right cool King do you need
this uh topic for the cloud or we good
you need this boss I mean listen right
now um Sony is just going to do Cloud
stuff um it's just what you see monkey
do
um we know that they were going to do
this at some point in time especially
with this little handheld that they um
getting ready to come out with uh thank
you Tom for um sending that to me
she had to tell me
I just
um I just this is the natural
progression yeah and sometimes Sony's a
little bit slower in in adopting things
and and coming up they need to see you
do it first in order to do it are you
trying to say Xbox and trendsetter and
they gotta make sure okay right they
need to see that you can swim in there
too okay okay that's how you move your
hands yeah so Sony is coming with their
clouds uh situation and they doing their
mobile stuff so yeah I thought it was
going to be in conjunction with the
handheld to be honest with you yeah and
I'll add a 22 positions higher related
to Cloud
um it looks like the interesting part of
it it looks like the relationship ship
suggests that it's a hybrid Cloud
infrastructure with um Amazon and
another Cloud backing not necessarily
Azure which is interesting because we
did heard about the partnership that we
thought was going AWS wait yeah so look
remember we thought the Manifest with
the Sony sensors and the AI and
Microsoft give them the Azure you know
apparently according to Jim Ryan talks
to Jolie in the initial stages so my
concern is to your topic is that the
Activision Blizzard kingding has changed
the relationship and now that they are
looked at as a competitor and they fall
back from that and Sony now does their
own hybrid Cloud thing like they were
doing before with Gaga so it's it is a
good topic it's something to pay
attention to to watch to see how this
moves forward because of the ABK thing
but that's what I got anybody else when
you get these super chats and put a poor
addicted to bet he did yeah just real
quick on that that is super interesting
because now you have Amazon completely
out I mean Amazon is still kind of in
the game with whatever Luna please
[Laughter]
where they could find you what you got
going on before you head out oh I
appreciate that yeah find me with Cog
over I'm defining Duke for Xbox podcast
goodness
um you know I I run two channels Mr
Maddie plays and retro rebound if you're
interested in the Retro nostalgic kind
of stuff from my PS2 air and on it's a
place to be Mr Maddie's just uh talking
about stuff like what's going on with
redfall a lot of modern stuff a lot of
reviews coming to his attic and I have
uh talked quite a bit about so we're
gonna be busy men in the coming weeks
but uh yeah thanks for having me on I I
hope I didn't overstate my Wellness no
no no
[Music]
you know but I I appreciate it congrats
again guys and uh and thank you for
having me and kaga well I will see you
on Wednesday brother you already know my
dude
congrats again thank you again
talk to you guys later get together on
redfall at the 30 frames together
but you guys got to split the frames
look oh so I'm gonna get the pole while
you queue up uh yeah the Thousand super
chats yeah all right all right I love
how y'all just didn't want to hear my
take on the Sony
yo what what was it I don't care it's
fine
now what was it what was it seriously
it's the obvious thing they're gonna go
with I think on Google I think Google
what I think they're going to go to
Google wait wait wait wait time out we
need to hear this because he's always
right yeah that's so cool
yeah they were opposing do you
understand like they're completely free
agent now they don't have they don't
have anything really like you would
think they don't even have anything
cloud-based but obviously they have a
lot of back-end stuff that is now Sony
can partner with them
that Tech would be fired the tech is
still there so that's a good partnership
if tech wise I really do feel like
that's a good partnership because as
much as I don't rock with um with cloud
like that the the biggest issue they had
was not with games and I feel like
PlayStation would give them that edge
yeah and then I just to me I don't know
I think it just makes sense because now
you know
we'll see if you pull this one out
like he pulled out the APK
you that that would really precipitate
the death of the PlayStation actually
thank you yeah we gotta we have great
power and with great power comes great
responsibility solve I need you to say
Xbox is buying Sega just say it out
there put that out there
enough he don't feel that voice
Xbox is buying Sega
[Laughter]
announcement of red four launching that
30 phrase what do you think is the best
course of action for red 4 moving
forward the choices are a keep red Falls
current release provide transparency on
when the 60 frames is coming B delay red
four launch what the 60 on um when the
64 frames perform mode is ready and then
um see I don't care y'all better off or
for the damn performance mode on
Starfield is all I care so that is the
choices Rock the vote when it goes up
sometime tonight or tomorrow late and um
yeah let's get these super chats man we
get these super chats so the last one
that I have is Max City Entertainment
two dollar Super Chat I'll get
everything after that yes okay so you
got that okay cool all right let me
switch off to my document
because it's legendary right now oh it's
crazy it's crazy so all right no we got
no okay let's make it a rule no one
interjects let's get straight through
listen to it unless it's something that
answers somebody a specific question yes
okay we got necromancers there remember
for one year ten dollars to protect
congratulations Lords for episode 300
and the many more to come thank you
brother
J dubs ten dollar Super Chat
congratulations to my brothers on their
300th episode I'll see you guys again at
the 400th much love Kings love you bro
thank you man appreciate that Namo Mar
member for 19 months Lord gold congrats
on episode 300 to the best pod ever
looking forward to the next 300 salute
thank you brother
and we have Matt without fear member for
15 months Lord silver congrats on 300
episodes of the best Xbox podcast around
much love
and we have Kia Sante fifty twenty
dollars salute to the IOP on the 300
episodes I hope to one day hit such an
amazing Milestone you're all a huge
Inspirations to me and ever born which
led us to start our own show it is no
doubt that we stand on the shoulders of
giants thank you brother appreciate that
remember
four is a legend member for 39 months
Lord bronze shout out to the Lords on
300 Spartans yo King SOB car go watch
Tech and Bloodlines it's really good
yeah good also tell Sony keep bucking up
Salute then we got zip Davis two dollars
if we tap a big congrats on number 300
and even bigger we
[Music]
then we got Stu Jersey five dollar Super
Chat three times one hundred congrats
and keep it going gentlemen appreciate
that brother love or is the legend once
again to the uh member for two years two
dollars for chat there needs to be the
best of King playlist
I'll be a pretty long playlist and we
got a intend on the otaku five dollar
Super Chat happy 300 Lords the greatest
Xbox podcast my bad greatest podcast of
all time may your future be as bright as
Leonidas oh no oh wait Maybe not maybe
not yeah that didn't end well Nick's
five dollars Super Chat thank you for
making my Sundays much more enjoyable
congratulations on 300 episodes a
well-deserved Milestone gentleman salute
thank you brother
we have RDJ five dollar Super Chat
congrats to the big three hundo thank
you brother yeah then we have Tom
Henderson member for nine months Lord
bronze congratulations Lords thank you
brother appreciate it
remember for one year two lawsuit chat
congratulations on 300 episodes salute
thank you brother
then we have uh jorvar ingi five dollar
Super Chat happy 300 thank you brother
am I saying you correctly yeah
that we have Robert kellett five dollar
Super Chat happy 300 Lords it's such a
shame lying Phil soured the celebration
with 30 frames Jesus you can't give a
toast to little Timmy who can't see
below a 60 FPS wow wow wow okay
did you all see Cox biceps grow through
the episode yes yes well did you notice
that I noticed that too and then King
turning into a Gray beard like me salute
gents I gotta blame Sovereign
I forgot what it is I'm sorry cycle
something like that happy 300 episode uh
you celebrate or rupees baby uh you
celebrate the same day I'm celebrating
my 50th birthday no I'm sorry I'm
reading the wrong one happy 300 episodes
Brothers may you rise to new heights and
Eclipse all your dreams and aims love
your content and long net happy for you
all and wish you the best thank you
Brothers
we have Hollywood rules remember for one
year ten dollar Super Chat
happy 300th episode you celebrate the
same day I'm celebrating my 50th
birthday happy birthday to you driving
back Upstate from Virginia I appreciate
what you guys do so much salute keep
doing what you do best pod period thank
you these dudes went to the shop Maddie
bit off look at that
I mean here chop his hair off y'all then
we have Tony private cheers
there will be no patreon tears here
today Tony Bryant member for two years
welcome to Lord bronze thank you brother
appreciate you Tony Bryant ever born
Saga two dollar Super Chat happy 300 to
the best show in the business thank you
brother appreciate you then we have Abba
cab 72 member for 26 months Lord bronze
congratulations on episode number 300
always keep it real and keep it gaming
special shout out to those no longer
with us God bless you all thank you
brother
and we got let's play with each other's
joysticks
five dollar Super Chat here's the 300
episodes of SOB even when he wasn't on
the show he was in my heart
yo can't wait for 300 more displays of
our love for joysticks
ah thank you appreciate it
narrow back remember for two years five
dollar Super Chat congratulations more
time 300 episodes I know it's Sunday but
y'all are the ish thank you brother
appreciate you man
and we have ducky five dollar Super Chat
love the intro Lords congrats on 300
episodes here's to 300 more thank you
brother
now we got tsws gaming two dollar Super
Chat new member thank you thank you solo
appreciate that happy 300 Lords
appreciate that brother
and we have hargit chani remember for
one year five dollar Super Chat wait
where's the Zelda topic I know we're not
about to skip talking about the game of
the year trailer we actually I don't
think Carl got the second paper
you want to do that after the okay all
right thank you
and we have Italian clowns remember for
two years ten dollar Super Chat salute
my brothers to 300. my favorite episode
was the Toys R Us episode yes that talk
brought me in my feels also all hail the
king bend the knee King ain't ever wrong
you know I love I love it he ain't never
wrong unless it's against me no
problems once again two dollar Super
Chat I dizzy would be proud of all of
you guess you would I appreciate that
brother
that we have Lord boxenberger with the
five-year-old children yeah thank you
brother yes proud of you guys big
congrats on hitting episode 300 thank
you bro appreciate that we have ta
checks 11 38 two dollar Super Chat the
Lord's keeping it 300. next level XP
salute thank you brother oh then we have
Mark Beach BG Bijou Bijou uh six Euro
Super Chat I think congrats on 300 what
the what the four of you do is more than
just a podcast you're all one of the
pillars of positivity in the gaming
industry thank you brother appreciate it
we have black Ronin three five seven
five dollars for Chad shout out to IOP
and the realm 300 amazing apps raises
Destiny 2 tanker to 300 more ah you
already know it's called a tanker yeah
that's out of control that thing is
crazy
then we have TSW you don't want any
extraneous conversations
you guys have inspired so many keep it
going thank you brother appreciate it
also then we have Eric s my fellas
IOP is the best video game podcast of
all time that's saying a lot
congratulations on 300 fellas thank you
brother thank you and we have willbo
gadgets
hey Lads it's been a while here's to 300
more thank you but appreciate that Miss
wilbo gaggan wow
then we got Nintendo the otaku ten
dollars in the chat now that the
formalities are out of the way that
appears to the Kingdom trailer was the
goat that three minute trailer bodied
some 25 minute showcases Cog it's over
tears of the kingdoms game of the year
it came with a decade you know it can't
stop it you know it's not profit but you
gotta keep talking
seems like there might be dungeons we'll
see oh my Attica be happy there ah Andy
Cruz
congrats on 300 you guys make Sunday's
Great Road to 600 salute thank you
brother who then turned down the otaku
once again to our super chat with that
I'm ending my B for [__] beef over
brother beef over then we have the Liz
22 remember for two years twenty dollar
Super Chat congrats Lords on 300 can't
stay for the live show but drop it into
some love blessed to find you guys over
two years ago you guys have me laughing
every week my number one podcast salute
to many more years thank you
then we have tipped whale five dollar
Super Chat congratulations Lords on
episode 300 of these soft talk Sundays
then we have blind giant 808 10 super
chat shout out to the Lords on 300
episodes this is hands down one of the
greatest podcasts out there appreciate
the realism and great takes on
everything in the industry cheers to
many more Aloha thank you brother
appreciate it man love
then we have black boxing Kings two
dollars
nice for now what up kid congratulations
my brothers keep grinding thank you
brother appreciate that
then we got Galveston five dollar Super
Chat congrats on 300 level 19 on naraka
will be able to join you all next
Community play yeah level 19. yeah he
ready for the lobby time level zero he
obese
that's crazy that's crazy and we have
Lord Metroid remember for 18 months Lord
silver Cog wears the tears of the
Kingdom trailer topic you still salty
I'm in control of all the time
congrats on your 300 podcast one year
ago I subbed I chose well thank you very
much appreciate you
and we have King is overrated
shout out to him
he's been listening been listening to uh
you guys for three or four months now
but I gotta say you guys have become my
favorite podcast I gotta play on Monday
morning when I'm working congrats on
300. thank you brother no doubt we've
got Gerald Mack oh don't you remember
for two years five dollar Super Chat
Lord King David changed the podcast and
landscape with being on camera no doubt
yes big big part of our success
because a lot of dudes out here was
rocking with them heartbeats and I was
just like that's not the RV
then we got four is a legend member for
two years five dollar Super Chat you
guys got my wife saying don't buck up on
me
what do you do
by far one of the funniest podcasts of
all time period Please keep it up Lord
appreciate it man thank you no doubt
then we got John Wolf X just Sean Wolf
two dollar Super Chat congrats for 300
Lords presented at 60 FPS yes
then we have Paris Lockhart 50 super
tech 300 a quote from the movie I'm here
for all those voices which cannot be
heard IOP you represent the gamers and
provide feedback for us who work behind
the scenes to improve and do better my
interview on the show is 10K by the way
no doubt slow blessings the legendary
that's what's up love you all for time
jorvar Ingy once again ten dollars in
the chat did you ever think people from
all over the world will be watching and
listening to you and how does it feel
knowing people all over the world talk
about you and your podcast that is still
weird to me that's crazy
people in the chat put where you're from
in the chat it's amazing to me it is
it's it's Bonkers Spartan 661 10 super
chat Lord Sovereign sorry for another
Super Chat message for you to read and
catch up on bro you're like in the
middle salute to all the eyes
it's almost 7 30 years yeah
my wife came in and gave me a look
outside
out there the Lords are awesome thank
you brother noodle
let's put the crust in the chat for
ready 5 000 new member welcome to Lord
bronze appreciate you brother absolutely
we can do a telephone yes someone said
they're from Gotham
oh he from New York though
then we have let's play with each
other's joysticks once again two dollar
Super Chat I'm not settling for King's
areolas only sobs
yeah that's what I said that you can
chill yourself
that's why I started laughing I read it
and I was like this man did not say that
he's out of control
then we got Tom Henderson once again
remember for six months he gifted 10 ILP
memberships
he also gifted a whole console
then we have already 5 000 once again
new member five dollars Super Chat happy
300 to the Lord's my favorite boy band
that never broke up when the reunion to
it when is the reunion to hit number one
hits big link and are you implying
let me get uh the ones at the bottom
because they're about to disappear okay
um we got a
like one of those stickers from irons uh
shaft I really appreciate that uh cure
Vader with the five dollar Super Chat
congrats on 300 from uh wherever he's
from I'm not trying to butcher that we
also have a member chat from gaming
Forte 40 months in the back congrats
again on 300 thank you for allowing the
community to participate in this uh
momentum occasion we love you guys five
dollars from chica Jay King that click
with you saying all Sony bangers donut
I'm out to a card as legendary congrats
to the 300 episodes we got a tour of the
super jump from drawing Collins peace to
the Lords have a birthday for my son and
come back to see I'm six hours behind I
know man I'm feeling you I'm feeling
congrats on 300 the most entertaining
informative game uh podcast period
cheers we got a five dollars good job
from uh uh Mexico I you that's what your
name is today just came in late don't
y'all talk about how no one's crying
over 10 frames on Zelda but losing their
minds over redfall no uh no same energy
congrats at 300. appreciate it we're not
talking about that though five dollars
if you travel from uh Luffy Dugout Luffy
to go I guess that's a uh anime
reference Lords you guys are blessed to
have each other uh each other to talk
about games you love I wish I had what
you have congrats on 300 love you guys
thank you he's
I don't care
[Laughter]
we got Matt Valdez two dollars had to
come through for my boys Luke Lord miles
don't play yeah as y'all have inspired
them and so many others love on 300
podcasts on 300 episodes Good sirs xcp
Xbox chatterdays DD and IOP family unite
yeah
and we got the trail City 24 10 super
chat good day Lords and congrats on 300
episodes thank you you guys are the gold
standard in the community when it comes
to podcasting sending blessings all the
way from Bay Area Frisco yeah Bay Area
let's go
we got black Ronin three five seven five
dollars for chat yo that last Super Chat
is wow
it's always amazing I don't even want to
know what it is it's always amazing
you reading it oh you got to read that
oh I gotta read it oh that one ain't
disappearing
that's crazy it's always amazing to see
the aisle we bring out the podcasting
Avengers and JLA on the one Banner
congrats on 300 apps this is Sparta
and we got Stewie 108 20 Super Chat
congrats on 300 IOP thank you brother
David hot right remember for one year
twenty dollars of chat just wanted to
say happy 300 to the Lords and guests
and here's to the next 300 let's go yeah
Luffy to go I know what one piece is
relax I was telling him it was an anime
reference
[Laughter]
cwg podcast 200 Super Chat oh my god wow
congratulations on reaching 300 from the
ladies of gwg thank y'all ladies we
appreciate y'all wow it's amazing it's
the whole team thank you then we got ham
from tsws gaming remember for one month
member from month Lord bronze it's the
Lord's 300 Banger love the show show the
love show the love I got you bro I gotta
owe you a text yeah and we have Tai
casares 15 Super Chat what the hell is
going on here this is like my worst
nightmare for a split screen Lobby 343
was right to forget about split screen
who wants to play like this happy 300th
my Lord
bronze I want the blood clots one happy
tree
girl
there we got splendiferous remember for
17 was Lord bronze yes Lord Savvy I was
one of those people but you guys have
taught me a lot about attacking a
particular argument without attacking
the person thank you
knowledge I like that love that love
that then we got basement Radio art brat
I'm reading it all the way that's rap
remember for what year five dollars 300
looking forward to the next 300 thank
you brother appreciate it
then we have THX 1138 two dollar Super
Chat IOP 300 episodes officially running
time 10 hours epic close enough
then we have booty once again remember
for one year two percent this is better
than any gameplay
[Laughter]
there we go split differs once again uh
remember for one year five dollars to be
chat but you gotta admit that guy has
some extreme takes but I have learned
how to respect that everything under the
IOP and all that follow we love hard
work yeah
I don't know all the people we had it
could be anything yeah
then we have Thai casares three dollars
I'll get my sleeping bag looks like a
24-hour episode
yeah we have uh a Rodimus member for two
years he gifted 10 IOP members of thank
you brother appreciate that blessings
bro
Jay remember for 25 months Lord bronze
thanks Lords for the 300 episodes and
300 more love you thank you brother
appreciate that absolutely beautiful
I've got the doctor 63 five dollar Super
Chat I just got out of church is this an
Avengers episode again happy 300 yes
indeed
then we have Lord Star Killer Xbox
series XO one ten dollar Super Chat
congratulations IOP on your 300 podcast
episode thank you appreciate that you
THX 1138 two dollar Super Chat topics
what topics is all from the hip today
yeah some topics man you went through
the topics I can't believe we did that
yeah yeah we did this we did it we did
that thing
then we have rap once again remember for
one year five dollars
the what the what the lgo Latino gaming
order let's go
[Music]
Lord gold let me say this all of you are
an inspiration you guys gave me the
courage to enter YouTube to quote the
Beatles you guys and I have memories
longer than the road that stretches out
ahead thank you brother appreciate it
actually
so and we have albino dread member for
28 months Lord silver don't usually
catch the podcast live but had to drop
in to congratulate the Lords on their
300th respect to each of you thank you
brother so you said albino dread yeah
uh My Name Is Mud new member what
the crust of the chatbot my name is
then we got Jess Gordon with the 30
pound Super Chat happy 300 thank you
brother appreciate that
shrimps and we have Hollywood rules
remember for one year two dollar Super
Chat a Brooklyn Bazaar reference Cog for
the win yes
then we have a Ralph Wiggum five dollar
Super Chat and congratulations on your
300 thank you sir appreciate that hello
then we have the great Bill still well
remember for two years ten dollar Super
Chat don't make me come back to defend
Mass Effect
then we have Joan Mercedes or Joe on
Mercedes sometimes it's pronounced Joe
on 20 Super Chat appreciate you man
salute then we got Randall for 19 20
Super Chat Mass Effect two is the goat
just like ILP I'll accept that take
today
then we got Bill still will once again
remember for two years 21 super chat
some people like cool stories like Mass
Effect other people like dating Sims
like Mass Effect
[Laughter]
then we have Robert Kelly new member
five dollars what's that just want to
say it's amazing how you guys got some
of the Gaming's biggest content creators
United like family thank you all for
making my Sunday special love thank you
brother appreciate that thank you
then we have Skywalker UAV one remember
for two years five dollar Super Chat
thank you so much then we got slo-mo
back slap remember for two years ten
dollars Mass Effect one usually takes
27.5 hours to complete but actually the
main story and the side missions take 10
hours and the other 17 and a half is
wasted trying to aim at enemies without
trash
talk it
I'll leave that alone
then we have Xbox Mick 29 or Mike 29
with the five pound Super Chat actually
uh Jesus was a Euro sorry five pounds
would be Jeff congratulations on the big
300 guys anyone here going to Gamescom
we need to meet up for all of us if you
are we need to happen did they give us
any info on Gamescom
because I want to be respectful because
the super chat's all super long
um I see MAV in here I know he want to
get some quick bars off you know I
respect his time as well I'm not even
looking at it yeah
but speculation is in the building
brother
he really was passionate and I want to
make sure he get his balls off quickly
sir a pleasure to see you for iop300
even at the very end listen
man so I was listening earlier and I
wanted to beg you guys for a link
because I was out with the family and I
was like I can't really do it so lucky
me this is a seven to eight hour show
and I've been out all day and I get home
and y'all are still alive so I was like
hey [__] I know it's like way past you
know but like I really got to give y'all
some respect if you'll have one so of
course I I appreciate you uh let me come
through
um so for me like you guys this is a
huge milestone right like
I remember I was I had just started my
show right one person show I didn't know
anybody in community I started kind of
watching some of the podcasts even after
I started
I didn't have any followers and Twitter
didn't have any subs nothing like that I
check out your guys show
wow like this is how you do it you know
um but then what meant even more is you
guys reaching out on Twitter and like
following back uh talking a little bit
here and there you know what I mean
um just being respectful because you
treat everybody the same doesn't matter
if they got like a million subscribers
if they have 50. you know what I mean
um so you guys have been like an
inspiration right but um you know it's
uh it's meant a lot to see you guys grow
I've been watching you guys now for over
two years I remember when uh King even
had uh black appearance
y'all are kidding y'all are been live so
long y'all are getting old before our
eyes
[Applause]
this is what you've done yes this has
like been forever now but it's it's a
huge accomplishment and I was listening
earlier and I really wanted to say
something about this because uh somebody
was talking about how YouTube and the
algorithm and you guys deserve way more
subs you know and for me it's like you
guys obviously have earned so much
respect right it is not even about the
sub count it's about who comes through
who shows you the love who shows up the
consistency with the numbers that you
guys pull through I mean you got like a
thousand super chats you can't even
finish them all right now and like
YouTube
takes notice of that stuff right they
they take they take notice of that stuff
if you've already seen changes with
YouTube and podcasting and how they're
starting to push it now like if you
notice on the playlist and stuff they
get labeled as podcasts and all these
kind of things right so these new things
and and that's because of people like
you guys are changing the game for
people like me right so you guys you
know Xbox two
uh Mr Boomstick x x and C you know all
the all these all these shows you know
RDX and stuff that have been doing it
for years now is starting to change the
trend and not only of what
YouTube recognizes but the content that
Gamers watch right and y'all are at the
Forefront of that y'all are like
for me like one of the most respected uh
groups out there and uh it's
inspirational to see what you guys do
and it's not just the pods it's the it's
the website it's the uh getting the
writers involved and the different
people you know uh to contribute content
it's the work you guys put in at all of
the uh gaming shows providing coverage
like you guys did at Pax like nobody
else is doing thank you brother and it's
like inspirational man so I just wanted
to say that you guys treat everybody
with respect uh class ax across the
board every single one of you nobody
reads super chats like soft
nobody puts in as hard to work as attic
does nobody's as funny as king and
nobody is as Class Act and well-rounded
as an individual that deserves as much
respect as God oh thank you brother the
laughter here just permeates through the
community and it's infectious and it's
what we all need so appreciate you guys
I had to say that and uh keep it up man
300 more and we can only hope that one
day we reach the status that you guys
got brother thank you very very humbling
very humbly it meant a lot you love
watching your journey and of course you
know one of the best names in the gaming
fun speculation I love that I think
that's so cool shout out to text even
when we beef with our little diamonds
and cowboy rivalry it's still low why
you gotta bring that up you gotta before
I bounce out You Gotta Throw it but it
shows you how we come together through
gaming brother
two years in a row God come on man you
know um man when when you look over and
you say I got uh six players people
watching or whatever you know majority
of the time I'm one of those six friends
you see that man I appreciate you always
tune into everything that you do
um and you know I I wrote my wife into
it too I'm like yo look look because he
leaves the games you know um I just I
like what you're doing and I do
appreciate the fact that you know you
give our flowers but I I love everything
that you joined and I really love you
and pong Soul together
the whole team too everybody you got
going on over there is great and one of
the one of the best power gaming couples
right half as well and I love to see
that y'all got that passion thank you
brother for coming through appreciate
the kind words I appreciate it and the
super chats are still coming through so
you got a lot of work we got work to do
we got to get back to work
you guys have a great rest of the show
all right thank you bro have a good one
peace out thank you
all right hold on oh damn it it jumped
me hold on a second let me scroll back
down now you good you're good
oh my God he kicks it all up yeah cause
I gotta take my son let's go just go
King we're good just ride it out he ride
it out 300. 300. even wifey was like
he's sitting he got school tomorrow but
you only do 300 once I feel that
Glory's sake okay let me get this all
right okay fonts it was fonze actually
uh fonze gaming remember for 23 months
Lord bronze apologies but I had to drop
out apologies on our apartment president
like I said I didn't see you in there
until it was too late and by then it was
I had to put it in gallery mode but I
apologize because your brother was
really sick and he tried his best to
stay in there and yeah definitely said I
yeah yeah he said I came down with a few
overnight and my head is killing me
y'all know how I feel loved podcast
congrats on 300 feel better brother
appreciate you man thank you brother
thank you brother we got dirt griggity
show five dollar Super Chat
congratulations on 300 episode fellas
thank you brother appreciate you thank
you and we have woden's Throne five
dollars for chat 60 FPS should be the
bare minimum that every game should run
if a game doesn't hit 60 FPS it should
be considered a watch 30 XPS put my mask
on here
then we got Turtles should die 50 Super
Chat oh yeah I want to congratulate the
whole crew for the 300th episode man you
guys have worked so hard to reach this
High I've been following you guys since
the beginning now it's like I oh now it
is like over a thousand playing with Cog
Destiny was a blast and King on fortnite
is suspect
wait who is
then we have Astro parrot King remember
for two months Lord bronze happy 300 to
you Kings have a my Gators just got
another grassland type of day oh salute
that the vessel what you call it the gig
yeah I think he made a comparison
already having a chance to see it he
apologized to me I don't know why
and we have bones lay five dollars to
protect happy 300 episodes of my iron
Lord Brothers really proud of the growth
and success that is going to continue to
go up from here IOP West baby that's
right baby you already know his family
that's the fam right there salute
yes sir
then we have changed remember for 14
months Lord bronze congrats on the 300th
episode Lords here's to hundreds more
thank you brother appreciate it
and we have hard to find remember for 23
months Lord bronze assalamu alaikum my
brothers 300 of them things okay I'm
proud of y'all and honored to have been
on board for almost two years oh
absolutely brother
and we have alien ninja twenty dollars
Cog SOB addict and King in the Ki voice
in The Kill instant voice King I found
you guys two years ago and have enjoyed
all your content since salute to the
Four Horsemen of gaming and continued
success thank you brother appreciate
that love we got booty once again
remember for when you're ten dollars
Super Chat enough respect to all these
men out here and let's get the woman's
that support you because without them
there is none there's no us grown woman
gaming the enough respect and give 300
more
for sure for sure respect from again my
wife is a saint
we're all gonna suffer today
appreciate you yes not sisters oh and we
have Masters in the mass Master Sith 40
Master Sith 40 two dogs congrats on 300
thank you appreciate that and we have
THX 1138 two dollar Super Chat three
hours in still first topic we can do
this all day Captain America Steve
Rogers
all day
we have Sith Lord remember for eight
months Lord bronze look at this party
hello boom and everyone hope you have a
good one I'm currently battling covert
for a second time of the year oh man
thanks for thanks for entering me whoa
whoa
whoa Sid I love you bro but I don't know
what you meant by that but yeah
don't think any of us for doing that
it wasn't me that entered you me
whoa well we hope you feel better
hope you feel better soon though brother
T.A text 11 38 yeah Super Chat I don't
know about it it's the same one hold on
uh
that I might have
two dollar Super Chat happy 300 to IOP
the absolute best in the game thank you
so much lessons Echelon seven remember
for two years twenty dollar Super Chat
I'm not saying that the Lords are better
than everyone else I'm simply saying
Nobody Does it Better Than Lord addict
Lord SOB Lord Cog and Lord King those
are my brothers peace to the Lord thank
you brother appreciate that
and we got free R Kelly we showed up
damn Xbox just killing off their first
party lineup say bye bye to Halo so when
he's back to dominating happy Sunday
fellas Kang it's over there's no
congratulations
IOP 300. he's just here to talk smack I
love I love when he go back on the Sony
side of the yard yeah
anybody
[Laughter]
sis you're killing me with that
CJ Mike 1024 remember for too much fifty
dollar Super Chat bunch of love to the
iron Lords keep doing what you do thank
you bro I never thought I'd say this but
please guys stop Super Chat you gotta
see the name of the last person
oh my goodness yeah we have Echelon
seven once again remember for 27 months
Lord silver I'll be 55 years old this
summer and there's no better time spent
or blessing scent than with you Brothers
is that a picture
Boston yeah
Eddie got my face in the Dominican Barry
great to see 300 episodes it's such an
epic episode I'm gonna bust one tonight
for every episode in your honor have a
great day Buster that Bucky thank you
for your thank you
and sabotaging and defiling my my
likeness thank you sir it surprised you
didn't not even so busted up Barrett
please
[Music]
appreciate you wow and we got one away
dragons TV five dollars
this is how you kicking the door and
show how to do the game in life lead by
example Brothers love y'all stay awesome
love you too brother appreciate you man
a lot of control
happy 300 to the only Xbox podcast
better than defining Duke
face 23 attic face 23 23
this is this is we were reading this for
hours it's an hour yeah that we have the
Tony B through that Super Chat no I did
that uh VL five dollar Super Chat I
found the IOP through Podcast Unlocked
when Cog was on and this is my favorite
podcast by far congrats fellas thank you
we're starting to get somewhere because
I'm pretty sure that was sent that was
right here
we're making a dance we're making a dent
we're making it that's what I said face
chill out we we getting it then we have
one bad mother remember for two years 50
Super Chat years ago when I heard IOP as
a newish podcast I remember telling
someone you'd all eventually be big time
never doubt my predictions what's better
your amazing people when nobody is
looking congrats on 300 and much more
success friends thank you so much
is a good dude yes sir then we got the
rubber knob remember for two years five
dollar Super Chat happy 300 episodes to
the best podcast on YouTube when the
only podcast I choose to support thank
you appreciate that love love appreciate
that love
then we have Nintendo Taco five dollars
to be chat four hours for the
celebration two hours for topics and
another four hours to go through all the
super chats
oopsop drank some lemon and honey tea yo
I remember seeing that
and we have Tyson Lewis member for 17
months Lord bronze congratulations super
happy for y'all all love to the IOP
family many blessings thank you man
appreciate it blessings
and we have Carl Andrews Junior two
dollar Super Chat this podcast is going
to midnight congrats
I would hope not sir you gotta put a
these super chats because they're coming
then you should have never mentioned an
attic and then we have Tom 909 5000 for
chat intro so long I'm tucking up in bed
and letting the four of you rock me to
sleep
ain't nobody rocking nobody you you yeah
listen man and this is for you
go to sleep
ain't nobody rocking you no place
they put Bliss
then we have Khan artistic five dollars
to protect well well well we're here
four to five hours in and there's still
over 600 people listening that says a
lot about how good podcast is truly epic
thank you appreciate that appreciate all
of y'all sticking around crazy crazy wow
amazing then we have sir duck member for
33 months Lord bronze salute to the Lord
for the 300 episodes and thanks for the
long-awaited eight-hour podcast demanded
by the battle damn near close
um best Xbox show in the world Craig
then we got the homie once again Cheryl
Mack member for two years five dollar
Super Chat all hail the IOP salute the
Lords I appreciate you gentlemen in the
chat getting me through this slow ass
Sunday congrats again on 300 we dem boys
yes we are boys
get them tired boys
back slap remember for three months 33
months Lord bronze I am one hour behind
the live show not as far behind us
Arcane with that 60 FPS performance
and I'm fully expecting this show to be
the longest yes
looks like it's gonna win yeah
face
options Demon Souls 30 or 60 FPS Miles
Morales 30 40 60 or 120 fpx uh ratchet
and Clack Rift apart 30 40 60 or 120
returnal 60fps Horizon we've been in
West 30 40 60 or 120. Gran Turismo 60 or
120. Ragnarok 30 40 60.
720 900p and 1200 P why don't you say
those numbers don't you come at me
not one of those games is 4K 30. it's
it's 700 912.
[Laughter]
Vaseline frequency
but it's running 60. it's ready 60. they
got the boat 60 and 720.
Robert Kelly you remember 2010. finally
dividing Duke Cross Iron Lord says it
did it did
then we got Lord Starkiller Xbox series
XO one ten dollars to protect 60fps
should be the minimum on the series X
and S and then and the PS5 I thank God
we're at the red fault topic here's five
and Halo infinite had a targeted 60s FPS
quality mode Dynamic resolution and a
targeted 120 FPS all in multiplayer so
this is facts and we have face once
again 23 BK and why 20 super Taps Sony
doesn't have the luxury of Game Pass
that they have to release their game
features because they have to release
their games feature complete at launch
for seventy dollars since Sony first
party gives a 60 FPS mode with all their
games no reason Xbox can't that's
exactly what I mean and you're right no
he said that it's a little absolutely I
came to the middle ground then we have
Sauron Sauron Grant with the five pound
super jacket Lord of the Rings Robinson
[Laughter]
Bilbo Williams
people Jackson
are on Grant five pounds
it's not a big deal but a bit
disappointing that Beastie Gamers get
the better version on release that
that's no guarantee either so you know
it may run at 60. they gotta twerk for
it that was they got a twerk that that
was not the promise no what was on the
box damn everybody
on the box and we have Max City
Entertainment two dollars which that
addict is killing the 300th episode with
straight facts yeah like killing this
then we got high on Cells Two Dollars
Super Chat happy 300 episodes so
grateful to know you guys no doubt thank
you appreciate it blessings
then we got Max City Entertainment again
two dollar Super Chat 30fps is a
straight dog-ish Xbox is wrong this is a
l yeah people have spoken it ain't wrong
and then we have back City Entertainment
again two dollars super chat now I know
Starfield is 30 FPS capped no 60 no play
yeah I'm playing at 30.
I can see what they say whatever you
want to say I'm still playing right now
Corey Tidwell I have a sneaky suspicion
that the issue is the unified SDK it
seems like the devs I created the game
using just Target specs of the series
consoles without much low level
optimization that would be weird
back City Entertainment two dollars
which had absolutely King 500 not four I
feel the exact same doubt
and we have the rambling gamer guy five
dollar Super Chat four player untethered
Co-op is a lot in computing power notice
that Gotham Knights had the same issue
should Co-op be tested for 60 FPS at
launch yes I don't know if it's that
easy but it gets and then they clip the
cord later
and we have THX 1138 two dollars with
chat Arcane get on the phone with the
Coalition
UE King yes okay get some help and we
have rubber knob man but for two years
two pounds super two dollar Super Chat
Xbox must have made Game Pass deal with
TCL
then we have um mikai right make high 28
two dollar Super Chat redfall is delayed
if you believe it is yeah you don't you
don't have to play it at lunch if you
don't want that's for sure
and we have lydian Master member for
five months Lord silver 300 and Beyond
keep doing what you do because my wife
and I can't get enough every Sunday no
doubt much love appreciate that let's go
a lot of innuendos
then we have Corey Tidwell five dollar
Super Chat what's going on with these
games with black leads running like hot
ass
and then in the Dr Umar voice don't that
seem suspicious
screaming angry
then we have K Asante ten dollar Super
Chat man you guys are getting me in
trouble been watching the six hour epic
went on a beach day with my family now
I'm home and wifey and it's giving me
the side eye because I still can't put
on the put the phone down I don't even
listening all that time yo let's go all
this time absolutely then we have Mr
orange five dollars of attack appreciate
the realm thank you appreciate it all
right my wife just gave him for a second
time she's like you you bugging you
wallet um
then we have Nintendo Taco five dollars
yeah definitely finish too continue so
Cog Final Fantasy can bring back the
same summons and Sid but when Zelda does
it with three characters is a crime
against humanity don't don't take that
bait keep going guys
don't answer we have Max City
Entertainment two dollars Super Chat
can't support Final Fantasy 16 because
the game has no color trash oh my
goodness all right stand on it I guess
then we
then we have darn darn thread uh with
with 100 sex super chat
um six plus hours damn had to tell my
girl that she's playing with herself
tonight oh
I'm gonna tell you don't choose me over
your girl
wow
rated then we have Kuro Vader 10 super
chat really addict I am from Old Key now
what yes I don't know man we go what are
going with it
should be less mad at me and more about
yourself for naming yourself something I
couldn't now
he knows I'm joking then we got royal
Boyle 78 five dollar Super Chat my guys
congrats on 300 what a milestone always
love and respect to the Lord in the
building that's my name
then we got Brad word fight Lord bronze
put the crust to the top of Brad work
thank you so that's what's up he
recording everything outfits Luke then
we got gamer by choice 20 30 Super Chat
happy 300 and I hope for many many more
you're loved by your community and it is
evident by all the people that popped in
just to show love and support salute to
the Lord's great show thank you thank
you appreciate it brother now we got the
motor I got jumped it's the man who got
them horns
good God I got jumped oh my man you got
them hordes the two dollars happy 300
metoo game Ashley is a space racist I
don't know
20 Super Chat for men uh
I got it I got it man he said mandoah
twenty dollars
congratulations on 300. that's a Sparta
you have earned it and then some I'm
very happy with you guys such a unique
cast you got the homeless guy the king
the Super Chat reader and that that and
the one that has the loudest mic
Jesus thank you for your descriptions
yeah it's crazy
that we have Texas member for six months
Lord bronze Lord salute congratulations
love seeing the gaming Avengers or
something and all and all to celebrate
you for can the show hit eight hours no
it's not gonna happen yes
[Laughter]
then we have dip down anime
300 thank you for giving in a small
Channel like us to stand on a huge
platform with you we'll be forever
thankful here's to 300 thank you brother
let's do what you do appreciate that you
guys that's right there we go Lords
exactly then we got lost killer What's
that name Xbox series x01 10 super chat
Star Killer IOP is the gold standard of
podcast thank you brother appreciate it
then we got busting up Bucky once again
oh no no yeah
I can't be on my face out there like
that thank you appreciation
then we have a game bread ten dollars
you can chat I have to stop by for a
second say big congrats on 300. you guys
are fantastic you all bring energy like
no other here's to 400 and Beyond thank
you appreciate that man blessings
black Ronin three five seven two dollars
for the chat keep it going bust as many
as you can stop that stop it
then we have Kyle bite five dollar Super
Chat congrats lowers on 300 and
listening to you guys always brightens
my day love the banter and gaming takes
y'all deserve all the best here's to 300
more could you stop yeah they let you
know they try to keep us hostage yeah we
have Samuel West coat five dollars
that's Coke
five dollars for chat congrats on 300.
thanks for all the laughs and great
times looking forward to the next 300
rarely get to catch y'all live still
going seven hours strong
then we got Jesh two dollar Super Chat
tucked or untucked
[Applause]
you've got to go to bed
shirts here yeah I think most of them
was like tucked them into bed or
something
we have Nelson Rivera five dollar Super
Chat this is my first Super Chat ever I
had to send one for 300. congratulations
I think I went to school with you yeah
then we have Joe Repco AKA flame Vlog
next finest five dollars for chat sorry
I wasn't able to give you guys your
flowers due to my time constraints but
major congratulations to the 300
episodes love you guys likewise brother
thank you thank you
then we have Robert kellett two dollar
Super Chat podcast covers my entire
shift at work fam yes
happy to be here
then we have Jesus two dollar Super Chat
Barry balrog
I thought the government out there again
Savage keep going then we have chill
Spencer's over there chilly chill just
wanted to take a break from pushing
ready to fall out the door to
congratulate you guys on 300 episodes
here's the 300 most saluted show that's
my chill expensive appreciate you chill
yeah that was really expenses alias
then we have Nova 30m3 to the 2.20 Super
Chat happy 300 uh Lords amazing
Milestone on to 400 thank you appreciate
that all right then I gotta rolled back
a little bit chill oh my God that's the
slow one this is crazy right we got uh
slim Ryan [__] up
I'm trying to find a first party game we
can put out in 2023 but I wanted to make
an offer to make this a more PlayStation
Centric podcast how much yeah we'll take
a bag I don't care that's a that's a
king
oh slim Ryan said uh how much would it
take for us to do a PlayStation podcast
for us to become more PlayStation
Centric okay what would it take what
would it take 600k
because I gotta split it I gotta split
it so 600k equals enough for us thank
you make it eight an even number for all
of us then we'll talk about you in a
more positive light or we can show The
Narrative now okay I think it's the same
way that you try to pay off those other
guys with the FTC I want money
and then we have rated blade remember
for 25 months Lord bronze remember
Bethesda had four games in Development
Across Xbox and Playstation 5. so it was
too late so was it too late to change
development process two of the four just
saying the Falcon uh Vulcan versus dx12
um
then we have sagging nut sack
10 pound Super Chat congrats on making
it to 300 from the get from The Gambia
Lord please Lord please riddle me this
why are Gamers okay with Nintendo
releasing a 30 FPS game but when Sony
and Microsoft did it everyone is
freaking out Nintendo's machine cannot
do 60 with any sort of regularity
casar is three dollars for chat have a
good night Lords yes a good night to you
as well I appreciate well we got four
left keep going before they do again
stop calling it out we got a picture
that question that we have King is
overrated two dollars of a chat just to
keep the Super Chat train rolling
now we have Italian clowns two dollars
Super Chat oh hell the king the king is
never wrong oh you said this already
yeah
we have hargit to these two live Super
Chat still need to discuss that at tears
of the Kingdom trailer yes all right be
good
think we could realistically expect for
the game will this title push gaming
forward in any way do you think that
Nintendo is hiding any trips up tricks
up their sleep
I think it'll take the foundation that I
wanted to see what breath of the wild
did sprinkle what I had issues with it
and put a little bit more of that
Foundation of Zelda back into it and
push Zelda forward and maybe a little
bit of that kind of genre for it like we
saw with like ginsha impact uh but
that's all I'm really gonna say in that
because we're almost eight hours in so
uh yeah that's that's mine okay so yeah
it's going to be iterative uh it is
they're taking a foundation and gonna
build upon it and we've already seen all
the crazy stuff you could do and it
seems like with this last trailer which
I did not watch I heard that uh kind of
feels like it's they're adding the stuff
that attic wanted so I'm excited for it
I don't know if it's gonna be the moment
that breath of the wild was but I think
it's going to be great no doubt okay
I could see it I could see a good game
of the year it looks phenomenal much
better than the first uh trailer that I
saw it was just a Sandbox demo but yeah
it looked really good okay I don't have
too much negative to say about it we
just gotta see uh I'm still going
Saturday for Final Fantasy 16 though oh
and we got you know I got sold two
dollar Super Chat congrats on 300 Epps
this is the way all right we just did it
300.
we did it salute and the super chats we
love y'all I love my brothers love y'all
and we gotta get some rest
attic cakes yeah so my brothers love
this community thank you guys so much
thank you this mistake sir King I want
to go last okay okay I I just want to
say um
I I love you guys
um and it's just a humbling thing you
see all those diverse individuals come
out people that don't mess with each
other
you know uh showed up showed out and and
was present just just to just say what's
up to us I want to give a huge shout out
to math
I mean I mean it's good to be first
right and it's good to be sending a
little cute he was saying this in the
background yeah and he was doing
whatever he was doing for the day or
whatever and he still got up and he
still came in here
um you don't know how you touch anybody
pause you don't know what effects that
you have on individuals and somebody put
in a Super Chat
okay
they don't do it just for sure they do
it when the cameras is not on yeah I
caught that you know
um shout out um to fame and baron I was
just talking to Baron about whatever it
was at Pax and it was just you know big
homie talking a little homie thing
um trying to you know I don't I don't
care I want you to win I want you to win
I want you every day you wake up I want
you to win every day that you you think
about podcasting I want you to win and
I'm just talking to him I didn't know
what effect that had because I was just
trying you know just to reach
um it's just humbling you know sometimes
I I need to see things yes and
because if you don't think that we get
down or we get you know as precious in
life on our back it is and it's
everybody in this community have
different things
um
Chris Cornell
um that that touched me so much man yeah
um when you bet your dialysis it's it's
things man so anytime you feel like you
want to quit or you want to stop or you
just don't want to push forward there's
other things for you to push forward
today we got a new grandkid that's in
our life and
um
I'm just humbled by today yeah today is
one of the moments and I'm glad we get a
chance to celebrate with those who who
made us yes it was it was amazing um
attic you want something to say yeah you
know first off I want to say I
appreciate it for coming through we had
a lot of people in here it's just very
successful uh 300th episode uh you know
we're gonna push more and more going
forward and you know I appreciate it for
coming through uh after the podcast I am
going to send you to my uh Xbox content
of Halo by doing these things yeah so
definitely go there and check that out
but I'm going to bed like the moment
this is over I I'm good so we have a few
more Kevin yeah we have a few more that
came in but again like I said I love
y'all this is amazing this is absolutely
amazing we appreciate you guys and we
just gonna keep as as we uh outed
ourselves a little bit earlier we will
be going we are pivoting away from E3
this year and we're gonna be trying to
do what we normally do at pax's and
we're going to Pax West this year so
yeah sure it should be cool should be
fun
um let me see we have THX 1138 two
dollar Super Chat Zelda tiers of the
frame rates yeah yeah let's promote that
let's talk about that
here we have Lancelot C five dollars
from chat you found these guys through
watching Cog and Maddie's podcast at the
end of last year YouTube algorithm
recommended you all and I love y'all
thank you appreciate it that's love
thank you awesome love is it a kingdom
is a solid 30 I'm gonna pass out
of Taco just cause he ain't like that
that's funny girl yeah then we got my
brother Lord kaibotsu IOP five dollar
Super Chat love you bro love you bros
happy number 300 but damn you for this
week's timestamp
apologies apologies in advance
sorry and we love you but we are sorry
for what we did to you today this is one
this is good guys please that we have
Nintendo Taco five dollars I don't know
who needs to hear this but redfall would
have gotten better buried in forgotten
by Zelda at 20 FPS even if it launched
at 120 FPS keep crying Jesus Christ of
the frame rate let's go yeah let's
finish it off with sagging nuts
I found Super Chat good night Lord my
wife is screaming at me so I have to go
to bed good night
everybody enjoy 300 we did that we did
it fish peace
[Music]
thank you